Die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.
Ich bin in Düsseldorf geboren, wohne aber leider in Leischlingen und bin schon immer hingefallen, ich bin schon immer Fertig-Jahr-Vertula-Fan. Ich war in der Fertig-Liga, genauso auf Akka, in Bad Thunlew und und und, heute wünsche ich auch noch Vertula, dass wir aufsteigen. Hurra, hurra, die Vertula ist da. Hier regiert einer, Vertula ist sonst keiner.
Alles zur Zweiten Bundesliga.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, eine Schlusskonferenz zur Zweiten Fußball Bundesliga und ihr lebt nicht in einer Parallelwelt, liebe Hörer. Es ist tatsächlich soweit. Der Rasenfunk macht was zum Fußball-Unterhaus, wie man so unschön sagt. Ich möchte zusammen mit ein paar Gästen auf die Hinrunde der Zweiten Bundesliga zurückblicken, die so freundlich war, tatsächlich auch eine Hinrunde jetzt schon abgeschlossen zu haben. Das heißt, ich muss nicht ständig Wortkombination verwenden, wie in der Schlusskonferenz Nummer 100, die gestern aufgezeichnet wurde, von einer noch nicht abgeschlossenen Hinrunde, von einem fast Herbstmeister. Das alles gibt es in der zweiten Liga nicht. Da ist man Realer, da ist man Straighter. Und da hat man jetzt schon einen Herbstmeister. Über den wollen wir sprechen und über alle anderen 17 Vereine. Und ich habe dafür ein Portfolio an Gästen mir zusammengeknausert, wie es reichhaltiger und wertvoller nicht sein könnte. Und zwar zum einen Desirée Wolff, VfB-Stuttgart-Fan. Ihr kennt sie von Meinsportradio, ihr kennt sie auch aus dem Rasenfunk. Desirée, sehr, sehr schön, dass du mit dabei bist.
Ja, der VfB gehört ja zum, ist der einzige Verein der zweiten Liga, dem die Ehre zuteil wurde, in dieser Hinrunde schon mal Teil einer Rasenfunksendung zu sein. Ich habe einen Kurzpass aufgenommen, damals nach diesem Heimspiel gegen Heidenheim, eins zu zwei verloren, und Joris Luhukai wart Geschichte beim VfB. Am vierten Spieltag war das Ganze, und das wollte ich mir dann doch irgendwie erklären lassen, was da so schief gelaufen ist. Und es war ehrlich gesagt für den ganz neutralen vielleicht erheiternd, aber auch einigermaßen erschütternd zu sehen, wie wenig gesteuert alles sich anließ, was schon quasi direkt nach dem Abstieg passierte. Also dass dann eben ein Vorstandsmitglied Sport, also Jan Schindlmeiser, installiert wird, der offenbar mit den Vorstellungen des aktuell verpflichteten Trainers Joris Luhukai nicht so wirklich übereinkommt. Und dann gab es eben diesen Cut, zwei Spiele unter Olaf Jansen und dann Hannes Wolff. Und da ging auch so ein bisschen ein Ruck durch die Berichterstattung, denn das war ein junger Nachwuchstrainer von Borussia Dortmund. Und wenn wir irgendwas gelernt haben aus den letzten Jahren Fußball, dann bedeutet es, junge Nachwuchstrainer sind der heiße Scheiß. Da kann man quasi nicht daneben liegen. Und man hat dann immer schon die Tuchels und Klops in Version 2.0 vor Augen. Wie hat sich das denn jetzt angelassen? Was hat sich unter Hannes Wolff verändert? Und wie ist deine bisherige Bilanz für das, was er jetzt geschafft hat bei Stuttgart?
Man ist ja als Fan grundsätzlich zum einen leid geprüft, aber zum anderen auch immer hoffnungsvoll. Ich würde tatsächlich sagen, dass nach anfänglichem wirklich echt viel Sand im Getriebe da jetzt tatsächlich eine Besetzung sitzt, die fit ist, ihren Job zu machen. Damit meine ich explizit Jan Schindlmeiser, der neue Sportvorstand, der eine ganz ruhige Art hat im Hintergrund. Da gab es ja auch riesen Geschichten, als er kam, weil er jetzt jahrelang einfach nicht irgendwo in der Öffentlichkeit großartig wahrgenommen wurde. Er war ja früher bei Hoffenheim und war dann quasi als Berater tätig oder was weiß ich, keine Ahnung. Dann tauchte er auf einmal auf, hat aber seither einen sehr, sehr guten Job gemacht, wie ich finde. Schindlmeiser ist so auch in Fankreisen, glaube ich, ziemlich anerkannt und auch eine Art Hoffnungsträger. Diese Geschichte dann mit Luhukai, die du ansprichst, war natürlich krass, weil du kommst dann als hinterherbestellter Sportvorstand zu einem Verein mit einem Trainer, wo du sagst dann hinterher und das hat er auch ganz krass so formuliert. Und zwar war im ersten Besprech schon klar, dass das nichts wird so ungefähr. Wir haben es halt probiert, aber es hat nicht geklappt. Das ist natürlich alles irgendwie so schon sehr, wie der Komödien-Stadl reif. Aber ja, wir haben schon auch unsere Momente und das Trainerwechsel brauchen wir jetzt nicht drüber reden. Das ist ja auch auch klar, dass da in den letzten Jahren unglaublich viel einfach passiert ist bei VfB, gerade weil es eigentlich auch immer dann die Zusammenarbeit mit Sportdirektor mit Präsidium nicht funktioniert hat. Jetzt hat Findlmeiser Hannes Wolff installiert, von dem ich sehr viel halte. Die genannten Gründe waren zwar leicht polemisch genannt, aber sind tatsächlich auch zutreffend. Also Hannes Wolff ist ein junger Trainer. Und gerade von ihm hoffe ich, ob man es erwarten kann, weiß ich eben nicht, aber von ihm hoffe ich mir, dass er diesen, wie soll ich sagen, diesen Mentalitätsproblem im Kopf bei der Mannschaft einfach noch rauskriegt. Die ist jetzt wirklich schon von links auf rechts gekrempelt eigentlich durch den Abstieg mit Zukäufen und natürlich auch Spielerabgaben. Aber es ist immer noch so und Hannes Wolff benennt es aber auch und sagt halt auch nach so einem Würzburgspiel, alles, was Würzburg ausgezeichnet hat, hat uns gefehlt. Einfach an einen Mann rangehen, das Spiel annehmen, zwei Kampfstärke. Und sagt halt auch wörtlich, auf den Platz gehen und ein bisschen kicken wollen, geht halt nicht. Das ist kein genaues Zitat, aber so in die Richtung. Davon gibt es eben immer noch. Dieses Gehen ist immer noch in ein paar Spielern drin, die das dann tatsächlich nicht ernst nehmen, offensichtlich. Und unter anderem dazu beitragen, dann solche Spiele zu verlieren. Das ist halt super ärgerlich. Und im Moment hat Hannes Wolff Gott sei Dank den Rückhalt von allen Seiten, dass er da einfach weiter macht. Weil alles andere wäre aus meiner Betrachtung absurd. Ich würde ihn auch behalten wollen, wenn wir tatsächlich jetzt nicht aufsteigen im Sommer, weil einfach die Arbeit, die er macht, ist sehr, sehr gut. Und er ist halt authentisch. Er ist ehrlich. Und er verleitet einen eben dazu, die Hoffnung zu haben, dass er die Mannschaft auch mentalitätsmäßig hinkriegt. Weil sie ist natürlich die Mannschaft, ist nicht so geschlossen, wie es einige andere Mannschaften in der direkten Tabellenumgebung auch einfach sind, die viel mehr zusammengewachsen sind und aber halt auch viel mehr auf Teamgeist geschult sind sozusagen als unsere zum Teil Einzelkämpfer. Und das ist ein Problem und das nervt natürlich als Fan auch. Und trotzdem glaube ich, dass da jetzt zumindest die Rahmenbedingungen mit den Besetzungen Sportvorstand und Trainer, Präsident kann ich noch nicht einschätzen, geschaffen sind, dass da mal Ruhe reinkommt und dass da jetzt mal wirklich was entwickelt werden kann, dass auch diese Komponenten einfach noch irgendwie gemacht werden. Und also toi toi toi, bitte lieber Hannes Wolff in der Winterpause. Geh da mal ran an den Speck bei den Spielern.
Na ich denke, hat's vor. Wenn man sich die Spiele des VfB anguckt, jetzt in der Gesamtbilanz stehen da 32 Punkte bei 10 Siegen, 2 Unentschieden, 5 Niederlagen, 30 erzielte Tore, damit zweiterfolgreichste Offensive in dieser Fußballbundesliga, über die erfolgreichste haben wir mit Hannover schon gesprochen, und 21 gefangene Tore, dann ist das alles eine sehr solide Leistung und auch die Ergebnisse stimmen ja bis auf diese paar Ausreißerspiele. Und man geht jetzt eben mit einem schlechten Gefühl, vor allem durch dieses Auswärts 0 zu 3 bei den Kickers in Würzburg, geht man mit einem schlechteren Gefühl in die Winterpause, als es hätte sein müssen. Was mich aber vor allem überrascht ist, wie viele Schüsse Stuttgart tatsächlich pro Spiel aufs eigene Tor zulässt. Da sind nämlich derer 14 durchschnittlich. Und damit liegen sie auf Platz 6 in dieser Tabelle, wo man am liebsten dort liegen möchte, wo Hannover 96 liegt. Die lassen nämlich nur 10 Schüsse pro Spiel aufs Tor zu und sind damit Spitzenreiter in dieser Tabelle. Woran liegt denn das, dass man es defensiv nicht hinbekommt, den Gegner vom Tor weg zu halten, spielen, da die Spieler, bei denen du angedeutet hast, die lassen sich manchmal hängen, wenn es keine Showcase-Spiele sind, oder hat es vielleicht auch mit Abstimmungsproblemen in den Mannschaftsteilen zu tun? Woran liegt das?
Also zum einen ist die Abwehr tatsächlich, also die Offensive ist jetzt bei uns eigentlich, so nominell würdest du sagen, haben wir da nicht wirklich ein Problem. Und gerade mit den beiden Neueinkäufen jetzt von Schindlmeiser, mit denen er sich dann mit Luhukai auch noch komplett verscherzt hat, nämlich Takuma Asano und eben Carlos Mané, sind da jetzt wirklich zwei Spieler noch dazugekommen, die da vorne eigentlich, wo ich sage, das läuft jetzt irgendwie, das ist keine brennende Baustelle, was aber halt tatsächlich wirklich noch nicht steht. Und auch eben offensichtlich, das hat man mich an dem Würzburg-Spiel jetzt auch gesehen, auch eben keine Tiefe sozusagen hat, das ist die Abwehrreihe. Problem ist ganz klar, wir haben Timo Baumgartel, der ja im Gegensatz zum anderen Timo nicht den Verein verlassen hat, obwohl er nun unbestritten ein vielversprechender Nachwuchsabwehrspieler ist, sehr, sehr guter Innenverteidiger ist, aber eben auch noch jung ist. Timo Baumgartel, wenn der gespielt hat, lief das alles irgendwie klar. Wenn der nicht gespielt hat, ob nun verletzungsbedingt oder eben wie bei dem Würzburg-Spiel, wo er eben gesperrt war durch die rote Karte aus der Nachspielzeit vom Spiel zuvor, dann läuft da hinten halt alles wirklich schief, wie Kraut und Rüben. Die Abwehrreihe ist eben, du hast da Spieler, der eigentlich, also da ist ein Florian Klein, der eigentlich wissen müsste, wie es geht, der aber kaum noch spielt, der auch meiner Ansicht nach echt so ein bisschen, der hat, glaube ich, also würde ich ihm jetzt unterstellen, er möge mir verzeihen, wenn das nicht so ist, aber der, glaube ich, auch echt so ein bisschen ein Problem, sich da mit abzufinden, dass er jetzt bei einer Zweitligisten spielt und irgendwie eher als österreichischer Nationalspieler, also der, weiß ich nicht, also der ist, glaube ich, im Kopf nicht so ganz da, spielt dafür auch tatsächlich nicht oft genug, dafür, dass er jetzt nicht massiv verletzt war. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du Emiliano Insua, der wirklich alle Spiele gemacht hat, der ist der einzige, glaube ich, neben dem Torwart, der wirklich alle Minuten dahinrunde auf dem Platz stand. Insua ist im Prinzip zuverlässiger Spieler, zuverlässiger Außenspieler, wenn du dann noch Timo Baumgartel in der Innenverteidigung hast und den auch neu hinzugekommenen Benjamin Pavard, der aber halt gleicher Jahrgang ist wie Baumgartel, also die sind wirklich komplett auch gleicher Geburtsmonat. Dann hast du da halt zwei wirklich sehr junge Spiele in Innenverteidigung, dann klappt das aber immer noch. Also Baumgartel hat die Klasse dann immerhin noch, dann sowohl mit Pavard zusammen gut spielen zu können, als auch zum Beispiel Marcin Klaminski, der ja ganz lang gar nicht zum Einsatz kam, auch unter Luhokai komplett weg war, auch einer der Sommereinkäufe, die so ein bisschen Rätsel aufgeworfen hatten, warum hat man den jetzt geholt, der wirkt so ein bisschen starksig und so, also es ist nicht irgendwie der eleganteste Fußballspiel aller Zeiten, aber wenn Baumgartel da ist, dann kann er den auch irgendwie führen und dann funktioniert das auch. Wenn Baumgartel nicht da ist, gehen die Spiele auch meistens verloren. Und das ist natürlich eine Abhängigkeit von einem Abwehrspiel und dazu von einem sehr jungen Abwehrspiel, die unsäglich ist. Und auch Großkreuz hat da eben noch nicht wirklich Fuß fassen können, der ja theoretisch auch rechts hinten spielen könnte, wenn er nicht natürlich an andere Positionen eingesetzt wird. Und so hast du so irgendwie. Und dann muss ich noch, ich muss in diesem, weil ich mich furchtbar aufgeregt ein ganzes Spiel lang, dann hast du noch Spieler wie Toni Sundic übrig, die dann eben natürlich ersatzweise für Baumgartel in Würzburg spielen. Und wo du sagst, wirklich, ich kann es nicht verstehen. Es tut mir leid, ich will den armen Menschen nicht wissen. Der ist vielleicht ganz nett und alles, aber er kann halt alles, aber nicht Fußball spielen. Das tut mir leid. Also es ist wirklich so furchtbar. Und wenn du den dann reinschmeißen musst aus Mangel an Alternativen, keine Ahnung, und der dann halt auch fast im Alleingang dann also da durchaus das Tor des Gegners begünstigt, dann kommen solche Spiele zustande. Also es ist in der Abwehr muss eigentlich noch was passieren. Und es ist auch, also Hannes Wolff jetzt wirklich noch nicht gelungen da mit dem vorhandenen Personal wirklich eine totale Stabilität reinzubringen. Es hat in einigen Spielen wirklich gut geklappt. Da war das wirklich sehr schlüssig. Aber eben nicht in allen.
Ja danke, das hast du uns ja sehr detailliert aufgedröselt. Nach einem muss ich noch ganz gezielt fragen, was macht Christian Gentner? Schafft es Hannes Wolff, dass Christian Gentner sich an taktische Vorgaben hält? Oder läuft er weiter wild einfach über den Platz und die anderen müssen halt seine Lücken stopfen, die er hinterlässt?
Ich glaube, er wird schon so ein bisschen eingenordet. Das ist nicht das Ding. Christian Gentner ist ja auch einer von den vielen Spielern natürlich und auch als Kapitän irgendwo ganz wichtig. Mir tut er immer so ein bisschen Leid, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass er mit dieser Kapitänsrolle eigentlich überfordert ist oder halt.
Was gibt dir dieses Gefühl?
Ich habe das Gefühl, er könnte unbeschwerter spielen, wenn er einfach das nicht an der Backe hätte. Er macht das gut und hat natürlich seine Kapitänspflichten dann auch eben gegenüber der Presse und so weiter. Das ist mal so, mal so. Da gab es auch Dinge, wo ich sage, hätte ich es nicht unbedingt von mir gegeben, aber egal. Aber er ist irgendwie, ich denke mir immer, lachen im Hintergrund. Aber er ist immer wieder einfach, ja, ich kann, also bei Gentner checke ich das nicht ganz, ob das wirklich so gut ist oder ob es nicht einfach jemand anders machen sollte, dass er sich auf sein Spiel konzentrieren sollte. Ich meine, Gentner ist einer der Achse, Großkreuz, dann natürlich Lengerac und eben auch Gentner, praktisch die alten, erfahrenen Spieler, die gesagt haben, hey, wir bleiben, wir gucken, wir schaffen den Aufstieg wieder. Naja, ich weiß es nicht. Also ich würde ihm das Kapitänsamt gerne wegnehmen, nicht um ein Zeichen zu setzen, dass er das ganz schlecht gemacht hat, sondern einfach, wenn man denkt, wenn er einfach nur Fußball spielen müsste, wäre es vielleicht sogar noch unbeschwerter, das Ganze. Und dann kann er auch gerne mal in seine berühmten Ausflüge und dann nehmen wir das, das wäre mir dann egal.
So ein bisschen Lucio Leid ist das manchmal bei Christian Gentner. Wenn sich die Hörer noch an Lucio erinnern. So, das ist aktuell Tabellenplatz drei. Das heißt, wenn es so bleibt, dann spielt ihr die Relegation gegen den HSV. Und damit muss ich gleich die Frage stellen. Was glaubst du denn, würde im und mit dem Verein passieren, sollte das mit dem direkten Wiederausstieg nicht klappen? Weil ich glaube, das Aufstiegsszenario ist für alle relativ deutlich. Man hat diesen Makel in der Bilanz nur zu einem Makel werden lassen und ist dann wieder in einer, ist dann wieder in der ersten Liga und spielt halt dann weiter sein Ding mit einer, mit einer leicht wackeligen Abwehr in einem anderen Trainer. Und dann kann man machen und tun und gucken, dass man wieder drin bleibt in der ersten. Aber interessanter finde ich ja die Frage, was würde denn im Fall eines Nicht-Aufstiegs passieren?
Also zum einen, na es gibt ein paar Ecken, die es da glaube ich zu betrachten gibt. Zum einen hat ja Jan Schindlmeiser auch in dieser Luhuka-Schindlmeiser-Auseinandersetzung aufgeworfen, dass er eben die Verantwortung hat, natürlich auch in die Zukunft zu blicken und jetzt bei allem Aufstiegsdruck nicht nur ein Kader für praktisch eine Saison planen möchte, sondern er schaut schon weiter und möchte natürlich schon junge Spieler ranziehen, mit denen er auch in den Folgejahren dann weiterarbeitet, idealerweise in der ersten Liga. Also der hat da durchaus einen Blick dafür, dass es jetzt nicht nur einfach heißt, okay, alle Mann jetzt hier auf Aufstieg und dann schauen wir mal. Da habe ich jetzt kein schlechtes Gefühl. Wolfgang Dietrich hat, also unser Präsident, der ja vorhin schon erwähnt wurde, hat ein Interview gegeben, was ganz vielen in ganz verschiedene falsche Hälse oder vielleicht auch in den richtigen Hals gekommen ist. Das kann ich nicht einschätzen, aber er würde halt im Prinzip auch danach gefragt, was ist denn, wenn der VfB jetzt nicht aufsteigt. Und er hat halt als, ich würde mal so sagen, in der schwäbischen Geschäftsmann Attitüde und ich kriege das schon hin. Und wir haben finanzkräftige Sponsoren, die haben wir ja nun mal auch. Und die haben sich auch längerfristig zum VfB bekannt. Hat er halt so sinngemäß gesagt, aber er hat es eben nicht so formuliert, wie es dann in der Presse stand. Wenn wir es noch ein Jahr in der zweiten Liga bleiben, dann kriegen wir das auch noch hin, irgendwie finanziell. Und das würde natürlich sofort umgedreht, nach dem Motto, Wolle Dietrich sagt, naja, ist wurscht, Aufstieg ist nicht so wichtig, so ungefähr, was natürlich Quatsch ist. Aber ich glaube tatsächlich, dass der Verein daran immer noch nicht zusammenbrechen würde, wenn das passieren würde. Es scheint finanziell wirklich so zu sein, dass die großen Sponsoren, also wirklich im extremen Kontrast zu Union Berlin, was mir sehr viel sympathischer ist als Modell der Finanzierung, dass eben Mercedes hat sich langfristig dazu bekannt, dann ist Porsche auch noch eingestiegen. Also die Top-Sponsoren aus dem Stuttgarter Raum praktisch, die sind da. Und die hat man auch gebunden. Man sagt allgemein, man würde das wahrscheinlich noch aushalten, noch ein Jahr in der zweiten Liga. Aber das darf halt nicht die Marschrichtung sein. Und da sind wir wieder bei der Mannschaft. Ich hatte echt so ein bisschen das Gefühl, obwohl das meinte ich mit falschem Hals, oder in den falschen Hals kriegen, ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass dann nach so einer Aussage vom Präsidenten, ja wir kriegen das auch hin, wenn es jetzt irgendwie hart auf hart kommt, dass dann ein paar schon wieder denken, ja okay, ist ja nicht so schlimm. Also, weißt du, aus meiner Sicht muss dieser Aufstieg unbedingt sein. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die Spieler das bewusst so denken, aber es ist halt immer noch zu viel Schlendrian da drin, und zu viel, ah ja, Würzburg, das kriegen wir schon hin. Und ich hatte wirklich große Bedenken vor diesem Würzburg-Spiel, weil ich genau so was befürchtet habe, dass sie dann so schlecht gespielt haben, wie sie gespielt haben, das konnte ich mir in meinen Künstenträumen leider nicht vorstellen. Das war echt eine Strafe dieses Spiels.
Okay, das heißt, wir halten fest, die Winning-Culture, die wir schon in der ersten Liga mehrfach im Rasenfunk vermisst haben, beim VfB Stuttgart, die hat sich immer noch nicht etabliert. Da fehlt so tatsächlich so eine Unternehmenskultur, würde ich sagen, die die Leistung fördert und fordert. Und wir halten fest, vermutlich hat Sebastian eine stille Träne verdrückt, er mit seinen 370 Sponsoren und du erzählst uns von Porsche und Mercedes-Benz.
Ich checke mal, was für Autohersteller es in Berlin so gibt.
Aber Desirée, eine Frage vielleicht noch. Was hast du denn für ein Gefühl, wie es mit den Fans diese Saison läuft? Es gibt ja in Stuttgart auch mal schnell Unmut zwischendurch. Haben die Fans denn die zweite Liga schon angenommen?
Also darüber muss man gar nicht diskutieren. Stuttgart hat einen Schnitt von fast 50.000 bei Heimspielen. Das war der Erstligaschnitt ungefähr, sogar ein Ticken mehr glaube ich manchmal noch. Und der wurde runter korrigiert von den Erwartungen her. Also man musste ja dann vor der Saison irgendwelche Prognosen auch vor Etat und so weiter irgendwie stellen. Man hat glaube ich mit 30 plus minus gerechnet. Wir sind jetzt bei fast 50. Den Schnitt drückt noch runter, dass wir tatsächlich auch von den Spielzeiten extrem begünstigt sind und halt auch immer irgendwie Spiele haben an Terminen, wo dann doch weniger Leute ins Stadion kommen können. Aber die Fans stehen unglaublich hinter dem Verein. Also es ist wirklich inzwischen so, dass ich sage, es gibt außer vielleicht ein, zwei Positionen im Kader, die man noch verbessern müsste, gibt es wirklich absolut nichts, was dem Aufstieg im Weg steht, also von der Unterstützung her. Die Fans sind wirklich, die fahren mit auf die Auswärtsspiele und da gibt es auch die Romantik in Anführungszeichen, wie Klaas vorhin schon ein bisschen angedeutet hat, die auch gesagt haben, hey, mal andere Grounds hier, dann sind wir halt mal in Sandhausen, dann sind wir halt mal in Heidenheim oder jetzt eben in Würzburg, die machen da ein super Support, wenn da halt ein paar Tausende als Gästefans dabei sind und wenn du im eigenen Stadion guckst, ist es wirklich so, dass man hinter der Mannschaft steht und also ich überhaupt nicht das Gefühl habe, dass die Fanszene da permanent nur rumgrittelt, nur wenn du halt dann, also das Dresden-Spiel war so ein Punkt, wo es extrem hart wurde in der Kritik, auch der Fans, Ich bin nicht der Fan, aber das kannst du auch nicht anders erwarten. Das war auch berechtigt. Jetzt ist es eben so, dass vor der Winterpause auch wieder ein extremer Dämpfer durch das Würzburg-Spiel kam. Die Leute sind echt ziemlich frustriert. Wobei ich sage, ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich, aus angesprochenen Mentalitätsproblemen, die ich den Spielern unterstelle, einfach mal heraus. Das ist noch wahrscheinlicher, dass wir aufsteigen, wenn wir jetzt auf Platz 3 sind und die praktischen Ziele vor Augen haben, was sie jagen können, als wenn die jetzt wirklich hier hochdekorierter Herbstmeister geworden wären. Dann hätten sie sich wieder zurückgelehnt und hätten gedacht, hey, super, wir sind alle toll. Und dann wäre nämlich der Bruchhalter gleich wieder in den ersten Spielen der Rückgrunde gekommen. Also der Fansupport, wie gesagt, abgesehen von solchen extremen nach unten Peaks, aber bei Niederlagen von 05 und so, kann man das, glaube ich, nachvollziehen, ist hervorragend und der ist auch danach dann immer hervorragend gewesen.
Ich hätte auch noch eine Frage zu Stuttgart. Und zwar, wie sieht denn das aus? Simon Terode habt ihr geholt von Bochum, hat die Hinrunde gespielt, aber der hatte in irgendeinem Pressespräch gesagt, dass er gerne in die zweite Reihe rückt, wenn Daniel Ginczek wieder fit ist. Und mich hat das so ein bisschen irritiert, weil Ginczek hat ja nun kaum oder gar nicht spielen können. Und Terode 11 Tore geschossen, was ja irgendwie eigentlich klarmacht. Ich bin hier der Platzhörscher.
Das hab ich tatsächlich nicht mitgekriegt, überrascht mich jetzt auch. Ist aber dadurch erklärbar, dass Ginczek ist einer der Spiele, das ist so leid, das es mir tut. Und mir tut jeder Einzelne von den Spielern leid, aber es ist so ein bisschen Badstuberkategorie. Wenn die spielen, sind das Top-Bundesliga-Spiele. Aber sie sind halt verletzt und zwar andauernd. Also das ist, da gehört übrigens auch in Ansätzen Daniel Di Daby noch dazu, den wir an Wolfsburg verkauft haben, wo er jetzt auch auf der Bank sitzt, weil er verletzt ist, beziehungsweise er treibt sich bei uns im Reha-Zentrum rum. Gintec ist so ein Spieler, der einfach unglaubliche Verletzungen hatte, immer wieder. Wenn er aber gespielt hat, war er immer ganz wichtig. Und es ist ein toller Sturm. Also der hätte für mich, wenn er sich nicht wieder verletzt hätte in der letzten Saison, der hätte für mich fast eigentlich schon Nationalmannschaftspotenzial gehabt, weil das echt so ein Tank vorne drinnen ist, der ganz großartig als spielender Stürmer auch noch mehr als Terotte. Also Terotte ist ja wirklich ein Strafraumstürmer, der eigentlich bedient werden muss, der sich jetzt die Bälle nicht von hinten holt. Gensteck ist noch ein bisschen mehr mitspielend und ist ein Typ, der also wirklich, der hat ja vor zwei Jahren, wenn ich mich recht zurück erinnere, ich hoffe, ich bringe es nicht durcheinander, massiv dazu beigetragen, dass er in den letzten paar Spielen dann wieder gesund war, wieder gespielt hat und den Aufstieg, aber den Nicht-Abstieg damals noch dann klar gemacht hat. Und immer, wenn er spielt, ist er praktisch ein Wahnsinns-Fund für das Stuttgarter Spiel gewesen. Und jetzt hat er ja bisher wirklich nur ganz, ganz wenig gespielt und hat da dann auch tatsächlich eine Torchance auf dem Fuß, die er nicht verwerten konnte. Das war dann alles ganz tragisch, wo ich sage, ja meine Güte, ist doch klar. Aber ich denke, das ist, Terotte ist so ein Typ, der leider sicher nicht unter diesem Mentalitätsding ist, was ich angesprochen habe. Das war natürlich ein Top-Einkauf auch als Torschützenkönig von Bochum kommend, der Zweiten Bundesliga. Und Terotte ist einfach so ein Teamspieler, der sich total einbringt, der ist von Anfang an tatsächlich nur positiv aufgefallen, mit irgendwelchen Bemerkungen, von wegen ich finde es jetzt cool beim VfB Stuttgart, ich habe total Bock drauf, weil und so weiter. Also er ist ein unglaublich mannschaftsinniger Spieler und ich denke, dass das so ein bisschen fast schon mannschaftsintern motivierend an Daniel Ginczek gerichtet ist, so nach dem Motto, hey, jetzt komm mal hier, du wirst da nicht auf der Bank sitzen nur und ich werde die ganze Zeit spielen. Anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären. Ich habe es leider nicht gehört jetzt, also mir fehlt da ein bisschen der Tonfall jetzt dazu, aber das würde ich sagen, also Terode ist einfach ein mega sympathischer und mannschaftsinniger Typ und würde, glaube ich, anerkennen, wenn Ginczek zurückkäme, lauter Konjunktive, und seine alte Klasse wieder erreichen würde, dass die dann zumindest abwechselnd spielen. Habe ich da jetzt irgendwas beantwortet?
Ja, eigentlich schon, weil bei Terode hat mich immer gewundert, dass er halt ein sehr guter Zweitliga-Stürmer ist, aber irgendwie nie in der Bundesliga gelandet ist, und deswegen passt es wahrscheinlich dazu.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass Sebastian, also wer Textilvergehen hört, weiß, dass er ist kein großer Freund von Terode. Kann man dazu sagen, vielleicht. Und ich glaube, wir können jetzt nicht über den VfB Stuttgart reden, ohne einmal das Wort Großkreuz benutzt zu haben.
Habe ich doch vorhin schon.
Und dann habe ich den überhört, Entschuldigung.
Na gut, es war ein Halbsatz, glaube ich. Also es war jetzt nicht wirklich minutenfüllend.
Ich finde es halt irgendwie interessant, dass er so, er ist ja dieser social media-affine Typ irgendwie, der mit seinem Fisch da immer Kommentare abgibt, wie er dann das doch irgendwie prägt. Und ich glaube, so den traditionellen romantischen Fußballfans ja irgendwie immer so was hinwirft, was den meisten, glaube ich, gefällt oder täuscht das.
Ne, ich meine, Großkreutz hat seine Tochter gekriegt und hat am Tag drauf. Also ich glaube, der VfB Stuttgart, der Twitter-Account hat ihm dann noch irgendwie geschickt, ach ja, übrigens hier, Kevin, ist das Formular eben für eine Mitgliedschaft. Und dann hat er am nächsten Tag natürlich bei beiden Vereinen, also auch in Dortmund, aber eben auch beim VfB, seine Leonie gleich als Mitglied angemeldet und hat das natürlich getwittert. Ich meine, was willst du machen? Das ist Social Media, technisch, also brauchst du keinen Berater mehr. Die Fans stehen hinter ihm und er hat im Moment leider einfach nicht spielerisch die Form. Das ärgert ihn auch mit Sicherheit selber. Und Hannes Wolff ist da auch durchaus nicht jetzt irgendwie aus alter Verbundenheit, weil die sich halt jetzt mal früher in Dortmund vielleicht auch natürlich schon kennengelernt haben. Es ist nicht so drauf, dass er sagt, nee, Großkreutz muss ich mal spielen, sondern er sagt, nee, reicht nicht. Entsprechend hat er jetzt auch nicht so unendlich Spielminuten, war natürlich auch mal verletzt, aber er ist tatsächlich momentan eben, das hatte ich ja vorhin schon so ein bisschen angedeutet, nicht die erste Wahl, weder hinten rechts noch auf einer anderen Position. Und das nagt so ein bisschen an ihm. Auf der anderen Seite ist er aber halt so ein Typ, der der Mentalität reinbringt, der halt dieses Kampf-Sau-Gen irgendwie hat und der für die Mannschaft mit Sicherheit ganz wichtig ist. Also ich würde mir wünschen, dass er halt auch fußballerisch da so ein bisschen zu leckt jetzt für die Rückrunde, weil wir brauchen ihn einfach. Also das ist, das sind zu viele Leute. Ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt sehr gespannt, wer da noch abgegeben wird. Weil also soweit ich das mitgekriegt habe, hat Schindlmeiser gesagt, es wird Zu- und Abgänge geben in der Winterpause. Und es gibt schon so ein paar Spieler, von denen ich vermute, dass die tatsächlich keine Rolle mehr spielen werden in der Rückrunde. Und dann wird es halt spannend, wer kommt noch dazu. Frage von mir an den Rest, besonders an dich, Max. Wir haben jetzt Julian Green gekauft vom FC Bayern. Was soll ich denn davon halten, bitte schön?
Ja, dass ihr euch einen Nachwuchsspieler vom FC Bayern geholt habt, der sicher schon einiges gezeigt hat. Aber für einen FC Bayern hat es nicht gereicht. Der ist schon rechts spielstark, auch rechts spielfreudig, braucht allerdings manchmal einen Schuss zu vielen, um ein Tor zu machen, wenn es nach mir geht. Aber war ja zwischendurch auch der totale Hype-Spieler. Vor allem auf unserer USA-Tour, da hat das natürlich auch vom Storytelling her perfekt gepasst. Sorry, wenn ich mal wieder einen Begriff aus meiner Berufswelt hier reinwerfe. Da hat er, ich glaube, drei Absteibertore gemacht und wurde danach gefeiert, als wären das sämtliche Fallrückzieher gewesen. Also es ist definitiv kein schlechter Spieler und hat vor allem eine Grundschnelligkeit und ist technisch sehr, sehr stark. Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, das soll jetzt nicht despektierlich klingen, sondern ich glaube, dass so ein Spieler ganz, ganz viele Mannschaften in der zweiten Liga helfen würde, weil das halt einfach so Grundeigenschaften sind, die man in der zweiten Liga nicht immer vorne im Sturmbereich hat und gerade bei dem Ball, den Hannes Wolff spielen lässt, lässt sich das auf dem Papier ganz gut an. Kannst du dich, glaube ich, darauf freuen?
Ja, ich hoffe. Also das Argument, bei Bayern hat er sich nicht durchgesetzt, kann ja nicht mehr zählen, weil wir sind kein Bayern-Verfolger.
Im weitesten Sinne schon. Ihr seid gerade auf Platz 20 der Bayern-Volge.
Prima. Also nur noch eine Frage von Minuten eigentlich. Aber ich kann es eben auch nur nicht einschätzen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie er sich da anlässt. Zumindest ist das ein Einkauf, der eben vor der Winterpause jetzt schon klar gemacht wurde. Das heißt, der ist wirklich ab gestern da irgendwie schon vor Ort, beziehungsweise natürlich nach dem Urlaub, dann nach Weihnachten und kann dann die Vorbereitung komplett mitmachen. Das ist zumindest schon mal ein Umstand, der mich irgendwie beruhigt, aber den kann ich halt noch nicht einschätzen. Ich persönlich vermute, dass Julian Green tatsächlich ein Ersatz für Maxime sein wird, der ja von jedem Report immer hochgelobt wird, als der Superspitzen-Spieler in der zweiten Liga, der aber halt unter wie viel? Sechs, sieben Trainer müssten jetzt inzwischen an ihm vorübergegangen sein. Und der hat sich immer noch nicht als Stammkraft etabliert. Also das ist auch so, das ist so klassisch verschenkte Begabung irgendwie bei ihm.
Aber gut. Man muss halt genau beobachten, Julian Green hat natürlich so als Makel an sich, das wird dir ja jetzt auch nicht neu sein, diesen Ausflug zum HSV, der sportlich und auch von den Zwischentönen her merkwürdig war und man nicht so genau einordnen konnte. Warum hat er da keine Rolle gespielt? Warum hat er sich da auch so verhalten, wie er sich verhalten hat? Wurde dann degradiert zur zweiten Mannschaft geschickt. Da weiß man nicht so ganz genau. Denkt das damit zusammen, dass Julian Green eigentlich von sich denkt, er ist im ersten Kader des FC Bayern und hat keine Lust auf so etwas wie den Hamburger SV oder gab es da noch andere Dinge? Ich denke, das sind wahrscheinlich so Mitgründe für Zweifel, die es an dem Transfer geben kann. Aber rein vom Sportlichen her müsste es eigentlich eine Verstärkung sein. Aber darf ich mal ganz kurz einhaken? Den habt ihr gekauft oder ausgeliehen?
Gekauft, tatsächlich. Also als die ersten Gerüchte aufkamen, also das war am selben Tag, also schindelweise macht das offensichtlich hinter verschlossenen Türen. Gott sei Dank, also diese Maulwürfe, die es da früher gab, gibt es halt nicht mehr. Da hatten auch alle darüber spekuliert, naja, Bayern verleiht den jetzt anderthalb Jahre oder so und dann, das wäre doch eigentlich das passendste. Aber nein, der hat einen Vertrag bis 2019 bei uns und ist gekauft. Für 500.000? Ich weiß es gar nicht sicher. Ich glaube.
Aber das ist dann ja tatsächlich eher so in Richtung Ersatz für irgendjemanden, weil, wie du schon sagtest, die Offensive ist ja eigentlich nicht die Baustelle, wo man zwingend jetzt was hineinschütten müsste.
Ja, also ich bin bei Maxim, ich weiß es nicht. Das ist eine Vermutung, das haben andere auch schon geäußert. Das könnte ich nachvollziehen, aber man weiß es nicht, was die da machen. Tatsächlich, ja, also ich hätte jetzt gesagt, im Angriff ist nicht die allererste Baustelle, aber ich glaube eben, auch weil das so früh jetzt durch war, dass das ein ziemlich früh angelegter Kauf jetzt auch war. Also der hat sich ja nicht diese Woche entschieden, den Julian Green zu kaufen und ist dann schnell durchgeboxt. Insofern ist das, glaube ich, schon ein Ergebnis einer längeren Beobachtung der Hinrunde und dann würde alles dafür sprechen, dass ein anderer Spieler dafür abgegeben wird.
Ja.
Und das werden nicht Asano und Mane sein, normalerweise.
Wir werden es genau beobachten. Ich finde, wir haben damit sehr viel zum VfB Stuttgart gelernt und jetzt kommen wir endlich zu einem der größten Mysterien für mich. Jetzt könnt ihr mir nämlich erklären, wie um alles in der Welt der erste FC Heidenheim, der 2007 noch in der Oberliga Süd, glaube ich, gespielt hat, der den drittjüngsten Kader der Liga hat. Ja, es war die Oberliga Baden-Württemberg. Wie dieser Verein auf einen, so wie ich es mitverfolgt habe, vollkommen verdienten vierten Tabellenplatz nach 17 Spielen kommen konnte. 25 zu 14 Tore, 29 Punkte, das heißt drei Punkte Rückstand auf Hannover und auf Stuttgart, über die wir gerade schon gesprochen haben. Das ist nicht allzu viel. Eine sensationelle Heimbilanz. Platz zwei in der Heimtabelle mit 15 zu 4 Toren. Das heißt, es ist nicht ganz so einfach in Heidenheim zu treffen. Das mussten schon viele Mannschaften erfahren. Und ich habe mehrfach tolles über Heidenheim gehört und was ich gesehen habe, hat mir auch gefallen. Unter anderem habe ich von jemandem, auf dessen Meinung ich sehr viel gebe, gehört, der ist Bielefeld-Fan und hat gesagt, das war die best organisierte Mannschaft, die er jemals in Bielefeld gesehen hätte. Ausgerechnet dieses Spiel hat Heidenheim allerdings verloren. Also vielleicht kann man Mike anfangen, dessen Stimme mir einfach jetzt gefehlt hat, auch in den letzten Minuten. Was macht denn Heidenheim so stark? Wie kommt das zustande? Also wenn wir das jetzt ganz kurz halten wollen, dann sage ich Mark Schnatterer und Frank Schmidt, was für mich die beiden Eckpfeiler auch gerade in der Außenwirkung sind. Also ich habe das Spiel meines Vereins in Heidenheim live gesehen und ja, da kann ich gar nicht so furchtbar viel zu sagen, weil wir waren einfach an dem Tag nicht so richtig gut, hatten dann auch ein frühes Verletzungspech eines zentralen defensiven Mittelfeldspielers und dementsprechend hat Heidenheim das echt ganz souverän runtergespielt, ohne sich groß verausgaben zu müssen. Aber frag doch mal den geneigten Rasenfunk-Zuhörer, nenne mir fünf Heidenheim-Spieler. Ich glaube, der werden die meisten Schwierigkeiten kriegen und außer Mark Schnatterer wird da vielen wenig zu einfallen. Der ist halt, ich glaube, seit dieser Oberligasaison dabei, beherrscht da auch das Spiel, ist im Mittelfeld zentraler Dreh- und Angelpunkt, ständige Anspielstation, noch dazu als Mittelfeldspieler ungemein vorgefährlich und rockt das da mehr oder weniger im Alleingang. Also wenn du jetzt alleine mal, auch wenn man auf Kickernoten nicht immer so viel geben soll, aber als Feldspieler, der 17 Pflichtspiele oder 17 Liga-Spiele gemacht hat, einen Notenschnitt von 2,56, das wirst du selten finden. Also das ist schon eine Ausnahmestellung und noch dazu eben, wie gesagt, turgefährlich und macht da die ganzen Standards. Also der ist für mich das Hauptargument für Heidenheim. Und wenn wir vorhin bei dem Stichwort Hannover und Stuttgart immer über Kader-Tiefe und so gesprochen haben, lass den mal verletzt ausfallen für drei, vier Monate, dann kriegt Heidenheim auch Probleme. Also nicht, dass sie deswegen da her herabsteigen würden, aber da ist eben nicht so furchtbar viel Kader-Tiefe da, dass du so einen Spieler, wenn er denn mal ausfallen würde, auch ersetzen könntest. Und um den zweiten Namen jetzt noch eben zu ergänzen, Frank Schmidt als Trainer, ich weiß nicht, wer diesen Trainer-Film gesehen hat, da gab es ja einige Personen, die nicht so ganz gut wegkamen, er ist da in meiner Sicht ganz hervorragend weggekommen und glaube ich, einer der Punkte, warum das in Heidenheim so wunderbar funktioniert. Und ja, da warte ich eigentlich jedes Mal drauf, wenn bei irgendeinem namhafteren Erstligisten der Trainerwechsel mal wieder erfolgt, dass dann zumindest der Name Frank Schmidt in die Rotation mal reinfließt. Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, dem gefällt das da ganz gut. Auf lange Sicht würde er aber sicherlich ähnlich wie Hasenhüttel auch mal sagen, ok, jetzt habe ich hier genug aufgebaut, jetzt würde ich gerne den nächsten Schritt auch machen. Ob der mit Heidenheim dann möglich ist oder bei dem dann doch bei einem anderen Verein gehen muss, das wird man dann sehen.
Also ich glaube schon, dass der Schmidt aber jetzt erstmal noch auf jeden Fall da ein bisschen bleiben wird. Der hat, glaube ich, nicht umsonsten einen Vertrag bis 2020 unterschrieben. Und der weiß ja halt, der hat ja auch seine komplette Trainerkarriere bisher da verbracht. Ich glaube, der ist auf Heidenheim oder in einem Nachbarort irgendwie geboren, hat dann ja bis 2007 da in Heidenheim auch gespielt, Karriere beendet. Dann in der Folgesaison hat er den Trainerposten irgendwie im September übernommen und ist dann halt direkt aufgestiegen. Und ja, war dann, glaube ich, noch vierte Liga. Ein Jahr darauf dann direkt in der dritten Liga und nach fünf Jahren dritter Liga, jetzt in der zweiten Liga. Ich meine, der weiß halt auch, was er da hat. Und wenn man selber was so aufbaut, ich glaube, dann gibt man das auch vielleicht nicht so schnell einfach für einen Trainer-Posten in der ersten Liga her, wo, wenn man sich die diesjährige Saison zum Beispiel anguckt, auch weiß, wenn das dann nach zehn Wochen oder so nicht klappt, dann bist halt auch ganz schnell wieder arbeitslos. Also ich glaube, dass Frank Schmidt, mit dem dieser Erfolg von Heidenheim auf jeden Fall ganz eng verknüpft ist, der wird auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, noch noch lange da bleiben.
Entschuldigung, der war bei uns auch schon im Gespräch und zwar nicht nur jetzt für die Zweitliga-Saison schon, auch als wir noch in der ersten Liga waren. Und da würde man ja vermuten, das ist ein Wohlfühlwechsel, so, weißt du, vom Umfeld her. Heim Stuttgart ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so weit. Der hat das nahmals abgelehnt und das spricht alles für das, was ihr bisher gesagt habt. Also ich glaube, das auch. Ich meine, es gibt diverse Gründe, warum man Trainerposten beim VfB Stuttgart ablehnen kann, versteht mich nicht falsch, aber es wäre in dem Fall schon so ein Karriere-Sprung-Zeitpunkt gewesen, ein möglicher und er hat sich bewusst dafür entschieden, dort zu bleiben und auch nirgendwo anders hinzugehen. Aber er ist auf jeden Fall als Trainer schon so weit gewesen, dass er selbst zu ersten Liga-Zeiten dann auch bei uns ganz klar im Gespräch war. Den hätten wir, glaube ich, gerne genommen.
Und ich glaube, wir müssen uns kurz von vorhin dann selbst widerlegen, weil ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es gesagt hat, aber Lieberknecht ist eben nicht der dienstälteste Trainer in der zweiten Liga, der ist seit 2008 da und Schmidt eben seit 2007 und hat eben die ganzen Ligen, wie du schon sagtest, durchschritten und das ist, glaube ich, schon, hatten wir vorhin auch ein Zeichen von Konstanz.
Und Max, bei welcher historischen Niederlage des FC Bayern München hat Frank Schmidt mitgespielt?
Wenn es eine historische Niederlage ist, hat er mal in Festenbergs Freude gespielt.
Er war 1994 Libero.
Ich kriege immer größere Lust mit diesem Mann ein Tribütengespräch zu machen. Vielleicht kommt man als kleiner Rasenfunk beim nicht ganz so großen FC Heidenheim ja dadurch. Mal gucken.
Vorher weiß ich, dass er da gespielt hat. Es gibt in Festenbergs Kreuz, da war ich mal, ein Gedenkstein an dieses Spiel.
Und den kann wenigstens keine Putzfrau wegwischen, so wie diese Unterschriften da.
Genau. Und dann stand da Frank Schmidt drauf und dann habe ich gedacht, ist er das wohl? Und er ist es tatsächlich.
Also, diesen Mann klebt der Erfolg quasi am Stiefel.
Ja, und man muss einfach sagen, man vergisst ja bei Heidenheim auch so ein bisschen, was da so dahinter steckt. Also, die spielen ja, ich glaube, die haben 2008 oder so dann ihr Stadion mal auf 15.000 Leute hochgebaut. Das Stadion heißt jetzt Feud Arena und Feud ist ein Technikkonzern, der irgendwie einen Umsatz von 4,3 Milliarden Euro hat und aus Heidenheim kommt. Der Hauptsponsor ist dann das Medienunternehmen Paul Hartmann, was einen Umsatz von knapp 2 Milliarden Euro hat. Das heißt, da ist halt auch eine Menge Potenzial auch finanziell in diesem Verein noch drin. Da ist glaube ich das Ende der Fahnenstange dann auch wirklich noch nicht erreicht.
Da hast du jetzt die ganze Romantik aber mal schnell rausverargumentiert. Merkt man das denn auch bei der Art und Weise, wie Heidenheim einkauft und sich finanziert, dass da mehr Potenzial dahinter steht?
Ich kann dir jetzt gar nicht sagen, was die für ein Etat haben, aber wenn du halt so ein Spieler wie Schnatterer, ist der nicht auch bis 2019, 2020 gebunden? Der wird ja mit Sicherheit auch seine Angebote schon bekommen haben, dass der dann halt da bleibt. Der wird da jetzt auch nicht für ein Appel und ein Ei spielen. Also ich glaube eine gewisse Finanzkraft wird da auf jeden Fall jetzt schon benutzt. Und man hat sich da ja auch, das klang auch in dieser Trainer-Doku so ein bisschen an, halt dafür entschieden, wir machen das jetzt mal hier ein bisschen größer. Der Verein heißt ja auch noch nicht so lange Erster FC Heidenheim, neues Stadion, neue Rahmenbedingungen und man will hier einen sukzessiven Aufbau. Und wenn man Frank Schmidt da auch in dieser Doku erlebt hat, das ist keiner, der das Ziel zweite Liga hatte. Der will mit Heidenheim am liebsten in die erste Liga. Und den Fußball, den sie spielen, der ist halt ja auch, ja gehört, ist ein sehr moderner Fußball. Ich glaube, so die Taktik Kipsa von Spielverlagerung kam auch Anfang der Saison. Heidenheim schon gelobt, spielen ein sehr starkes Pressing, das aber auch mal wechselt. Also das hat man gegen Hannover auch gesehen. Da wurde dann zwischendurch mal so richtig angerannt, dann wieder ein bisschen zurückfallen lassen. Die Stürmer positionieren sich so ein bisschen anders zwischendurch, also auf einem taktisch sehr variablen Niveau. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, Mike hat zwar gesagt, dass das jetzt halt alles namhafte Kräfte sind da vielleicht, die man jetzt nicht so direkt kennt. Aber in der Truppe ist ja auf jeden Fall auch Potenzial. Da sind Leute, die ja einen guten Fußball spielen können. Das sieht man schon, als wenn man das 3-2, was jetzt gegen Hannover verloren haben, halt auch sieht. Das war wirklich ein Spitzenspiel der zweiten Liga auf jeden Fall.
Die Transferpolitik ist ja nicht, weil es eben die Frage war, von viel Geld gekennzeichnet. Also die haben sich vor der Saison fast nur mit jungen Leuten verstärkt, größtenteils ablösefrei. Und der Einzige, der da ein bisschen rausreißt, ist John Verhoek, der von uns kam mit 27, aber auch der ablösefrei. Ansonsten sind die alle quasi wie RB Leipzig oder Hoffenheim, Hoffenheimer Schule, sehr jung, teilweise von Hoffenheimer U19 und so. Also da ist ja schon auf Sicht geplant.
Ich habe das Gefühl, die müssen ein ziemlich gutes Scouting haben, wenn man guckt, wo die Leute da herkamen, von Leverkusen, Salzburg, Hoffenheim, hat man immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass das Leute sind, die es dann in deren Verein nicht so schaffen, wo man aber ein großes Potential sieht oder dem man sagt, komm, hier kannst du schon Zweite Liga spielen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und das halt über die letzten Jahre ja immer wieder erfolgreich. Es ist jetzt glaube ich das dritte Jahr einer zweiten Liga. Die letzten beiden Jahre irgendwie gut 40 Punkte geholt, im Mittelfeld gelandet. Ja, und meine, da trifft jetzt wahrscheinlich auch das zu, was Sebastian sagt. Wenn Heidenheim jetzt halt einfach die Saison auf dem vierten Platz abschließt, dann kann es auch mal sein, dass dann zwei, drei Leute da weggekauft werden. Aber dann hast du halt da diese Konstanz im Verein mit dem Trainer, mit dem Umfeld, dass man da auf jeden Fall einen Verein hat, der dann auch im nächsten Jahr wieder für das obere Tabellendrittel da ist.
Sehr, sehr faszinierend und es fällt tatsächlich auf, da müsste man auch mal eine eigene Geschichte zu machen, wie wichtig das Schwäbische für den Fußballraum ist. Also da hat sich eine Nachwuchsleistungszentrenkultur und gleichzeitig auch eine Trainerkultur etabliert, die ihre Auswirkungen bis in den ganz großen Fußball hat, aber auch im Kleinen sehr interessant ist. Also es ist kein Zufall, dass so viele erfolgreiche deutsche Trainer aus dem Schwäbischen kommen und es ist auch kein Zufall, dass so ein Verein wie Heidenheim dann schon indirekt auch von seiner Lage profitiert. Da kann man eben jemanden mal auch aus der U19 von Hoffenheim recht einfach holen und der Weg nach Stuttgart ist auch nicht allzu weit. Echt interessantes Fleckchen da unten in Deutschland.
Aber da gab es ja mal jetzt ein bisschen Spoilern und Werbung machen, aber da gab es ein Kapitel, glaube ich, dem Buch von Tobi Escher zum Thema Süddeutsche Fußballschule.
Ich war mir gerade nicht sicher, ob es ein Buch von Tobi war oder in Raphael Honigsteins Reboot, deswegen habe ich sie gerade ausgespart. Ja, war es bei Tobi im Buch? Ja, dann unbedingt.
Ja, es war bei Tobi, ganz sicher.
Dann unbedingt das Buch von Tobias Escher, Kaufen Fußballtaktik in all seinen Facetten, wunderbar geschrieben, da lernt man sehr viel, ohne es zu merken.
Hat er nicht sogar den Begriff Spätzle-Connection verwendet oder war er jetzt wieder woanders her? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Der ist aber jedenfalls großartig.
Hat man vorher schon auch schon mal gehört, aber ja, ich glaube auch, dass er da gefallen ist. Also wirklich, wirklich sehr, sehr interessant.
Und dann direkt natürlich im Anschluss an das Buch, dieses berühmte Trigünengespräch mit Tobias Escher und Max Makov ausführen.
Das ist sehr nett von dir. Ja gut, ich habe das Gefühl, jetzt etwas eher verstanden zu haben, wie Heidenheim da oben hingekommen ist, was da auch so die Hintergründe für sind. Wie gesagt, beste Defensive der Liga, 14 Gegentreffer nur. Und wenn ich mir dann die Abwehrspieler angucke, dann hört bei mir tatsächlich das Fußball-Wissen auf. Kevin Kraus, jetzt allerdings sehr lange verletzt, Kreuzbandriss, Matthias Wittek, Timo Behrmann, Ibrahim Haititsch sind die Innenverteidiger. Und auf den Außenverteidiger-Positionen Arne Feig, Robert Strauß, Ronny Philipp, Robin Becker. Wenn diese Mannen, die ich da genannt habe, in unterschiedlichen Kombinationen, ich könnte jetzt nicht mal sagen, wer von denen der Stamm ist, es tut mir auch leid, dass ich da wirklich Lücken habe, aber da muss ich jetzt auch zu stehen. Ich kann jetzt nicht so tun, als ob ich Heidenheim-Kennner wäre, aber wenn diese Mannen es schaffen, 14 Tore in 17 Spielen nur zu kassieren, und sollte das ein weiterer Trend sein, dann werden wir davon noch Leute in der ersten Liga sehen, denn das kann nicht sein, dass die ohne Talent da rumlaufen. Das ist sehr, sehr beeindruckend.
Ich habe ja leider Union gegen Heidenheim sehen müssen in dieser Saison.
Holen wir uns mal noch mal kurz ins Boot, wie das ausging.
3 zu 0 für Heidenheim. Und es war das einzige Spiel in dieser Saison, in dem Union keine Chance hatte. Das muss ich mal sagen und das war ein paar Tage nach diesem hervorragenden Spiel gegen Braunschweig, dass man gewonnen hat und wir waren alle so, wow, ja, Braunschweig geknackt, muss man ja so sagen. Und dann fährt man nach Heidenheim und denkt, ja, das nächste Ding einfach noch mal genau so ein Spiel machen und null Chance von Anfang an. Die sind so dynamisch gewesen, dieser Tim Kleindienst, den sie sich von Freiburg ausgeliehen haben, der Stürmer, ist eine Wucht, der kam da frisch nach irgendwie acht Wochen Pause rein, Verletzungspause. Und man hat ihm das nicht angemerkt, irgendwie Schnatterer, irgendwie Bauchmuskizierung oder was weiß ich. Vielleicht war es eine ausgedachte Verletzung, keine Ahnung, aber Wahnsinn, was die über die Flügel haben, die Union einfach komplett geknackt. Also wenn man sich anschaut, links fand ich das wahnsinnig. Ich glaube, es war Arne Falk als Verteidiger und dann Schnatterer vor ihm. Da hat die Union einfach nichts dagegen zu setzen. Ich habe die noch nie so chancenlos gesehen in dieser Saison. Ja, also deswegen, wenn die, glaube ich, von Verletzungen verschont bleiben, dann sind die ganz oben dabei. So ein bisschen ähnlich wie Braunschweig irgendwie. Sie können ein bisschen variabler, glaube ich, spielen noch als Braunschweig und sind unglaublich diszipliniert. Es ist wahnsinnig schwer, gegen die ein Tor zu schießen. Keine Ahnung, wie Hannover da drei Stücke hingekriegt hat.
Hanover ist aber Klaas ist der einzige von uns, der tatsächlich gegen Heidenheim sozusagen gewonnen hat. Also alle anderen drei Mannschaften haben da richtig Federn gelassen. Stuttgart genauso.
Hätte aber auch alles rausgehen können bei uns, muss man auch dazu sagen.
Also ich bin sehr beeindruckt davon. Und wenn du irgendwie Frank Schmidt mal für längere Zeit von Mikro kriegst, ich würde es mir gerne anhören.
Ja, ich würde es auch gerne aufnehmen. Da bin ich jetzt echt tatsächlich eingefixed. Mal gucken, die Anfrage geht nach Beendigung dieser Folge raus. Das heißt, in circa fünf bis sechs Stunden sollen wir noch mal eine lizenzrechtliche Frage stellen. Wie ist das momentan in der ersten Liga mit Sitzplätzen? Wie viel sind da vorgeschrieben? Weiß das jemand?
7500 ab der nächsten Saison.
Aus der Pistole geschossen.
Ja, 4000, ne, da waren es 8500 oder 8000, aber jedenfalls so in dem Dreh und 4500 in der zweiten Liga ab der nächsten Saison, also mehr als jetzt. Ich kann das auch sagen, weil ich das weiß, weil Union und AUE, glaube ich, die Vereine, sind die darunter leiden unter dieser Lizenzänderung, die von Darmstadt und den K2SC eingebracht wurde, während die meisten Vereine das überhaupt nicht juckt. Aber für die Vereine, die aktuell zweite Liga spielen oder erste Liga gibt es Bestandsschutz. Und wenn man aufsteigt, kann man erst mal eine Ausnahmegenehmigung bekommen, wenn man ausbaut. Aber das kann ich ja nachher nochmal erzählen.
Ja, aber das wird für Heidenhain dann nämlich auch relevant, weil die haben momentan 4.500 Sitzplätze. Und das vielleicht noch, ich denke mal, die meisten Hörer waren da wahrscheinlich noch nicht. Wenn man da ankommt, das Licht in so einer Talsenke ist also wunderbar idyllisch gelegen. Man kommt da dann anmarschiert, sieht aus zum Wald heraus in dieses Tal hinein, wirklich malerisch. Und das wird man dann demnächst ein bisschen zerstören müssen, wenn man da ausbaut, weil ja, wie gesagt, vielleicht 4.500 Sitzplätze aktuell. Und ich denke, da ist aber dann drumrum genug Fläche, sodass man das auch vergrößern kann. Ich glaube, das nimmt man dann tatsächlich auch gerne hin, auch wenn man dafür ein bisschen landschaftlich da noch was verändern muss. Es hat sich ja schon sehr viel getan. Also da kann ich nur empfehlen, googelt das mal und schaut euch an, wie es 2008 aussah und wie es jetzt aussieht. Da hat sich schon ein bisschen was bewegt.
Was ich noch ein bisschen fürchterlich finde, da bei Heidenheim, die haben sich ihr Maskottchen an den Sponsor verkaufen lassen. Das Maskottchen ist Pauli, ein steif Teddybär. Geht doch gar nicht, oder?
Naja, ich habe schon schlimmere Maskottchen.
Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen. Also hätte ich jetzt gesagt, das wäre irgendwie Leitz und das sind die Nr. 4 Ordner, hätte ich gesagt, ja. Ich bin jetzt nicht so, aber steif Teddybär ist doch...
Ja, der Teddy ist schon sympathischer als viele andere Maskottchen.
Ich merke Ironie im Podcast funktioniert auch nicht.
Du kannst ja nicht die ganze Zeit so mega trocken vor dich hin parlabern und dann plötzlich ironisch werden. Das geht auch nicht. Das geht nicht. Sollen wir denn vielleicht mal von drittjüngsten Team der Mannschaft zum zweitältesten Team der zweiten Liga kommen? Und möchte mir Sebastian vielleicht sagen, welches Team das sein könnte?
Wow, jetzt was?
Ja, 26,5 Jahre. Nur die Würzburger Kicker sind noch älter.
Ja, aber das liegt ja bestimmt daran, dass im Kader Benjamin Köhler ist, der ja nicht spielt. Und aber wie alt ist er? 1980 geboren, also ein Tick jünger als ich, 36. Der reißt das bestimmt raus. Keine Ahnung.
Klar, das hat jetzt natürlich auch Stil, wenn du es auf einem alten Sack abwälzt, aber okay. Also wir sprechen jetzt über den ersten FC Union Berlin.
Ja, weiß ich gar nicht, warum zweitältester Kader.
Also sie spielen aber dann definitiv keinen Fußball, der alt wirkt, sonst hättest du ja dazu schon einen Bezug gehabt zu dieser Frage. Und die Stammspieler sind natürlich auch wesentlich jünger. Der bekannteste, glaube ich, überregional Felix Groß im Mittelfeld, wo man ja bei euch im Textilvergehen quasi wöchentlich mitverfolgen konnte, wie ihr erst gebankt habt, dann etwas ungläubig wart und euch dann gefreut habt. Und ab jetzt poppt er halt immer wieder auf. Ist so einer der Schlüsselspieler bei euch, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich bin mir auch noch unschlüssig, wie dieser Deal mit Werder Bremen zustande kam. Aber nochmal danke, dass die mit Viktor Skripnik in die neue Saison gegangen sind, weil das war so der K.O.-Faktor, weshalb Felix Groß da auf keinen Fall bleiben wollte. Und 500.000 Ablöse hat das gekostet. Das ist eigentlich vergleichsweise günstig. Ich glaube aber, beim Gehalt langt er mächtig zu wahrscheinlich. Ist aber, ja, also ein bisschen, also klingt jetzt fies, weil eigentlich das Letzte, was Felix Groß hören möchte, sind Vergleiche mit seinem Bruder. Der wird ja immer als Weltmeisterbruder und so weiter und so fort bezeichnet. Und es gibt immer mal einen Trainer, der ihn Toni Groß nennt, also auch der Trainer von Union, André Hofschneider. In der letzten Saison hatte ich ihn einmal in der Pressekonferenz Toni Groß genannt. Also das will er sicher nicht hören, aber der ist halt irgendwie so sehr passsicher, also den kann zu anspielen. Der ist relativ pressing-resistent, würde ich sagen. Und würde ich schon sagen, dass es eine Schlüsselfigur ist. Vielleicht jetzt nicht so, wie er nach außen dargestellt wird, ja, weil er ist ja Kapitän geworden. Das hat mich schon verblüfft irgendwie, weil er halt sehr verletzungsreinfähig ist. Das war so, glaube ich, auch so der Grund, weshalb er sich nie so hat etablieren können. Und er ist jetzt auch nicht der schnellste Spieler, um es mal so zu sagen. Aber er ist halt immer anspielbar, er weiß Lösungen und tritt Standards. Also für zweite Liga ist es wahrscheinlich ein Spieler, der zu gut für die zweite Liga ist. Aber ich glaube, solche Spieler braucht man. Also hat man ja auch bei Hannover oder Stuttgart irgendwie im Kader, um dann tatsächlich irgendwie diesen Kick zu machen, irgendwie, um den Aufstieg mitzuspielen bzw. aufsteigen zu wollen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das die Schlüsselverpflichtung war. Das weiß ich nicht, aber das war eine sehr wichtige, die auch dazu geführt hat, dass halt so ein bisschen die Plätze im zentralen Mittelfeld zementiert sind bei Union. Also umfähig groß gibt es dann halt im defensiven Mittelfeld, wahlweise Stefan Förstner oder Dennis Daube, der aber auch häufig verletzt ist. Das wird Mike vom Übersteiger, also von St. Pauli auch dann wissen, irgendwie. Und vorne Damir Kreilach, der vorher auch mal Kapitän war. Und da gibt es ein starkes Talent bei Union, Errol Zehnulao, der ist mit dieser Verpflichtung von Felix Groß im Prinzip komplett draußen. Da weiß ich überhaupt gar nicht, was so die Zukunft dann für ihn bereithält. Aber die wichtigste Verpflichtung aus meiner Sicht war so tatsächlich die Trainerposition, würde ich sagen, mit Jens Keller. Da können wir auch wieder sagen hier Spätzle Connection, so auch wieder aus Süddeutschland dann irgendwie. Und weil der profitiert von dem, was Union hat jetzt zwei Jahre sehr, sehr inkonstant gespielt, obwohl sie auf Platz sechs und sieben dann eingelaufen sind am Ende. Und mit Trainerwechsel hatten erst einen sehr jungen, unbekannten Trainer, der bei Hannover 96 mal war, Norbert Düvel, hatten dann Sascha Lewandowski, der dann wegen Burnout ausgeschieden ist und dann halt auch noch Selbstmord gemacht hat. Und ja, dann mit dem Co-Trainer quasi Saison zu Ende gespielt, mit Ausnahmegenehmigung von der DFL und so weiter und so fort. Und es war halt alles so riesige Umbrüche, zweimal hintereinander sehr viele Wechsel gehabt. Und mit Jens Keller hatte ich so gedacht, naja gut, keine Ahnung, was der die letzten Jahre Zeit nach Schalke gemacht hat.
Die Bostransformation, glaube ich, will ich mir so angucken.
Ja, auf jeden Fall viel gepumpt. Also da habe ich auch gestaunt, als er so vor mir stand, dachte ich, wow, die Zeit hatte ich nicht. Aber der hat irgendwie profitiert davon, dass die Trainer vorher sehr viel aufgebrochen haben bei Union und Spieler halt reingebracht haben, die dann halt jetzt im Prinzip auf ein völlig eingespieltes Team zurückgreifen. Und wenn man so schaut, so die Top-Verpflichtung, es wurde halt gar nicht so viel verpflichtet, aber die Spieler, die geholt wurden, sind halt so Spieler, wo man sagt, die haben unglaublich individuelle Klasse, sind eigentlich zu gut für die zweite Liga, aber vielleicht nicht gut genug für die erste. So diese Zwischenspieler, also Felix Groß, dann Philipp Hosiner, der wegen, der hat ja auch Krebs gehabt irgendwie, bei Köln, nach Köln ausgeliehen wurde, der ein toller Stürmer ist. Und Simon Hedlund aus der schwedischen Liga, sehr viel individuelle Qualität, aber so die Top-Leistung ist eigentlich, dass man so diese Mannschaft insgesamt so zusammengehalten hat. Also mein bestes Beispiel ist Toni Leipzner in der Innenverteidigung, glaube ich. Weiß ich nicht, Max, du hast ja so diese Hammer-Statistiken für die zweite Liga. Ich würde sagen, der kopfballstärkste Zweitligaspieler, verliert überhaupt ein Kopfball-Duell, keine Ahnung. Stuttgart war mit ihm im Gespräch, keine Ahnung, warum das nicht geklappt hat.
Der kopfballstärkste ist tatsächlich Tim Kleindienst. Nein, ich sehe gerade, das Plugin hat sich aufgehängt. Ich muss nochmal reloaden und dann kann ich dir sagen, der kopfballstärkste ist Tim Kleindienst, Lasse Sobek, Tim Kister von Sandhausen, Tony Leisner dann auf Platz 10. Aber was ja von allen Zweitligaspielern nicht der schlechtste Wert ist.
Ja, also wahnsinnig sicher als Spieler und das ist so der Unterschied zu Union in der letzten Saison. Die schießen im Prinzip ähnlich viele Tore. Also da hat sich nicht viel geändert, wo man denkt, irgendwie Bobby Wurth ist weg, weil er so viele Tore geschossen hat. Aber in der Defensive hat sich einiges geändert. Also man hat sich aus der zweiten dänischen Liga Christian Pedersen geholt als Linksverteidiger, wenn man in der letzten Saison eigentlich quasi gar keinen Linksverteidiger hatte, sondern ja, das war so ein bisschen ein Kaderfehler.
Der sehr, sehr gute Zweikampfstatistiken hat Christian Pedersen.
Der ist Wahnsinn. Also da kommt jemand aus der zweiten dänischen Liga und ist quasi von Anhieb Stammspieler und macht quasi fast jedes Spiel aus. Einmal ist er gelb-rot gesperrt gewesen. Ist für mich so die Überraschung eigentlich des bisherigen Hinrundes aus Union-Sicht. Und Jens Keller hat halt sich auch noch so einen Co-Trainer geholt, den ich nicht kannte, Henrik Petersen, der früher mal bei Salzburg war. Was ist ich, was er da gemacht hat? Irgendwie Koordinator, Nachwuchs oder so. Und der gilt so ein bisschen so auch als so die Connection zur Mannschaft. Und Jens Keller, den ich total als spröde wahrgenommen habe bei Schalke oder Stuttgart, so aus medialer Entfernung, den finde ich ja ehrlich gesagt ziemlich witzig. Unglaublich schlagfertig. Vielleicht jetzt nicht die Medien so immer gegenüber, jedenfalls nicht in Pressekonferenzen. Die sind wahnsinnig öde mit ihm, aber so, wenn halt so Kameras ausrücken, ist der wahnsinnig schlagfertig und ich glaube, dass so was im Team ganz gut ankommt. Und ich hatte so ein bisschen für mich gefragt irgendwie, was der eigentlich für den Fußball irgendwie zur Union bringt. Da habe ich mal so gefragt irgendwie dann so mal Schalke Leute, was ist denn das für ein Fußball, dieser Kellerfußball oder was weiß ich. Er stellt sich raus, Gegenpressing ist so sein Ding. Und das hat ja irgendwie dieser Mannschaft ganz gut beigebracht. Wenn auch jetzt so, also hat man so meinetwegen jetzt ein Spiel gegen Braunschweig, glaube ich, ganz gut gesehen, irgendwie auch am Anfang, ja, so Anfang Mitte der Saison war es auch sehr gut. Und so ein bisschen ist die Luft rausgegangen, wo ich überlege, ob er vielleicht so ein bisschen Plan B braucht für Mannschaften, die sich aus dieser Nummer auch befreien können. Also Heidenheim hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Andere Spiele sind halt einfach an der Chancenverwertung dann gescheitert. Also wie jetzt gegen Fürth, das war ja, ich glaube, wir haben das Kaktor des Jahres bekommen. Die hatten ja eigentlich gar keine Chance. Und man spielt dann trotzdem nur 1-1. Ja, also da bin ich von Jens Keller positiv überrascht, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich da gar keine großen Erwartungen an ihn hatte. Und man denkt halt so Bundesliga-Trainer geht in die zweite Liga. Aber ich glaube, der kann profitiert hat einfach von diesen ganzen Umbrüchen und kann das Ganze sehr gut konsolidieren. Bloß halt diese Verstärkung im Kader individuell, das hat schon viel ausgemacht.
Da hat er generell...
Nein, ich wollte nur kurz anfügen, dass ich mich sehr freue, dass Jens Keller da so gut angekommen ist, weil er einfach, ich finde auch echt nicht so richtig... Er hatte es nicht leicht bei seinen Stationen. Der ist ja auch ein VfB Stuttgart Gewächs natürlich und hat dann da nach Christian Groß damals die Mannschaft übernommen, ist dann aber gleich wieder freigestellt worden, weil His Majesty Bruno Labbadia um die Ecke kam und ist so ein bisschen auch rumgereicht worden. Also ich finde einfach, er wurde auch immer... Er war eigentlich immer da und wurde immer gerade dafür ausgenutzt, was gerade irgendwie nötig war. Und bei FC Schalke war es auch so, dass man einen Eindruck hatte, er hatte da nie die volle Rückendeckung und irgendwie... Also er hat auch mich da immer so ein bisschen unglücklich mit Eindruck gemacht, also auch nicht unglücklich, dass er selbst unglücklich ist, sondern dass das so ein bisschen unglückliche Verpflichtung dann vielleicht auch war, dass es nicht so gut lief. Und dann hatte ich gehört, er kommt so zur Union und musste nicht so richtig, okay, wird das passen oder nicht? Aber wenn er da jetzt wirklich so, wie er es jetzt tut, die Saison so gut bestreitet und erfolgreich bestreitet, ist das ein... Du sagtest ja vorhin schon, Sebastian, dass er auf Pressekonferenzen so öde ist. Er ist jetzt keiner für das Rampenlicht und er ist auch keiner, der jetzt unbedingt dann bei Schalke eine Pressekonferenz abhalten möchte, wo ihm medial an die Gull gegangen wird, wegen was auch immer. Und insofern könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass er da echt so seinen Platz gefunden hat jetzt bei Union und zumindest im Moment in der Zweiten Liga. Und ich wollte das nochmal loswerden, weil wie gesagt, der war bei uns auch Thema und mir hat er immer irgendwie so ein bisschen Leid getan und jetzt hat er mal irgendwie einen guten Halt gefunden und das finde ich ganz schön. Also das ist zu weihnachtlich, Entschuldigung.
Nein, nein, nein, alles gut und ich finde es ja auch richtig, Jens Keller da noch mal auch in Retrospective zu bewerten. Das war ganz ähnliches, das habe ich übrigens im Sportradio 360 gestern erst erzählt, ein vorgestern war es. Schön, dass ich da nicht so ganz daneben lag und mir auch die Experten quasi zustimmen. Ich finde die Entwicklung ganz interessant, was Sebastian die Union Berlin genommen hat. Vom dem Verein, der vor allem dadurch überregional aufgefallen ist, ein anderer Berliner Verein zu sein, mit dem selbstgebauten Stadion, hin zu einer Mannschaft, die schon sehr, sehr, also in die sehr viel investiert wurde. Und ich habe den Eindruck, der Anspruch beim 1. FC Union Berlin hat sich immer mehr nach oben verschoben und so langsam, auch wenn man bei euch reinhört, kriegt man das ja immer wieder mit, müsste eigentlich der Aufstieg mal her, wenn man es vergleicht mit dem, was die Konkurrenten so investiert haben in den letzten Jahren.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht ganz so überraschend. Ich hatte ein Interview mit dem Präsidenten mal vor zwei oder drei Jahren, wo er damals schon gesagt hat, man möchte in die Top 20 des deutschen Fußballs, wir kennen das ja vom SC Freiburg, diese Bezeichnung. Und da hat das bei Union Fans, glaube ich, so für ein bisschen so Augenlupfung gesorgt. Aber ich fand das eigentlich logisch, weil Union wahnsinnig viel investiert. Ich glaube, diese vielen, nennen wir es schon Jahrzehnte, des dauernden Existenzkampfes bei Union hat so ein bisschen zu einer Verschiebung geführt, dass man halt immer sagt, ja, ja, erst mal Klassen erhalt. Aber der Kader, der Vereinsetat, der war bei Aufstieg 2009 bei, glaube ich, 11 oder 12 Millionen und jetzt ist er bei 31 Millionen. Und das ist nur der Etat vom Verein. Es gibt da noch GmbHs zur Verwaltung und für Events. Und dann gibt es noch die Stadion AG. Und wenn man das alles zusammenzählt, merkt man, dass da schon sehr viel Geld unterwegs ist mittlerweile. Wie auch immer sie das machen. Also ich würde es gerne mal sehen, die Zahlen. Aber da wird auch investiert und da werden auch Gehälter gezahlt, wo andere nicht mit können. Also ich erinnere mich irgendwie so ein Brandi, wurde als Stürmer verpflichtet vor ein paar Jahren. Den wollte St. Pauli auch haben. Die sind dann halt ausgestiegen, weil sie einfach die Gehälter nicht zahlen konnten. Und deswegen muss der Anspruch natürlich sein, dass man halt dann nicht nur ein bisschen mitspielt, wie man das bei Union so macht. Eine ganz klassische Union-Saison sei bisher so aus, irgendeine Art von Fehlstart. So, erster Sieg dann am 5. und 6. Spieltag, vorher schön erste Runde Pokal ausgeschieden. Dann gute Hinrunde irgendwie zwischen Platz 1 und 6. Dann noch mal kurz ran tasten an die Top 3 und dann so ab, sagen wir mal, Spieltag 22, 24 abreißen lassen und austrudeln. Und dann irgendwie auf zwischen Platz 6 und 9 ankommen. Und deswegen ist ja Uwe Neuhaus entlassen worden 2014, nachdem er sieben Jahre bei Union war und die da auch in die Zweite Liga gebracht hat, um das halt irgendwie diesen ganz man hat so das Gefühl gehabt bei Union, dass es so verkostet ist irgendwie und das alle so ein bisschen ja so naja so eine Komfortzone für sich gefunden haben. Man spielt oben mit, man kassiert ganz gut Geld, aber man muss ja nicht alles. Ja, und ja, das ist jetzt anders und das merkt man auch. Und Jens Keller trägt auch seinen Teil dazu bei, dem er halt irgendwie überhaupt nicht den Anschein macht, irgendwie als es dann hieß ja Montag gegen Braunschweig und am Freitag vier Tage später in Heidenheim. Und mit ja wurde gefragt, ist ja fast wie eine englische Woche und er so, ja, das sind Profis, die müssen das halt aushalten. Union spielt halt die zweite Runde im DFB-Pokal vor 80.000 in Dortmund und der Einzige, glaube ich, dem das irgendwie zwar vielleicht nicht am Arsch vorbei ging, aber der irgendwie total relaxed war, war Jens Keller. Alle anderen haben halt den größten Vereinsausflug der Geschichte gemacht, irgendwie die gesamte Geschäftsstelle. Und bei Union sind, weiß nicht, so viele neue dazugekommen. So es waren nicht irgendwie 30 Leute aus der Geschäftsstelle, sondern irgendwie über 100 arbeiten ja mittlerweile fest Angestellte bei Union. Dann sind die halt alle gemeinsam nach Dortmund gefahren mit 10.000 Fans noch dazu. Und der ist halt da total relaxed. Der hat glaube ich in der Zeit einfach bei Schalke alles gesehen, was man so an Druck und so weiter und so fort haben kann. Genießt dieses Umfeld, das er bei Union hat. Das ist ja sehr gefestigt. Und hat gleichzeitig halt einfach verkörpert alles, was sagt irgendwie Bundesliga ist das Ding.
Ich finde es aber auch ganz interessant, dass man so dem Keller halt so ein Stempel aufdrückt von außen, obwohl man kennt ihn ja eigentlich gar nicht. Also man hat das immer nur so mitbekommen, was da halt über Schalke berichtet wurde. Aber wie er wirklich so als Typ ist, weiß man ja gar nicht. Deswegen fand ich es ganz interessant, was Sebastian sagte. Ich habe mir vor der Saison auch mal so ein Interview mit ihm angeguckt, was euer Pressesprecher da geführt hatte. Und da siehst du halt auch so, dass er schon so einen kleinen Schelm im Nacken hat, aber auch keinen Bock hat, jetzt so den großen Clown irgendwie für alle zu geben, weil er halt auch weiß, was immer draus gemacht wird. Und ja, hat bei Union, glaube ich, jetzt auch so eine Truppe vorgefunden, mit der er halt jetzt auch was erarbeiten konnte. Und was ihm, glaube ich, auch groß mit reinspielt, ist, dass er halt eine sehr konstante Aufstellung immer hat. Also ich glaube, ihr habt acht Leute, die irgendwie 16, 17 Spiele gemacht haben diese Saison. Na ja, Hosiner war jetzt auch noch verletzt die letzten paar Spiele, sonst hätte er auch mehr oder Kwan hat auch ein paar Mal ausgesetzt zwischendurch. Sonst wären das noch mehr. Das heißt, ihr spielt auch fast jede Woche mit denselben Leuten.
Ja, das ist so ein Jens Keller Ding, der halt sagt, er schmeißt die Leute nicht nach einem schlechten Spiel wieder aus der Mannschaft oder so. Das war zum Beispiel bei Uwe Neuhaus ganz anders, wo halt auch so ein bisschen, wenn Spieler Angst bekommen, Fehler zu machen, kann das ja auch leistungshebbend wirken. Und vielleicht war das auch so ein Punkt, würde ich sagen, ist ein Unterschied. Und bei Jens Keller kriegen die halt das Vertrauen. Wenn sie aber mehr schlechte Spieler haben, sind sie dann irgendwie auch weg. Also nicht so konstant ist zum Beispiel die Position links außen, wo Union theoretisch im Moment vier Spieler hätte. Einer ist Langzeitverletzt, Maxi Thier, der kam von Köln mal. Und dann gibt es Adrian Nixchi, der kennt man ja vielleicht von Hannover oder so. Und eigentlich hat da Kenny Prinz Redondo sich mit Adrian Nixchi abgewechselt. Dann wurde Simon Hedlund zum Ende der Transferperiode verpflichtet. Der musste sich erstmal hier irgendwie eingewöhnen in Berlin und überhaupt so vom schwedischen Fußball. Und außerdem hatte er den Sommer über, weil die ja den Kalenderjahr spielen da in Schweden, durchgespielt und der kam jetzt erst so die letzten Spiele so richtig in Fahrt. Ja, also aber ansonsten der hält an den Leuten fest, tatsächlich. Also das ist ein Punkt, wo ich mal gespannt bin, wie das so über die Saison aussieht. Weil es halt natürlich Spieler gibt, die komplett raus sind, muss man so sagen. Und Jens Keller hat auch gesagt, mit den Spielern wurde auch gesprochen, die es betrifft. Und dass man denen auch keine Steine in den Weg legt, falls sie jetzt im Winter wechseln wollen. Weil Union hat einen relativ großen Kader, das lag zum Teil an ein paar Langzeitverletzten. Also Benny Köhler zum Beispiel ist ja auch jemand, der hat diese Krebserkrankung überstanden, hat aber nur Knieprobleme. Ich glaube, der wird kein Pflichtspiel mehr machen. Der wird jetzt auch nicht ins Wintertrainingslager mitfahren. Christopher Queering, der aus dem Union Nachwuchs kommt, ist im Prinzip komplett außen vor. Jetzt beim vierten Trainer in Folge, der sollte sich dann auch vielleicht mal überlegen, ob er bei einem neuen Verein irgendwie was macht. Und die haben 29 Spieler im Kader und vielleicht reduzieren sie es im Winter auf 26, 27, wenn es irgendwie möglich ist. Und man hat dann trotzdem die Kader-Tiefe. Das muss ich schon sagen. Also wenn du auf die Bank schaust, da fällt es halt nicht runter. Da sitzt da nicht plötzlich irgendwie ein 18-Jähriger aus der A-Jugend noch da drauf oder so. Also das ist insgesamt der Kader sagt im Prinzip das Gleiche. Vielleicht auf einem bisschen anderen Niveau, auch Gehaltsniveau, als bei Stuttgart oder Hannover. Wir wollen auch steigen. Und deswegen, als mich so Leute vor den Spielen gegen Stuttgart oder Hannover oder Braunschweig gefragt haben, ja, hier Union, was meinst du, wie es ausgeht? Die Spiele ich so, die werden das gewinnen oder sie... Also das ist auf jeden Fall so, Union nicht Außenseiter gegen solche Mannschaften. Und es war es dann auch nicht. Also gegen Stuttgart war ich sehr froh, weil die auch sehr dominant gespielt haben, die erste Halbzeit. Aber danach konnten sie froh sein, dass sie noch mit einem Unentschieden rausgekommen sind. Hannover hat verloren, Braunschweig hat verloren, insofern... Also der Anspruch muss sein, Aufstieg, ohne dass man jetzt sagt, irgendwie wir müssen direkt. Das ist nicht ganz so. Aber man möchte schon in die Bundesliga. Und diese Lizenzänderung, die ich angesprochen hatte vorhin, die hat man ja auch massiv mitgestaltet dann. Also eigentlich sollte es einfach durchgewunken werden auf so eine DFL-Versammlung. Und es wurde dann von der Tagesordnung genommen. Und Union hat so lobbyiert, dass zum Beispiel eben diese Regelung ist dieser Bestandsschutz, dass man halt, wenn man weniger als diese 4500 Sitzplätze in der zweiten Liga hat, und Union hat in diesem Stadion mit 22.000 Plätzen knapp über 3000 Sitzplätze nur, dann kann man trotzdem halt weiterspielen, ohne dass man irgendwie eine Ausnahmegenehmigung bräuchte oder so. Und sie haben für die erste Liga jetzt planen sie den Stadionausbau. Aber auch aus einem zweiten Grund, weil das Stadion halt auch permanent im Heimbereich ausverkauft ist mittlerweile. Und die werden das Stadion auf irgendwas ausbauen. Wir werden im Februar, Februar, Quatsch, März, April oder so sollen die Pläne vorgestellt werden. Da untersuchen sie gerade, wie es am besten klappt. Aber dann wird das halt ein Stadion mit über 30.000 Plätzen sein. Und dann entsprechend wie auch immer sie das gestalten mit diesen, glaube ich, 8.000 Sitzplätzen, dass halt dieser Charakter im Stadion einer alten Füsterei, der sehr von diesen Städtplätzen geprägt ist, irgendwie erhalten bleibt. Bin ich sehr gespannt, wie man das macht. Auch bei der Finanzierung bin ich sehr gespannt. Weil die Stadt bezahlt da keinen Cent dazu.
Wie, was? Berlin hat da keine Kohle für übrig?
Naja, also Olympiastadion gehört ja letzten Endes dem Land Berlin und da gab es auch Kohle, auch vom Bund und auch vom Land dafür. Aber es gibt so ein Deal mit der Stadt. Also Union hat dieses Grundstück, auf dem das Stadion steht, irgendwie per Erbaufacht übernommen. Und alles, was sie da drauf bauen und alles, was für den Profifußball ist, bezahlen sie komplett selbst oder finanzieren es selbst. Und das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum wird, sollte ursprünglich zu 100% vom Land bezahlt werden, weil es halt quasi Amateur- und Frauenmannschaften und so weiter und so fort auch betrifft. Und da ist jetzt auch so, dass Union 20% bezahlt und 80% vom Land kommen. Ja, also insofern, ich finde es eigentlich eine saubere Regelung, ist aber eher selten im deutschen Fußball, dass die Stadt sich so wenig beteiligt. Also schaut mal so Stadionausbau jetzt irgendwie in Karlsruhe an. Das zahlt schon der Steuerzahler.
Da hast du aber natürlich in Berlin eine andere Situation und die ist glaube ich auch vergleichbar mit Hamburg, weil du musst dich halt auf mehrere Vereine verteilen. Und das war in Hamburg mit dem Volkswagen-Stadion genauso. Also auch da, WM-Stadion, etc. Beteiligung von Stadt, Land, sonst was. Und das Milantor ist halt auch, ja, die Pacht hat man den Verein irgendwie überlassen, aber das war es dann auch größtenteils. Jetzt, wenn wir so Zwischenbilanz ziehen, Sebastian, dann legt er jetzt auf Tabellenplatz 5 mit 28 Punkten. Das sind 4 Punkte Rückstand auf die Aufstiegsringe. Was muss sich denn verändern in der Rückrunde, dass das hinhaut mit dem Aufstieg?
Jens Keller hat gesagt, wir haben mehr Punkte verloren als durch unglückliche Spielausgänge oder so, als durch glückliche gewonnen. Ich glaube, das wäre so ein Punkt, der sich auf jeden Fall mehr ändern könnte. Ich erinnere mich irgendwie, wie gesagt, das letzte Spiel gegen Quatsch. Fürth war so eins und eins eins, aber wir hatten auch ein 4-4 in Bielefeld. Das Union, glaube ich, da lagen sie 3-1 zurück, haben 4-3 geführt und dann kassieren sie noch Daten. Na egal. Und solche Sachen könnten sich ändern. Und was ein Punkt ist, über den ich die ganze Zeit nachdenke, bei dem ich auch nicht genau Bescheid weiß. Ursprünglich war ja Philipp Hosiner als Nachfolger für Bobby Wood verpflichtet worden im Angriff. Hatte sich dann quasi vor dem ersten Saisonspiel verletzt. Dafür kam Colin Kwana, den ich eigentlich schon Richtung dritte Liga verabschiedet hatte, zum Spiel. Ich glaube, er hatte noch nie in seinem Leben so einen Lauf. Der hat dann ständig getroffen. Und hat sich so ein bisschen eingespielt, dass Colin Kwana im Sturmzentrum steht und spielt. Auch wenn er jetzt nicht mehr so trifft, aber halt so auch als Zielspieler da ist. Aber so ein bisschen hat er auch ein Problem mit der ersten Ballannahme. Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass man doch wieder von diesen Richtung hoher Bälle auf Kwana geht immer irgendwie. Ja, wenn man gepresst wird, dass man dann halt die Richtung spielt, dass man so ein bisschen sich mehr durchkombiniert und halt die Stärken der anderen Spieler mehr mit einbringt. Also wie die von Steven Skrips geht, der eigentlich auch Stürmer ist, auf rechts außen spielt. Simon Hetlund auf links außen. Und meinetwegen dann Philipp Hosiner oder wer auch immer da im Zentrum steht. Dass das so ein bisschen runtergeht, dass man da sicherer im Spielaufbau ist und nicht darauf angewiesen ist, den Zielspieler Kolinkwana zu suchen. Ich glaube, diese Zielspielernummer ist immer so eine süße Versuchung. Weil man den sieht man halt. Der ist ja auch schnell der Kolinkwana. Und ist auch irgendwie ein cooler Typ und ein toller Spieler. Aber es ist so die Versuchung, man sieht da diesen Typen und man spielt einfach lang, anstatt vielleicht andere Wege zu finden. Und ich habe so die Hoffnung mit, da durch das Simon Hetlunds erste Mal quasi eine Vorbereitung, in dem Fall die Wintervorbereitung mit Jens Keller macht, der irgendwie die Mannschaft, bei Jens Kellers Anblick ist das ja nicht verwunderlich, sehr fit macht. Sie können laufen ohne Ende und sie werden auch nicht müde, dass er da irgendwie mal ein bisschen mehr Variabilität wieder reinbringt, die am Anfang auch da war. Das wäre so mein Ding irgendwie. Ansonsten ist es die beste Hinrunde, die Union J in der zweiten Liga gespielt hat. Die hatten einmal genauso viele Punkte, aber nicht so ein gutes Torverhältnis. Also insofern, ja, das kann ruhig noch mal so gehen, aber andererseits darf man vielleicht in der Rückrunde nicht so viele Punkte am Anfang liegen lassen, wie man das jetzt in der Hinrunde gemacht hat, weil hinten raus ist das Programm mit Stuttgart, Heidenheim, Braunschweig doch einigermaßen fett, würde ich sagen, auf die letzten fünf Spieltage diese drei Gegner zu haben.
Ja, das wird ein spannender April und Anfang Mai dann in der zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga. Ich glaube, da können sich auch die neutralen Fans darauf freuen. Und dann schauen wir mal, ob bei euch dann auswärts in Fürth am 21. Mai gefeiert werden kann, Sebastian, wo du dich dann befindest zu diesem Zeitpunkt oder ob es dann vielleicht auch um nichts mehr geht. Ich habe noch eine Sache. Als du die wichtigen Neuverpflichtungen erwähnt hast, habe ich eigentlich auf einen anderen Namen gewartet, habe jetzt aber nachgeguckt und es stimmt gar nicht, weil der kam schon im Winter, nämlich Jakob Busk. Ich habe von außen immer so das Gefühl gehabt, Torwahlposition bei Union ist immer was ganz Spezielles und war halt auch nie so ganz fehlerfrei. Und mit ihm habe ich jetzt das Gefühl, das ist eine Bank.
Ja, das stimmt auch. Also das war tatsächlich ein. Also einerseits die Verpflichtung von Jakob Busk und andererseits haben sie auch einen Torwart-Trainer verpflichtet und den alten einfach entlassen. Sie haben Dennis Rudel geholt, der auch früher, glaube ich, Stuttgart irgendwie unterwegs war. Also nochmal süddeutsche Trainer-Connection. Von den Kaiserschiefs aus Südafrika haben sie den geholt. Und mit den beiden hat sich wirklich was getan. Also so mitspielender Torwart. Jakob Busk ist auch nicht komplett fehlerfrei oder so. Aber er spielt mit, während halt schon die Strafraumbeherrschung vorher bei Torhütern eher ein Problem war. Glaube Union hat keinen Gegentor nach Ecken, keinen Kopfballgegentor kassiert, was einerseits für die Verteidigung, andererseits auch für den Torhüter spricht. Also insofern, das haut total hin. Und der steht dann auch mal 30 Meter vorm Tor. Ist so ein bisschen... Ich will jetzt nicht diesen neuen Vergleich bringen. Aber er spielt sehr gut mit. Und ist gleichzeitig... Ja, so dieser Prototyp irgendwie eines skandinavischen Spielers, sagt nicht viel. Aber auf dem Platz ist er echt...
Damit haben wir Tabellenplatz 5 uns auch näher angeguckt. Und jetzt kommen wir, schon jetzt kommen wir zu den beiden Aufsteigern in diese zweite Fußball-Bundesliga und zuerst zu den Würzburger Kickers. Damit werden wir auch beim durchschnittlich ältesten Team dieser Liga. Und wer von euch kann mir denn sagen, was da in Würzburg los ist? Es ist meine alte Heimat im weitesten Sinne. Ich habe das aus der Distanz mitverfolgt. Und bin mehr oder weniger ungläubig bis fast überfordert, damit zu erklären, was Bernd Hollerbach mit Würzburg gemacht hat. Wer kann mir das erklären?
Okay, ich würde es mal versuchen. Hollerbach hat an sich einen wahnsinnigen Job gemacht mit dem Aufstiegsdurchmarsch sozusagen. Ich glaube einfach, dass er da in Würzburg den Spielraum gekriegt hat. Das ist ja auch seine Geburtsstadt. Da kommt er daher, sich da eine Mannschaft zusammenzustellen. Die ist natürlich nominell. Da kennst du so gut wie gar keinen, wenn du dich nicht wirklich auskennst in der zweiten Liga. Aber die er gut gemixt hat, also sie wird immer als relativ alt beschrieben, aber es ist zum Beispiel ein ganz, ja, wirklich schnittverzerrender Mitspieler ist natürlich der Torwart, der übrigens, wie ich aus Protest hier nur kundtue, Wulle mit Spitznamen heißt, also Wuldikowski ist es. Und Wulle ist unser Lieblingsspiel in Stuttgart. Also bitte ja, passt mal auf, da in Würzburg. Ihr könnt euren Wein da trinken. Und der ist, das ist so ein Buffon-Verschnitt. Also der steht da hinten drin mit, keine Ahnung, um die 40. Und hält da den Laden zusammen. Und ist natürlich da ein ganz erfahrener Rückhalt für die Spieler, die natürlich da dann weiter vorne auch jünger sind. Und ich glaube wirklich, dass das Hollerbach da unglaublich viel über Mentalität geht und über Kampfes willen. Und ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass natürlich keiner damit gerechnet hat, dass die auf diesem Tabellenplatz stehen nach dieser Hinrunde. Ich glaube aber auch wirklich, dass da auch ein bisschen mitspielt, dass die halt auch unterschätzt werden und auch schwer einzuschätzen sind. Weil sie natürlich jetzt auch nicht jahrelang irgendwie Spielerfahrung in der zweiten Liga haben. Und Hollerbach hat da offensichtlich ein gutes Händchen. Ist taktisch tatsächlich auch jetzt nicht so festgefahren. Der will das Flexibelhand haben und muss da seine Spieler offensichtlich gut einleiten, dass die es schaffen, wirklich immer wieder so Überraschungsmomente zu erzielen. Und ich habe ja das Spiel noch im Nacken gegen VfB. Und da war es auch wirklich so, die rennen halt an, wie die bekloppten in ihrem Stadion. Es ist wirklich so, in diesem Stadion, das ist ja so ein, ja, wirklich so ein kleines Ding mit irgendwie 14.000, 13.000, 12.000, weiß ich nicht, Plätzen, sowas in der Gegend.
13.000.
13.000, ja gut, Schnitt passt. Und die haben da wirklich, die haben genau das gemacht, diese Welle, diesen Spiel, Mut und Witz und so, den zum Beispiel unsere Recken da vermissen haben lassen. Und ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, ohne natürlich jetzt andere Würzburg-Spiele gesehen zu haben, muss ich ehrlich sagen, dass das dann bei anderen Mannschaften vielleicht auch ein bisschen auf, ja, wie soll ich sagen, dass die auch ein bisschen überrascht waren, was da einfach auf sie zurollt. Und also ich persönlich würde da schon ganz, ganz, ganz viel dem Trainer Bernd Hollerbach irgendwie zuschreiben. Meine persönliche Meinung.
Ja, ist sicherlich auch nicht ganz falsch, wenn man einfach mal so ein bisschen die Entwicklung anguckt. Ich glaube, der ist seit 2014 da. Und in Würzburg hat man sich ja irgendwann mal überlegt, wir wollen wieder Profifußball haben. So ein Projekt aufgerufen, drei mal drei. Also in drei Jahren will man in die dritte Liga. Das hat man dann ziemlich schnell geschafft. Dann hat man gesagt, komm, jetzt in drei Jahren in die zweite Liga. Das ist dann glaube ich gleich im ersten Jahr passiert. Das heißt, man versucht ja in Würzburg halt auch so eine gewisse Euphorie wieder ein bisschen rund um den Verein zu entwickeln. Der ja, Max, du weißt es wahrscheinlich besser, die haben früher auch mal in der Bayern Liga ziemlich hoch gespielt. So in den 60ern rum kann es sein.
Es gab auch mal vor allem ein Würzburger Team, das auch in der zweiten Liga war. Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, dann müsste das der FV noch gewesen sein. Muss ich aber selber gerade nachgucken. Also Würzburg hat quasi eine Profifußballvergangenheit, der immer hinterher getraut wird. Und das war immer so ein bisschen die Frage, wie kriegt man das hin? Und dann gab es die Kickers als die Zuflucht dieser Hoffnungen. Da gab es auch im Hintergrund, glaube ich, da will ich mich jetzt nicht ganz drauf festnageln lassen, es ist schon alles ein bisschen länger her, dass ich mich damit beschäftigt habe, den Zusammenschluss von einigen Stadtmannschaften. Und dann eben jetzt dann diesen von dir angesprochenen Dreimal-Dreier-Plan, der dann zum Einmal-Einer-Plan wurde. Also gleich im ersten Jahr ging es dann hoch in die zweite Liga. Und jetzt setzt man sich ja durchaus auf höhere Ziele noch.
Ja, und man hat halt ja auch dann irgendwie vor der Spielzeit 2014, 2015 war das, da hat man so einmal den kompletten Kader ausgetauscht. Und ist dann halt direkt in die Liga hochgegangen. Hatte mit Amir Shapursade da auch so den großen Kicker, der die Mannschaft da angeführt hat, der jetzt glaube ich auch seine Karriere beenden musste. Also der fehlt dem Kickers eigentlich praktisch im ersten Jahr der zweiten Liga schon direkt. Aber man hat halt so Leute wie Duckfuss zum Beispiel, der auch schon seit mehreren Jahren in Würzburg spielt, hat, ja, ich glaube Robert Wulnikowski habe ich auch noch im Hinterkopf. Der war da glaube ich auch vorher noch, ist er noch? Klar, spielt er noch.
Ja, Wulle, das ist der Wulle. Das ist dieser Wulle eben.
Genau, der seit Ewigkeiten im Tor steht, hat doch früher auch mal bei Union gespielt, Sebastian, oder?
Wulnikowski war in der ersten Zweitliga-Zeit von Union zwischen 2001 und 2004 Torhüter, also auch dort. Und ja, deswegen kennt man ihn, aber wie alt ist er, 40?
Ja, aber nicht ganz, aber ja.
Worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist halt, in Würzburg hat man halt ein Projekt ausgerufen, was natürlich auch an vielen anderen Orten schon gemacht wurde, aber da hat es halt wirklich geklappt, hat neue Sponsoren gewonnen, hat eine neue Euphorie auch in der Stadt für den Fußball so ein bisschen losgetreten. Und ich glaube, dass das jetzt so gut läuft in Würzburg, hängt ein Maßgeblich damit zusammen, dass man halt auch nur 15 Tore bekommen hat. Also eine sehr gute Defensive da aufstellt, wo man natürlich auch jetzt sagt, ja, komm, Hollerbach, das passt, spielt da defensiv. Aber wenn man sich die Spiele von den Kickers, ich habe jetzt das gegen Stuttgart zum Beispiel gesehen, da sieht man halt auch, dass sie ja ein gutes, gutes, kompaktes Mittelfeld haben, was auch ziemlich aggressiv drauf geht. Die Spitzen laufen vorne an, versuchen den Ball so nach außen zu treiben. Also haben da auch so einen Plan. Und wenn sie selber den Ball haben, dann wird versucht, den sehr schnell in die Spitze zu leiten, damit dann vorne Dachfuss, Rama und Soriano dann da Torchancen kreieren. Und ja, da hatten viele in dieser Saison auch große Probleme mit der Spielweise der Würzburger.
Ja, Union auch. Die haben einfach nur sauglücklich 1-0 gewonnen, weil es irgendwie bei, glaube ich, Colin Kwan nicht wusste, wo ein Ball hin spielen soll und einfach von der Mittellinie fast durchgelaufen ist und auch drauf geschossen hat. Ansonsten war Würzburg Wahnsinn. Also die sind auch so sehr, ja, vielleicht ist dieses Gegenpressing so ein Ding der zweiten Liga mittlerweile.
Interessant, ja. Und wichtige Komponente noch. Sehr, sehr gut verstärkt und das relativ kostengünstig. Also man hat sich viele ablösefreie Spieler geholt. Tor-Erster-Neuzugang tatsächlich mit Jörg Siebenhandel von Admiral Wacker mit 500.000 Euro ein Torhüter. Und von den Neuzugängen allesamt hoffnungsvolle Talente, würde ich sagen, sehr, sehr viele auch mit einer wichtigen Rolle. Also Sebastian Neumann kam vom VfR Ahlen, in Innenverteidiger 19 Spiele gemacht, also alle Spiele, die man bisher für Würzburg machen konnte, in dieser Inserie. Tobias Schröck kam, der wird vielleicht auch noch ein Begriff sein, von Sonnenhof Groß-Aßbach, Marco Königs von Fortuna Köln, David Piesot, Rune Jordias vom SV Darmstadt 98, den haben wir alle in der ersten Liga zumindest kurz mal spielen sehen, Walde Rama von den 60ern, Patrick Weihrauch, sehr gutes Talent von den Bayern. Und all diese Neuzugänge, das sind jetzt alles Spieler, die über zehn Pflichtspiele gemacht haben für die Kickers. Da sieht man schon, sie haben sich nicht nur kostengünstig verstärkt und mussten da nicht ins tiefe Investment reingehen, sondern tatsächlich haben diese Spieler auch ihre Wirkung so entfaltet, dass sie zu einem wichtigen Bestandteil der Mannschaft wurden. Ich glaube, das ist auch noch ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt bei dem Erfolg, den wir jetzt Stand 17. Spieltag für die Kickers haben.
Darf ich noch eine schöne Geschichte kurz erzählen? Das habe ich jetzt gerade wirklich bei Wikipedia nachgelesen, muss ich zugeben, aber das finde ich enorm, weil es passt einfach zu diesem ganzen Würzburg-Thema jetzt. Der Aufstieg in die zweite Bundesliga wurde ja dann angestrebt, und dann steht hier tatsächlich, dass also die Finanzen, die finanziellen Mittel dafür dadurch erzeugt werden sollten, dass man 125.000 Boxbeutel pro Saison verkauft, 125.000 Einwohner hat wohl Würzburg, und der Preis ist dann 19,07 Euro, weil es das Gründungswahl der Kickers ist, und dann noch plus natürlich langfristige Bindungen, Sponsoren und so weiter. Aber dass man Boxbeutel verkauft, das finde ich ja, finde ich einfach eine superschöne Marketing-Aktion. Also, chapeau.
Ja, das ist halt einfach das Ding der Unterfranken, was denn? Was muss du dem das Deutschlands jetzt erklären, genau?
Weiß man das echt nicht? Oh krass, Entschuldigung, also Boxbeutel ist die typische bauchige Flasche für Wein, und Würzburg ist natürlich Weinregion, das weiß Max besser als ich. Und insofern, also Boxbeutel sind Weinflaschen.
Genau, und die haben eine besondere Form, die sie sich, glaube ich, irgendwann haben auch schützen lassen. Und da sind die Unterfranken ganz, ganz stolz drauf. Also auf den ganzen Weinfesten bestellen sie normalerweise einen Boxbeutel und nicht die anderen Flaschen. Aber es ist halt trotzdem noch Frankenwein drin. Ah, ah, ich darf jetzt nichts sagen. Ich war schon bei der Geschichte mit dem Würzburger FV und den krieg ich jetzt schon so unsicher. Jetzt darf ich nicht auch noch über den Wein lästern.
Hallo, es gibt hervorragenden Frankenwein.
Ja, das stimmt, es gibt hervorragenden Frankenwein. Man muss allerdings auch ein bisschen danach suchen. Also er ist jetzt auch nicht so hervorragend, wie sie immer tun. Ja, das ist halt leider so. Oh Gott, hoffentlich hört es keiner in der Heimat. Ich darf nicht mehr einreisen.
Naja, Kenner trinken Württemberger.
Ja, oder halt vielleicht einfach beim Bier bleiben. Gut. Aber vielleicht noch ganz kurz zu Würzburg und cleveren Ideen. Also das Stadion heißt ja Flyer Alarm Arena. Klar, das alte Traditionsunternehmen aus dem 19. Jahrhundert. Genau, vielleicht einer der Gründe, warum der Verein dann auch so erfolgreich ist, wo wir wieder bei erfolgreicher Wirtschaft im Süden Deutschlands dann sind, auch wenn es in dem Fall nicht bei den Württemberg ist. Und da, ich hoffe, ich verwechsel das jetzt nicht mit Heidenheimer. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es bei Würzburg so war, dass da momentan gesammelt wird, um den Namen des Stadions vom Sponsoren wieder zurückzukaufen. Also fast ein bisschen das Gegenmodell zum Volksparkstadion. Also da sollen die Fans dann Geld sammeln, um das Ding dann wieder seinem ursprünglichen Namen zuzuführen. Der Sponsor zeigt sich dafür aber wohl recht aufgeschlossen. Also er unterstützt das auch. Würde sich freuen, wenn sein Name dann da wieder verschwindet und man dann als Verein sagen kann, hier, das haben wir uns selber zurückerkauft.
Das kann ich mir jetzt ja gar nicht vorstellen, aus der Sicht von Flyeralarm.
Ja, ich rede auch als Blinde über Farben ein bisschen. Aber wir haben ja diese Vor- und Nachmittagsgespräche bei uns. Und da war ein Würzburger Fan, der das sehr ausführlich geschildert hat. Genau, und deswegen wusste ich das auch mit dem Boxbeutel, weil ich glaube beim Spiel gegen uns war das dann irgendwie mit einem guten Zweck verbunden. Also da waren wahrscheinlich die 125.000, oder was auch schon erreicht, und die zu überzähligen, sollten dann aus anderen Gründen einem guten Zweck zugeführt werden, wenn ich das nicht verwechsel. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, da haben wir auch wieder das Beispiel, da ist jemand mit Geld im Hintergrund und im Gegensatz zu anderen Vereinen wird das halt sehr sinnvoll eingesetzt, offensichtlich mit guten Ideen und einigermaßen kreativ. Tatsächlich ist die Region natürlich rein aus dem Sportaspekt her interessant. Also Würzburg hat nicht allzu viel Konkurrenz im Spitzensport. Der Weg nach Nürnberg ist relativ weit und die Nürnberger sind halt die Nürnberger, ehrlich gesagt. Die Bayern, klar, die gibt es überall. Und die ganze Stadt lechzt so ein bisschen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, denn der Würzburger an sich ist auch eher so ein bisschen gemütlich und schaut sich erstmal alles ein bisschen distanziert, kritisch an. Aber du hast mit den Sir Oliver Baskets ein zwischenzeitlich sehr erfolgreiches Basketball-Team gehabt, aber auch mit allem, was im regionalen Spitzensport dazugehört, d.h. drohende Insolvenz usw. Aber als bekannteste Sohn der Stadt, mit Dirk Nowitzki, auch ein absoluter Spitzensportler, auf den keiner in Würzburg auch nur irgendetwas kommen lassen würde. Den lieben sie ohne Ende. Und der Fußball, der war immer unterrepräsentiert. Und das, obwohl es infrastrukturell für die Würzburger viele Vorteile gibt. Also eigentlich dürfte es für die nicht so schwierig sein, aus ihrem Einzugsgebiet rund um die Stadt herum, ich würde sagen so einen Umkreis von 80 Kilometern, sich Talente zu holen, weil es eben keine so große Konkurrenz gibt, wie wenn du eben zum Beispiel in Heidenheim sitzt, wo es 15 Nachwuchsleistungszentren außenrum gibt, von anderen Bundesligisten und nicht vom DFB. Das ist in Würzburg eben anders. Das heißt, neben dem, was du richtigerweise ansprichst, dass es da auch einen industriellen oder einen Sponsorenhintergrund gibt, sind sie auch von ihrer Lage eigentlich relativ begünstigt. Deswegen ist es schon, Würzburg in der Zweiten Bundesliga kann man sich aus verschiedenen Aspekten schon ganz gut vorstellen. Und jetzt aktuell natürlich sieht es ja auch sehr, sehr hervorragend aus.
Manchmal bin ich ja froh, dass ich Fußballfan bin, doch noch.
Ich kann dir nur empfehlen, die Thomas Schaubo Eistigers.
Die Fußballer werden auch von S. Oliver gesponsert, ne?
Jaja klar, du kommst an S. Oliver nicht vorbei in Würzburg. Das ist klar. Aber da könnten wir jetzt noch ganz andere Ratio-Farm ulmen. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel aus der DEL sind die Thomas Schaubo Eistigers.
Guck dir das mal in Österreich an. Da hast du ein Potpourri der Namensvielfalt. Das ist ja fantastisch.
Das ist es nämlich.
Das wird fantastisch. Ich freue mich drauf. Ich glaube, das 96 wird einfach rausgestrichen.
Martin Kind Fanboys. Ja, wir können uns alle drauf freuen. Das wird schön. Lasst uns über den zweiten Aufsteiger sprechen, denn ich habe es schon angekündigt. Die Aufsteiger in die zweite Fußball-Bundesliga machen sich ganz herausragend. Wir haben gerade mit Platz 6 den Würzburgern besprochen und auf Platz 7 Dynamo Dresden. Die, denke ich, vielen Fußball-Fans sind aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen. Wenn wir uns allein die sportlichen Platzierungen der letzten Jahre anschauen, dann sehen wir ein fröhliches, oder nicht ganz so fröhliches, Hin- und Herwandern zwischen dritter Liga und zweiter Liga. Und jetzt eben wieder den Aufstieg geschafft unter Trainer Uwe Neuhaus mit einer überragenden Bilanz, unangefochten am Platz 1, 75 zu 35 Tore, war eine ganz, ganz tolle Drittligasaison für Dynamo Dresden. Und jetzt geht dieser Trend erstmal in den ersten 17 Spielen, auch in der zweiten Liga weiter. Und Dynamo Dresden steht eben jetzt gerade mit 27 Punkten, satte 13 Punkte vor dem Relegationsplatz. Das heißt, wenn man auch nur halbwegs das fortführen kann, was man jetzt in den ersten Spielen geschafft hat, dann wird man mit dem Abstieg in dieser Saison nichts zu tun haben. Stellt sich für mich die Frage, Sebastian, warum? Was macht Dresden besser, als so viele andere Mannschaften, die hinter ihnen stehen?
Also, der Trainer ist schon ein Unterschied. Sie haben sich halt irgendwie nach diesem, war das ein direkter Abstieg? Ich weiß gar nicht, oder? Sie haben sich Uwe Neuhaus geholt, vor der letzten Drittligasaison. Und der kann das halt. Also der kann eine Mannschaft zusammenstellen und der kann auch eine Mannschaft aus der dritten Liga in die zweite Liga bringen. Der kann auch eine Mannschaft in der zweiten Liga etablieren. Und plus, ich glaube in seiner, der so ein knappes Jahr Auszeit genommen, Uwe Neuhaus, der hat auch so loslassen können. Und ich nehme ihn jetzt als viel entspannter war, auch im Umgang mit Journalisten, selbst mit Berliner Journalisten, die er dann ja auch mal wieder getroffen hat diese Saison, als das vorher der Fall war. Also insofern tat ihm das gut. Und ich finde ihn eigentlich auch ein guter Trainer, der ist ja sehr, sehr akribisch, ein totaler Workaholic.
Ich wollte sagen, woher du ihn kennst, vielleicht wissen das dann.
Er war 7 Jahre Trainer bei Union von 2007, damals noch, glaube ich, 3. Liga, Regionalliga. Und dann über die 3. Liga, als die 3. Liga hieß, und dann in die 2. Liga.
War auch kein Zufall, dass ich dir die erste Frage zu Dresden gestellt habe, ganz ehrlich.
Ich finde ja, mal davon abgesehen, ist nie verwunderlich, dass Vereine, die aus der 3. Liga aufsteigen, in der 2. Liga am Anfang sehr gut abschneiden. Das ist vielleicht im Gegensatz zu Aufsteigen aus der 2. Liga in die 1. Liga ein bisschen anders, weil die auf eingespielte Teams zurückgreifen können. Das ist ja selten so, dass die Spieler gehen noch alle mit in die 2. Liga mit den Vereinen, weil halt auch das finanziell lukrativ ist. Die werden dann nicht weggekauft unbedingt nach so einem Aufstieg. Und die sind halt eingespielt. Deswegen ist das erstmal nicht so verwunderlich, dass die so gut dastehen, auch zur Halbserie. Wie das dann am Ende aussieht, ist dann immer noch eine andere Sache. Und Dresden ist ja jetzt auch so, wir sagen das jetzt immer häufiger die letzten Jahre, aber es ist ja auch kein normaler Aufsteiger. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein Verein wie Würzburg, der irgendwie da zu sehen muss, dass er, oh mein Gott, wir sind jetzt aus Versehen zu schnell aufgestiegen, das passt nicht in unseren Plan, jetzt muss irgendwie schnell das Stadion umgebaut werden und so weiter und so fort. Dresden hat ja ein perfektes Fußballstadion, kann man empfehlen, da hinzugehen, ist wirklich Wahnsinn, da mal drin zu sein, sehr steil, sehr laut, über 30.000 Plätze dann haben sie aber, also die haben ja auch keine Konkurrenz, weit und breit nicht, ja, also ich mag diesen Satz FC Bayern des Ostens nicht sagen, weil das überhaupt nicht zutrifft, aber die sind halt weit und breit der einzige Verein, der wirklich Leute zieht und jeder im Osten hat irgendwie eine Meinung zu Dynamo Dresden. das ist schon sehr stark und die Leute das zu monetarisieren und als Verein zu nutzen, das war glaube ich eher so Dresdens Problem, also die Professionalität in der Vereinsführung. Auseinandersetzung mit der Stadt über die Höhe der Stadionmiete, auch ein großes Thema und ein Thema, was Uwe Neuhaus auch diese Saison zur Weisgut getrieben hat, ist ja, dass Dresden ja als Verein quasi nichts besitzt. Die haben halt ein gemietetes Trainingsgelände und wenn sie dann im Stadion trainieren wollen, dann brauchen sie die Erlaubnis von dem Amt in der Stadt und die haben die Saison öfter mal verneint. Was auch immer die da in dem Stadion gemacht haben und warum das so ist. Und jetzt gibt es endlich so den Punkt, dass Dresden okay bekommen hat, ein echtes eigenes Trainingsgelände zu bauen. Das war ein super Nachteil bisher und ist es auch noch. Und deswegen, die entwickeln sich tatsächlich besser, als ich das dachte. Also auch dieser ganze Chaos-Faktor. Dresden hat halt dieses Traditionsvereinsproblem, dass sie halt ein sehr erfolgreicher Verein waren und dann halt sehr lange auch nicht. Und man immer irgendwie an diese Punkte zurückdenkt, irgendwie Europapokal. Das ist ja total absurd aus heutiger Sicht. Und wenn man das irgendwie mal komplett wegbekommt und mit Uwe Neus haben sie jemanden, der so wie Thorsten Liebeknecht irgendwie den Leuten relativ gut verklickern kann, Leute, hier Pokalsieg, Meisterschaft, Europapokal ist jetzt erstmal nicht. Wird auch auf absehbare Zeit kein Thema sein, auf sehr absehbare Zeit. Und wenn sie das irgendwie weiterhin bekommen, also diese Professionalisierung, dann haben die halt ein Potenzial. Rasen bei Sport Leipzig versucht ja, dieses ganze brachliegende Potenzial im ostdeutschen Fußball abzugreifen. Und Dresden hat aber halt diese Connections schon immer. Also die können das halt einfach eher nutzen theoretisch. Insofern, ja, vielleicht bessere Voraussetzungen eigentlich als meinetwegen Würzburg oder Heidenheim, weil sie halt einfach ein riesiges Fanpotenzial haben.
Aber halt auch eine totale Freakin-Runde irgendwie gespielt. Also haben im Pokal haben sie erstmal RBS Leipzig geschlagen, dann haben sie auswärts auch Hannover geschlagen, die haben Stuttgart 5-0 weggehauen, die haben Braunschweig geschlagen, gegen Heidenheim Würzburg Unentschieden gespielt, aber verlieren dann auch zu Hause gegen Aue 3-0. Das ist irgendwie schon ganz lustig irgendwie anzugucken. Aber wenn man sich auch die Kickernoten anguckt, die Top-Mannschaft der zweiten Liga in den Durchschnittswerten, ja, auf jeden Fall für einen Aufsteiger auch eine sehr, sehr starke Hinrunde.
Also was mich ein bisschen wundert, die haben halt so als Linksaußen Marvin Stefanjak und da hieß es die ganze Zeit irgendwie, der wechselt noch woanders hin und ist tatsächlich passiert, aber der spielt diese Saison bei Dresden zu Ende und hat dann einen 5-Jahres-Vertrag bei Wolfsburg unterschrieben. Was ich irgendwie total schräg finde, dass man jemanden verpflichtet, aber für nicht sofort und dann aber gleich 5 Jahre, also Wahnsinn.
Das heißt aber, er hat das Beste aus beiden Welten. Er muss jetzt noch nicht bei Wolfsburg spielen. Alles richtig gemacht, dieser Stefan Jak. Was für eine Art Fußball spielt denn Dresden? Kann man das auf so ein paar Stichpunkte runterbrechen?
Ja, sehr aggressiv auch. Also auch großer Kampffaktor dabei. Mit einer großen Spielfreude. Du hast auch so Leute dabei, wie Andreas Lamberts zum Beispiel, den man ja aus Düsseldorf halt noch kennt. ja, ich sag mal so, im Herbst seiner Karriere ist. Aber immer noch das alte Kampfschwein von früher ist, der nie aufgibt. Und ich finde, das ist so ein Merkmal auch für die ganze Truppe. Also die funktionieren auch als Mannschaft. Spielen ja auch viele noch aus der letzten Saison als große, mannschaftliche Geschlossenheit. Und spielen einen Fußball, der, wie sagt man das jetzt, ohne dass es abwertend klingt. Aber es ist halt schon eher so ein typischerer Zweitliga-Fußball, aus meiner Sicht. Kampfbetonterheit.
Sind auch ganz gut in Kontern, wenn ich so richtig mitbekommen habe. Haben da jetzt zwar gar nicht so viele Tore draus erzielt, aber das berühmte Umschaltspiel, bei Dresden sieht man das immer wieder in den Partien. Und da hat ihn, glaube ich, auch gerade am Anfang der Saison, was ich so mitbekommen habe, da hat ihn manches Mal auch die Einstattung, mit der Gegner gegen Dresden gespielt haben, ganz gut in die Karten gespielt. Das heißt, da hatte sich die Kontergefahr noch nicht so weit rumgesprochen und dann spielst du gleich mal gegen Nürnberg 1 zu 1, dann auswärts bei Union 2 zu 2, dann dieses berühmte Pokalspiel gegen Leipzig und dann kam schon der dritte Spieltag, wo man dann auch den FC St. Pauli schlägt. Mike wird sich schmerzlich erinnern. Dann kommst du genau in den selben oder in einen ähnlichen Lauf, den die Würzburger Kickers auch hatten. Und dann kommt man auch mit 27 Punkten gleich mit denen auf Platz 7 raus. Das ist nicht so schlecht. Ich muss da nochmal ausholen, auf die letzte Saison zurückgreifen, weil Abgänge nach der letzten Saison waren ja unter anderem Michael Hefele und Justin Eilers. Also Hefele nach England und Eilers zu Werder. Und da habe ich gedacht, die sind so souverän durch die dritte Liga marschiert und jetzt wird's ihnen wieder so gehen, wie bei den letzten Aufstiegen. Sie sind dann einfach mit der zweiten Liga überfordert. Und für mich tatsächlich noch fast die größte Ruhr als Würzburg, dass Dresden es dies Jahr so gut hinbekommt und sich da so einen starken Kader zusammengezimmert hat, der eben das nicht macht, sondern eben tatsächlich so souverän durch die Liga marschiert und wenn man sich die Namen der Zugänger anguckt, da hätte ich eigentlich nicht wirklich jemanden gekannt, außer Akaki Gugia, weil der vor kurzem halt noch bei uns war, der aus Brentford dann kam. Aber gut, ich war jetzt auch bei dem Spiel in Dresden vor Ort. Ja, was Sebastian schon gesagt hat, du hast natürlich eine unfassbare Atmosphäre da in dem Stadion. Also da laufen sicherlich auch manche Dinge falsch, aber von der Lautstärke her, von der Hingabe des Publikums ist das nach wie vor, finde ich, ich hoffe, ich trete jetzt niemanden zu nahe in Deutschland einzigartig. Also ich finde, da kann auch Dortmund locker einpacken. Und das kann so eine Mannschaft dann natürlich auch tragen und pushen und durch so eine Saison dann auch ein paar Plätze höher spielen, als du eigentlich von der Leistung her tatsächlich sein müsstest. Und Klaas hat es auch gesagt, die Kickernoten, demnach wäre Dresden sogar der beste Kader. Also ich glaube, die sind weiter von entfernt in der Rückrunde einzubrechen. Also ich glaube, die werden eine sehr entspannte Rückrunde auch spielen. Und wichtiger Abgang noch Quirin Moll, den wir vorhin so gelobt haben bei Eintracht Braunschweig, ist schon eine Weile her, liebe Hörer, ihr könnt ja noch mal zurückskippen, auch eben an direkten Konkurrenten verloren, den auch sehr, sehr gut ersetzt. Also da kommt einiges zusammen bei Dresden. Auch einiges zusammen kommt bei Fortuna Düsseldorf und das ist ein weiteres der Teams, bei denen ich nicht damit gerechnet hätte, die auf Platz 8 wieder zu finden, nach 17 Spieltagen in der zweiten Liga. Die Fortuna hat einen bemerkenswerten Platzierungsverlauf in den letzten Jahren hingelegt. Wir alle erinnern uns noch an die Erstligasaison unter Norbert Meyer, damals noch 2012, 2013. Dann den direkten Wiederausstieg unter, letztlich war der Trainer Oliver Reck nicht geschafft, Platz 6, Platz 10, Platz 14 und der Trainer Friedhelm Funkel. Und jetzt kommen wir eben zur Zwischenbilanz und sind auf Tabellenplatz 8. Wir haben die Dame im Intro gehört, Fortuna-Fan, vielleicht war es auch die Ente von Twitter, ich weiß es nicht. Grüße an der Stelle. Ja, was ist denn mit der Fortuna los? Wo liegt denn da jetzt auch das sportliche Mittel? Ist das vielleicht genau dieser Tabellenplatz 8, Sebastian, auf den die jetzt gerade einlaufen?
Ich verstehe es nicht. Ganz ehrlich, erklärt mir das, weil ich habe Fortuna gesehen, die haben unsere Heimserie beendet von einem Jahr ungeschlagen alte Fösterei mit einem 1-0 und hab die da nicht besser gesehen und mir ist unklar. Also ehrlich gesagt, so weit oben hätte ich sie nicht erwartet.
Klaas, ihr habt den Pokal 6 zu 1 gewonnen gegen Fortuna. Und dann später noch mal in der Liga 2 zu 2. Du musst es uns doch sagen können.
Also das war wirklich, da war Düsseldorf so schlecht, da haben sie die 96er vorne nicht angelaufen und hinten Böcke geschossen. Das war glaube ich so der Ausreißer nach unten in der Düsseldorfer Saison und nach dem Spiel habe ich auch gedacht, meine Güte, so ein Verein, der kann ja eigentlich nicht in dieser Liga überleben. Aber, ja, haben wir gegen 96 dann auch nochmal gespielt in dieser Saison, haben da 2-2 gespielt und da war das dann halt schon auch deutlich besser, auch wenn 96 da ein bisschen fahrlässig den Sieg außerhand gegeben hat. Ja, ist irgendwie so eine Truppe, glaube ich, wo man bei vielen Düsseldorfern, wenn man denen so ein bisschen auch bei Twitter folgt, die reißen sich viele Haare in der Saison aus. Es ist schon, glaube ich, ziemlich haarsträubend, was da zwischendurch passiert. Aber zwischendurch reißen sie sich dann irgendwie zusammen, haben ja auch einen Kader, wo man halt auch so ein paar Leute irgendwie draus kennen. Agbo Gouma, Talent aus Hoffenheim zum Beispiel, Rensing, alter Torwart aus München noch, Schmidt, zwar auch lange in der Bundesliga, Bellinghausen, man hat einen alten Kämpfer und im Sturm halt so einen Rufenhennigs. Also ich sag mal so vom Kader her für die zweite Liga sollte das eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht sein. Aber so eine Konstanz reinzubringen und dass sie halt in jedem Spiel wirklich 90 Minuten im Zweitliganiveau erreichen, das kriegen sie im Moment noch nicht hin. Woran das so genau liegt, kann ich auch nicht sagen. Ich glaube, das Spiel gegen Union war ja auch relativ unverdient der Sieg, oder? Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, wart ihr da ziemlich überrascht, dass dieser Punkte, dass die Punkte nach Düsseldorf gegangen sind. Ja, also ist glaube ich eine Truppe, die jetzt auch vielleicht sogar ein bisschen zu hoch bewertet steht in der Liga.
Na ja, ist so. In der Halbtabelle auf Tabellenplatz 12 mit in Anführungszeichen nur drei Siegen, drei Unentschieden, zwei Niederlagen und auswärts aber auch dreimal gewonnen, aber viermal unentschieden, damit vierter Tabellenplatz in der Auswartstabelle. Vielleicht ist es mit einer Tordifferenz von acht zu sieben Toren übrigens. Also ehrlich gesagt, it smells like Friedhelm Funkel a little bit.
Ja, ich wollte es gerade sagen, es stinkt nach Funkelfußball. Aber ich habe mir jetzt gerade nochmal den Kader angeschaut, der ist ja wirklich mit Spielern gespickt, die man ja kennt. Und auch die Erstliga-Erfahrungen haben. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich hatte mich ursprünglich, das hätte mir jetzt mein Düsseldorf erklären müssen, ich hatte mich ja gewundert, dass Friedhelm Funke überhaupt noch verpflichtet wird, weil man ja wusste, was man mit Funke bekommt. Man bekommt halt jemanden, der einen Verein durchaus in der Liga halten kann, aber irgendwie spielerisch weiterentwickeln und so. Dafür war Friedhelm Funke in der Vergangenheit ja nicht mehr bekannt.
Ja, aber in der vergangenen Saison brauchte Düsseldorf genau das. Und hier kommt halt aus Neues direkt um die Ecke. Passt doch. Schön ist es nicht, aber die wollten dann in der Liga bleiben. Es klingt perspektiv, wie man Friedhelm Funke verpflichtet, das sehe ich ja auch ein. Aber ich meine, die Düsseldorfer waren ja letzte Saison wirklich halt auch auf einem Weg, wo man halt dachte, naja, das wird ganz bitter, ne?
Aber, ja, bin gespannt, wohin das führt und wie lange Friedhelm Funke dann halt so bei Düsseldorf bleibt. Also weil, ich glaube, Düsseldorf ist so eine Mischung aus der Anspruch im Verein und dann halt, wie der Verein geführt wird, dass das halt manchmal ein bisschen auseinandergeht. Und vielleicht kriegen sie es wieder hin. Mal sehen. Da ist vielleicht Friedhelm Funke genau der Richtige, der so ein Verein so ein bisschen sediert. Ich bin kein großer Freund, oder?
Das ist jetzt kaum zu tragen gekommen.
Das ist schon auf jeden Fall das Zitat des Tages.
Ja, also wir können es uns alle nicht so ganz erklären und wir werden ja jetzt auch nicht bei jedem Verein hier sagen können. So, daran liegt es. Und an Tabellenplatz 8 ist er jetzt auch erstmal nur an Tabellenplatz 8, aber durchaus eben erstaunlich. Ich denke, das haben wir alle auch herausgearbeitet. Und dahinter auf Tabellenplatz 9 nach 17 Spieltagen landet der Club aus meiner fränkischen Heimat. Bei dem die Divergenz zwischen Heimspiel und Auswärtsspiel noch viel krasser ist. In der Heimtabelle nur Tabellenplatz 14, 3 Mal zu Hause gewonnen, Auswärts die stärkste Mannschaft der Liga. 4 Mal gewonnen, 18 zu 18 Tore. Und der Club wäre nicht der Club, wenn er nicht auch schon wieder seinen Trainer gewechselt hätte. René Weiler wurde durch Alois Schwarz ersetzt. Er ist jetzt 175 Tage im Amt und damit schon länger als damals. Valerian Ismael. Herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu. Und macht sich ja auch nicht so schlecht. Und trotzdem ist es so eine komische Zwischendrinnsaison wieder für den Club. Und es schlägt immer von einem in das andere Extrem hinein. Wer kann mir denn von euch sagen, warum dem so ist? Warum kriegen die das denn nicht irgendwie mal kontrolliert? Warum kriegen die keine Konstanz rein?
Ich hätte jetzt geantwortet, weil sie keine Konstanz haben. Aber wenn du mir sagst, warum kriegen sie keine Konstanz rein, sie haben ja ihren Trainer nach Anderlecht verloren, sehe ich das richtig? Das hat mich ja schon so ein bisschen gewundert. Aber Alois Schwarz finde ich ein sehr starker Trainer, der ja vorher in Sandhausen sehr gute Arbeit geleistet hat. Und fand, glaube ich, dass der sich erstmal an den Club gewöhnen musste und umgekehrt wahrscheinlich auch. Und es ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man jetzt festhält, bitte haltet auch Alois Schwarz fest. Ja, egal. Sie haben gegen Fürth, glaube ich, verloren. Trotz solcher Sachen, ja, das ist dann halt auch nur ein Spiel in der Hinrunde gewesen.
Ja, das war damals die vierte Niederlage in Folge. Da hat schon ganz schön der Baum gebrannt. Da stand man dann auf der Weltplatz 18.
Aber man kann ja nicht dann irgendwie anfangen, alles wegzuwerfen, was man an Vorbereitung hatte, bloß wegen ein paar Spielen. Das muss man dann halt auch mal aushalten. Und ich glaube, wenn der Verein diesen Punkt dann auch erreicht hat und den hat er offensichtlich erreicht, dass sie halt sagen, ist jetzt der richtige Trainer, dann einfach mal konstant reinzubringen. Und vielleicht hat man dann halt, wenn man nicht so auf den Trainer wechselt, dann irgendwann auch mal so ein Team, was irgendwie so eine Spielidee verkörpert. Ich kenne Nürnberg nur aus, also für mich ist jedes Spiel, das Union gegen Nürnberg macht ein Freakspiel. Also es gibt, da ist nichts normales. In der letzten Saison hat Union 2-0 in Nürnberg geführt zur Halbzeit und 6-2 verloren. In der Hinrunde führen sie 3-1 und spielen 3-3 und so weiter. Diesmal haben sie ganz lässig 2-0 verloren. Also das ist irgendwie sowieso nicht berechenbar für mich. Und vielleicht ist das aber auch so ein bisschen das Grundproblem von Nürnberg. Sie sind halt an sich überhaupt nicht konstant in allem, was sie machen. Und wenn man jetzt mal beim Trainer anfängt, von dem kann man ja überzeugt sein und dann hält man durch und dann baut man da die Mannschaft auf, dann wird es vielleicht mal was auf Dauer.
Ich denke, ein Punkt ist sicher halt die Offensive, oder?
Entschuldigung, ich wollte ja nicht reinquatschen. Du wolltest über die Offensive sprechen, kurz?
Richtig? Ja, und dann darfst du sehr gern dein sagen, weil sie haben mit Guido Burgstaller nicht nur den erfolgreichsten Torjäger, sondern auch nach Hannover die meisten Schüsse pro Spiel.
Ja, und Burgstaller ist halt auch wirklich ein Tier, ne? Also wirklich ein ganz starker Stürmer, der glaube ich auch schon kundgetan hat, dass er gleich am liebsten weg will, erste Liga spielen und so. Das kommt ja auch mal ziemlich gut an. Aber ich habe die da, als ich mit Hannover war, ich war in Nürnberg und dann auch nur gedacht, Wahnsinn, also ein Riesentyp, unglaublich beweglich, große Körperkraft, guten Zug zum Tor, also wirklich so ein Stürmer, wie man in sich wünscht, hat funktioniert. Was ich eben noch kurz sagen wollte, die Nürnberger kamen jetzt halt auch wirklich von ganz unten, die waren Tabellenletzter noch am 6. Spieltag, da haben sie jetzt so langsam hochgekämpft. Ich finde, man kann ja auch nochmal an diese fantastischen Spiele da erinnern, die verlieren 6-1 gegen Braunschweig, die verlieren 5-4 gegen Bochum, also da sind ja auch schon wirklich Mannschaften daran gescheitert, wenn sowas innerhalb von zwei Wochen passiert und dass sie sich dann so gefangen haben und als 96 da in Nürnberg gespielt hat. Die Niederlage, die war komplett verdient. Nürnberg hat eine Mannschaft da aufs Feld gestellt, die gut zusammen gearbeitet hat, die kaum eine Möglichkeit zugelassen hat und dann, wie du halt sagst, haben sie vorne eine Offensive, die halt gut funktioniert. Ich habe mir diesen, ich weiß nicht, wie man ihn ausspricht, Mattausch, aus Augsburg, glaube ich, kam, der ja auch aus meiner Sicht einer der Besten in der zweiten Liga ist, also ein ganz großes Potenzial hat und über kurz oder lang auch wieder in der ersten Liga landen wird und bei Burgstaller würde ich es genauso sehen.
Mit Kevin Müll weit noch den stärksten Vorlagengeber jetzt nach 17 Spielen und 12 der 30 Tore tatsächlich aus Standard-Situationen heraus. Das ist halt immer auch ein Pfund, wenn du so etwas hinkriegst.
Ich wollte nur sagen, die Defensive ist dann aber halt genauso nicht so voll am Ende. Also, 29 Gegentore ist halt auch zu halb sehr katastrophal. Ich kenne das von Union aus der letzten Saison, da hatte Union, glaube ich, ähnlich ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis, also auch mit so vielen Gegentoren. Das reißt sich halt voll runter. Das wird bei Nürnberg, wenn es halt diese Anfangsspiele gewesen sein mit diesen Freaky-Ergebnissen, die da halt jetzt so reinspielen und wenn man dann bloß auf die Tabelle guckt, dann sieht man das. Aber, ja. Also offensiv sehr stark und es wäre jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass Nürnberg irgendwie von ganz unten in der Saison anfängt und dann irgendwie Relegation spielt oder so.
Sounds familiar, ja. Könnte aber auch genauso sein, dass sie wieder abstürzen. Tatsächlich, also Spiele mit dem Klub sind immer ein Blick wert, wenn man neutraler Beobachter ist.
Denn sie haben eben sowohl die meisten Schüsse, die zweitmeisten Schüsse aufs gegnerische Tor, als auch, dass sie die meisten Schüsse aufs Tor zulassen pro Spiel. Das heißt, da geht es munter hin und her. Und das drückt ja genau dieses Torverhältnis von 30 zu 29 Toren dann auch aus. Das heißt, liebe Hörer, wenn ihr mal reinschnuppern wollt in der zweiten Liga, so ein Klubspiel, das geht unter neutralen Gesichtspunkten schon. Und die Klubberater, naja, die haben sie inzwischen schon dran gewöhnt, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Das ist genau das, was ich am Anfang über die zweite Liga so meinte, da ist Nürnberg eigentlich wirklich so das Passporto-Tor, dass man halt wirklich drauf gucken kann. Es gibt kein Spiel, das dominiert wird, sondern es geht immer hoch und runter. Und wenn du sagst, die haben genauso viele Schüsse gefangen, wie sie gemacht haben, dann spricht das eigentlich für die Liga.
Ein bisschen aber auch gegen den Klub, ehrlich gesagt.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Nun ja, und dann kommen wir zu quasi der Symbol-Mannschaft, ohne dass ich sich jemals darum beworben hätte, der zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga, der SV Sandhausen, der immer herhalten muss, für Vergleiche. Nächstes Jahr werdet ihr gegen Sandhausen spielen. Das hat man sich, glaube ich, auch in Stuttgart und in Hannover zugeraunt. Desirée, wie ist es denn jetzt dann, gegen Sandhausen zu spielen?
Ja, das war ja immer so der, wie soll ich sagen, der Running Gag. Der Hansi Müller hat das ja wirklich tatsächlich selbst so formuliert. Das wollen wir doch nicht, jetzt sind wir so weit. Du hast, da bin ich wieder ein bisschen bei der Romantik von Klaas vorhin. Du hast tatsächlich, wenn du nur eine Zweitligasaison hast, in Anführungszeichen, wenn es nicht zu regel wird, hast du natürlich dann irgendwie diesen Charme von irgendwie Mannschaften, gegen die du nie gespielt hast. Und da gehören natürlich auch Sandhausen dazu oder noch nie natürlich Liga gespielt hast. Und du triffst dann da in kleinen Stadien auf wahnsinnig sympathische Vereine mit Fans. Und also, ja, es ist halt dann einfach die Frage, hält uns das auf Dauer bei der Stange und das bezweifle ich eben. Und SV Sandhausen ist auch so ein Spiel gewesen. Also wir haben da zwar gewonnen mit 2-1. Und das war aber gleich, das war glaube ich am dritten Spieltag gleich mal so die Erfahrung, wie ist das da so? ich hätte es unseren Recken auch zugetraut, dass sie da wieder verlieren, so nach dem Motto, ach Sandhausen, schaffen wir schon. Und ich glaube, die Sandhausener werden da einfach gerne mal unterschätzt. Und entsprechend sind auch die Spielergebnisse dann. Also zum Beispiel Sandhausen Dynamo 2.0 finde ich jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen ungewöhnlich. Und wenn Dresden noch so sehr der Aufsteiger ist, aber da hätte ich Sandhausen nicht irgendwie vorne vermutet. Das sind also für mich die Spielergebnisse für Sandhausen in der Runde tatsächlich zum Teil ein bisschen ungewöhnlich. Ich meine, ich will jetzt keine Wunden aufreißen, aber 3-0 gegen St. Pauli, das finde ich ein krasses Ergebnis irgendwo. Dann hätte ich St. Pauli eigentlich normalerweise vorne gesehen. Also ist so ein bisschen, gibt es natürlich auch viele Unentschieden und viele 0-0s, aber keine Ahnung. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Wir haben die ja bald wieder im Februar. Das ist das dritte Spiel, das müsste im Februar noch sein. Und da kommt dann Sandhausen in die Arena bei uns. Da müsste man das Spiel dann eigentlich gewinnen, hoffe ich.
Also ganz weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, will sie sich da nicht, das hört man schon eindeutig raus.
Ja, ja, ein bisschen noch mit einer muss noch hinten festhalten.
Ich glaube, viel wird ja an dem neuen Trainer Kenan Kocsak festgemacht, den sie verpflichtet haben, nachdem Alois Schwarz dann halt von Nürnberg abgeworben wurde. Ich glaube schon, dass das irgendwie tatsächlich, also sie spielen nicht anders als unter Alois Schwarz, habe ich das Gefühl. Ja, also das ist halt das übliche Rezept, irgendwie kompakt und sie haben halt ihre Leute bei zusammengehalten, also ich bin immer froh, wenn Andrew Wooten, bevor er Sandhausen gegen Union spielt, schon mal getroffen hat irgendwo, weil dann trifft er vielleicht mal nicht gegen Union. Ja, das ist so das Ding. Und dann haben sie Tim Kister als Abwehrchef, der super stark spielt und ja, vielleicht verlieren sie halt aber die Spiele. Das ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem, dann zum Saisonende. Die sind halt, ihr habt das ja vorhin gesagt, irgendwie so der typische Zweitligis, der immer herhalten muss, also das, was früher Mappen war, das ist jetzt Sandhausen, aber die leiden dann natürlich auch unter solchen Sachen. Also sie profitieren nicht so stark von diesem ganzen Süddeutschland-Bonus, wie andere Vereine dort unten. die mögen zwar dort herkommen, aber sind halt auf, sind überhaupt nicht auf Rosen gebettet. Und ich hatte mich sehr gewundert, dass sie Markus Kahl, früher im Defensiven Mittelfeld bei Union, dann bei Kaiserslautern, dass der halt von Kaiserslautern, weil die ja auch finanzielle Probleme hatten, da so quasi Vertragsende, keinen neuen Vertrag bekommen hatte und dann bei Sandhausen gelandet ist, aber überhaupt kein Stammspieler ist. Das heißt, die haben ein sehr eingespieltes Team und profitieren halt davon. Und das Kenan Korshak, das halt so hinbekommen hat, also würde ich sagen, ist für mich so die Leistung schlechthin.
Ja, und haben sich auch ganz gut verstärkt, muss man auch sagen. Also Sandhausen schafft es schon auch dann immer wieder von Saison zu Saison, sich auch durch gute Transfers in der Liga zu halten. Thomas Bledl, jetzt im offensiven Mittelfeld, Leih von Ingolstadt, 18 Spiele gemacht, Lukas Höhler, Mittelstürmer, erst viermal getroffen, aber immerhin. Gute Ergänzung eben zum angesprochenen Andrew Wuthen mit seinen neun Treffern. Markus Kahl im defensiven Mittelfeld von Lautern gekommen, Daniel Gordon, Innenverteidiger vom KSC und ein Name, der vielleicht noch einigen Leuten was sagen wird. Sogutha Pasu läuft auch von Sathausen inzwischen auf. An dem kann man sich ja auch noch erinnern. Dem ist tatsächlich so. Und man muss sich ja wirklich so ein bisschen vor Augen führen, die jüngere Story von Sathausen in der Saison 2012, 2013, nach dem Aufstieg in die zweite Bundesliga, 17. Platz und dennoch nicht abgestiegen, weil der MSV Duisburg seine Lizenzauflagen nicht erfüllen konnte. Aber dann sich jedes Mal recht souverän in der Liga gehalten. Oder was heißt recht souverän? Sehr souverän sogar. Also mit Alos Schwarz haben 44 Punkte in der Saison 2013, 2014, 39 Punkte in der Saison 2015, 40 Punkte in der Saison 2015, 2016 und jetzt eben aktuell stehen wir schon bei 24 Punkten auf dem Tabellenplatz 10. Da kann man eigentlich alle Hüte nutzen, wie ich finde. Dann wollen wir dem auch nichts hinzuzufügen, sondern dann wollen wir über den VfL Bochum sprechen. Auch ein sehr interessanter Verein, nicht zuletzt dank seines Trainers, würde ich sagen. Gert-Jan Verbeek und die Bochumer kriegen es aber auch irgendwie nicht so hin. Mike, da kannst du gerne mal was dazu sagen. Die kriegen immer nicht so ihre PS auf die Straße. Das ist so Ich meine, wir erinnern uns wahrscheinlich alle noch an die Erstliga-Zeiten vom VfL Bochum. Das wird aber jüngeren Bundesliga-Fans dann tatsächlich schon schwerer fallen. Und man hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck, vielleicht haben die den Absprung nach oben wieder raus, aus dieser sich immer mehr zementierenden zweiten Liga verpasst. Jetzt dann schon das sechste Jahr in der zweiten Liga. Ne, siebte sogar schon.
Vor der Saison, glaube ich, in der Eigenwahrnehmung auch, mit der Maßgabe schon, um den Aufstieg zumindest mitreden zu wollen, sieht es jetzt eher nicht so nach aus. Und so richtig erklären, warum kann ich dir das auch nicht? Weil ich finde schon, dass der Kader das auch schon hergeben könnte. Ich halte noch dazu auch von Gerd-Jan Per Beek eigentlich einiges, auch wenn er in seiner Art immer ein bisschen schrullig ist, auch gerade in der Außenwirkung. Weil es auch gerade beim Spiel bei uns so, als er sich nach dem Spiel wohl in der Pressekonferenz einigermaßen daneben genommen hat. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich denke, dass natürlich dann auch so eine Sache dazukommt. Ich sage ja immer, die ersten zwei, drei Spieltage in der Liga sind in der zweiten Liga eigentlich schon die halbe Miete. Und Nürnberg ist eigentlich der eine Ausreißer, der da immer das Gegenbeispiel liefert, weil die immer scheiße starten und dann am Ende doch gut dastehen. Und Bochum ist eigentlich ganz gut gestartet. Die haben nämlich gleich erstmal gegen Union gewonnen und in Karlsruhe zumindest einen Punkt geholt. Aber ich glaube, dann kam bei denen der Knackpunkt, dass sie nämlich bei Astoria Waldorf rausgeflogen sind im Pokal. Das war dann etwas, was denen alles so ein bisschen den Boden weggezogen hat. Haben dann gegen Hannover zumindest noch einen Punkt geholt, aber dann eben in Würzburg verloren. Und dann ging es auch nicht so richtig gut weiter, sondern eher durchwachsen. Und sie haben natürlich auch viele der Begriff Freak-Spiele von Sebastian Passé vielleicht ganz gut. Also sie haben 5 zu 4 gegen Nürnberg, haben 4 zu 2 gegen Aue, 2 zu 2 Sandhausen, 2 zu 2 Dresden. Also auch da ist ja immer was los. Und es ist aber eben nicht die Konstanz da drin, mit der man sagen könnte, wir spielen dauerhaft da oben. Und warum das so ist, ja, das kann ich dir auch nicht genau sagen. Ich glaube, das wüssten sie auch gerne.
Ich glaube, die hatten ein echtes Problem mit Abgängen diese Saison. Also Simon Terotte hatten wir ja schon, dass er zur Schuttgart gegangen ist, der einfach der Kampf von Union, wo er quasi für 5 Treffer in der Saison gut war. Und hat dann durchgestartet, leider ablösefrei nach Bochum gegangen. Und Onur Bulut nach Freiburg, Thierry Lohan, Ne Quatsch, Terazzino Hoffenheim und Andreas Lute Torhüter nach Augsburg. Und ein Teil davon auch noch ablösefrei. Das muss man dann irgendwie erstmal kompensieren. Und ich glaube, das haben sie nicht ganz hinbekommen. Und deswegen sieht es halt auch so, vielleicht ist es das Geheimnis irgendwie, dieses nicht konstant spielen, wenn die Neuzugänge nicht sofort funktionieren, ist ja dann halt so. Obwohl es eigentlich eine gute Mannschaft ist an sich.
Gut, Lute hatte natürlich so seine eigene Geschichte zusammen mit Gert-Jan Verbeek. Da gab es einen Facebook-Posting, in dem er sich nicht so toll geäußert hat, über seine, ja, Nicht-Nominierung für ein Spiel.
Ja, das passiert ja bei Spielern schon manchmal. Ich finde das nicht so dramatisch.
Ja, vielleicht liegt tatsächlich auch dieses Hin und Her im Spiel vom VfL Bochum am Spiel des VfL Bochums. Also, Gert-Jan Verbeek ist ja bekannt als Trainer, der viel Wert auf die Offensive legt. Ich glaube, einer der wenigen Trainer, der sagen würde, lieber ein 3 zu 2, denn ein 1 zu 0. Und ehrlich gesagt, genauso lesen sich auch ganz viele Ergebnisse vom VfL. Insgesamt kommt dann nach 17 Spielen 24 erzielte Treffer und 28 gefangene Treffer bei Raus, bei 22 Punkten. Das ist okay, aber das reicht nicht nach oben und nach unten hin. Darin muss man jetzt in der Rückrunde schon noch was draufpacken, damit man sich da immer in sicheren Gefilden bewegen wird. Aber ich finde tatsächlich, dass Untergard Jan Verbeek Bochum immer solche Saisons gespielt hat. Es macht meistens Spaß, sich Spiele des VfL anzuschauen, weil in der Regel immer etwas passiert und weil es eine Mannschaft ist, die etwas machen möchte. Das ist ja auch nicht immer gegeben in der zweiten Liga. Es gibt ja auch viele, die erstmal nur verhindern wollen und dann mal gucken, ob ihnen was in den Schoß fällt. Also der VfL ist da ein bisschen kreativer unterwegs, aber ohne eine stabile Defensive geht halt nach oben einfach nicht mehr.
Ja, das ist vielleicht dann auch der Punkt, Max. Also das glaube ich, die Defensive ist, wenn wir jetzt mal die Mannschaften vorne weggucken, auch die, die uns überrascht haben, dann sind das ja die Mannschaften, die irgendwie es verstehen, erstmal auch nichts zuzulassen. Und vielleicht ist das einfach nicht die Spielweise für die Zweite Liga. Also wenn man nicht die Spieler hat dafür, also ich hatte es vorhin gesagt, mit dem Kader, wenn man Aufstiegskandidat sein möchte oder da oben mitspielen möchte, braucht man schon ein paar Spieler, die über eine höhere individuelle Klasse als ein regulärer Zweite Liga-Spieler verfügen, um halt dann in solchen Drecks-Spielen, früher gab es noch den VfR Ahlen für sowas, aus 0-0-1-0 für die eigene Mannschaft zu machen. Und ich glaube, Bochum fehlt tatsächlich, also denen fehlt auch dieser Terrode einfach wirklich sehr.
Irgendwie ist Bochum ja wirklich so, aus meiner Sicht, so der letzte kleine Traditionsverein, der irgendwie so ein bisschen übrig geblieben ist, habe ich das Gefühl, dass da alles noch so geblieben ist, vielleicht noch Karlsruhe so ein bisschen, aber wenn man nach Bochum fährt, wie ich das diese Saison gemacht habe, dann ist das immer schön, weil es ein sehr schönes Fußballstadion ist, und man kommt da rein und denkt eigentlich so, jetzt laufen gleich Rhein-Pfandoynhofen und Thomas Stäbel wieder auf mit Edouard. Genau so. Das ist so ein bisschen die richtig schöne Erinnerung, die man da so dann direkt wieder wachrufen kann. Und ja, ich bin froh, dass der VfL Bochum so gut dann immer doch noch über die Runden kommt. Ich meine, die stehen jetzt im Mittelfeld der Tabelle. Weder nach oben noch nach unten wird wahrscheinlich viel passieren diese Saison. Und ja, ich glaube, damit du halt so eine Saison wie Braunschweig spielst, zum Beispiel, ich glaube, da kann man die Vereine auch irgendwie vergleichen. Dann brauchst du halt auch einfach Glück, dass so ein Spieler wie zum Beispiel Peniel im Lapper halt nicht nur 6 Tore macht, sondern vielleicht halt mal 12 oder so. Also dass die halt dann mal so eine richtig gute Saison spielen und ich glaube, das ist einfach auch schwer planbar. Das kannst du dir zwar immer vornehmen, aber spielen halt unglaublich viele Faktoren mit rein. Ich glaube, das zeigt die zweite Liga auch jedes Jahr wieder, dass Erfolg schwerer planbar ist, als vielleicht man sich das so vorher vornimmt irgendwie.
Und gleichzeitig zeigt die zweite Liga, dass man sich aber auch mit Prognosen nicht so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen sollte. Es reicht eine Serie von 6 gewonnenen Spielen am Stück und dann kannst du dich, wenn du dich vorher eher mit Tendenz nach unten in der Tabelle gefunden hast, auf einmal hast du dann wieder den Anschluss nach oben, also komplett abschreiben, würde ich den VfL jetzt auch noch nicht.
Aber es ist schwer, in diesem, also dort so ein bisschen Euphorie rein zu bekommen. Ja, also ich glaube, die leiden halt so, also dadurch, dass sie halt nicht mehr Bundesliga sind, stehen sie halt total im Schatten der anderen Ruhrpott-Vereine. Und die haben jetzt, ich habe geguckt, 16.000 Zuschauerschnitt, ist jetzt wirklich nicht berauschend so. Und gerade bei der Größe des Stadions, und ich kann mich erinnern, wenn ich jetzt in der Zweite Liga schaue und dann hoch rum, sieht man ja erst mal nur leere Plätze, weil ja so links vor allem so die Stirnseiten des Stadions sind halt eher besetzt und die Gegend gerade ist halt so relativ leer. Und es sieht sehr, sehr trist erstmal aus.
Und das, obwohl sie zu Hause noch umgeflagen sind.
Ja, wie gesagt, 16.000 Zuschauerschnitt ist jetzt vielleicht okay, aber es ist jetzt auch, es spricht nicht von Euphorie.
Jaja, ja, absolut richtig. Das heißt, wir können nicht davon ausgehen, dass sich Bochum aus dieser Liga verabschiedet in dieser Saison. Weder in die eine noch in die andere Richtung. Aus dieser Runde verabschieden werden wir jetzt aber natürlich die beiden Absteiger. Die können jetzt nicht mehr, die wollen jetzt nicht mehr. Es war lang genug jetzt, dass sie sich mit der zweiten Liga auseinandergesetzt haben. Jetzt müssen sie gehen.
Jaja, macht dich ruhig lustig über uns.
Sorry, es lag einfach so auf der Hand. Also noch mal ganz herzlichen Dank an Desirée Wolff bei Twitter. Ette Tösi Röö verfolgt sie. Sie freut sich darüber und es ist auch immer sehr lesenswert. Desirée, es hat großen Spaß gemacht, dass ich dich mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk mit dabei haben durfte.
Ja, ich bin ja froh, dass ich diese Zweitliga-Chance hier bekommen habe. Und hat großen Spaß gemacht. Ich wäre gerne noch bis zum Schluss geblieben, aber geht leider nicht.
Geht leider nicht. Und ebenso großen Dank an Klaas Reese, Edge Sport Kultur, auf Twitter. Ihr hört ihn hoffentlich ganz oft bei Collinas Erben. Ihr freut euch über seine Gifts, die er zu jedem Bundesligaspieltag sammelt. Folgt ihm auf Twitter. Vielen Dank, Klaas, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Schön, dass du dir mal Zeit für die zweite Liga genommen hast. Und mich hat es gefreut, dass ich mit Vertretern der Spitzenteams und mit Mike sprechen durfte.
Wir im Rausgehen einfach noch mit der Blutgräte rausgehen. Das hat echt Klasse oder halt auch nicht, Klaas.
Aber ich fürchte, Mike wird sich furchtbar rächen und unsere Abwesenheit nutzen, um irgendwelche fiesen Parolen gegen oben auszuteilen. Und das höre ich mir dann einfach am Podcast an.
Ja, das liegt jetzt in seiner Hand. In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank für eure Zeit. Und bis bald, hoffentlich mal.
Sehr gerne, bis bald. Tschüss.
Wir winken Desirée und Klaas zu und wenden uns, mit leicht bemütigendem Gedanken natürlich noch an die beiden, jetzt der Spielvereinigung Greute Fürth zu, denn die steht auf Tabellenplatz 12 mit 21 Punkten, 17 zu 27 Toren und eines das Teams, das auch schon seinen Übungsleiter gewechselt hat. Man ging in die Saison mit Stefan Ruttenbeck, der ja auch schon letzte Saison im Dienst war, Nachfolger von Mike Biskens damals, wer sich noch erinnert, aber Ende November war es dann so weit. Seine Tage bei Fürth waren gezählt und jetzt haben wir mit Janos Radoki, wo auch bestätigt wurde, er bleibt der neue Trainer, ein Nachfolger von ihm. Was ist denn in Fürth passiert, Mike, dass man da die Reißlein hier in Form eines Trainer-Rauswurfes ziehen musste?
Tja, zu wenig offensichtlich oder zumindest zu wenig Positives. Also ich glaube, man hat vielleicht, ich will nicht sagen unterschätzt, aber zumindest halt die Abgänge, die man hatte, eben nicht adäquat ersetzen können. Ich denke, insbesondere Marco Stiepermann tut weh, auch wenn er nur zu einem Zweitligisten, nämlich Bochum, gegangen ist und da nicht so richtig brilliert momentan. Aber trotzdem fand ich, war das immer ein sehr wichtiger Mann für Fürth. Gleiches ist Benedikt Röcker. Als Innenverteidiger habe ich auch immer sehr gut wahrgenommen und da gab es vielleicht ein bisschen zu viele. Und ja, Rutenberg tue ich mich schwer mit, weil von dem habe ich eigentlich immer sehr viel gehalten. Und der hat es aber in Fürth nicht so richtig auf die Ergebnisse bringen können. Und ja, jetzt steht man halt da, wo man steht, ist tatsächlich einer von nur zwei Vereinen, der es geschafft hat, gegen St. Pauli zu verlieren. Und das sagt dann auch schon einiges. Und ich glaube, dass man in Fürth sehr froh ist, wenn diese Saison mit einem blauen Auge irgendwie vorbei ist. Ich meine, die haben sieben Punkte Vorsprung vorm Redigationsplatz. Das sollte eigentlich locker reichen. Aber insgesamt hat man sich da, glaube ich, von der Saison doch einiges anderes erwartet. Auf der anderen Seite geht es ja da jetzt draußen rum so ein bisschen vorwärts. Also Stadionumbau geht voran und ja, mal schauen.
Hin und her gerissen ist man bei der Spielvereinigung, glaube ich, Sebastian. Ich kann es auch irgendwie schwierig fassen. Also natürlich, die Offensive ist bei 17 geschossenen Toren ein Problem, vor allem wenn du 27 fängst. Also man kann es allein an diesen Zahlen schon ein bisschen festmachen, wo da der Hasenpfeffer begraben liegt. Aber allein der Saisonverlauf war halt schon wieder, ja, anscheinend kann man, wenn man im tiefsten Mittelfranken beheimatet ist, kann man keine andere Saison spielen, weil der Club macht es regelmäßig genauso. Aber auf Licht folgt Schatten, auf Licht folgt Schatten und wir sehen alles, bloß keine Konstanz.
Ja, also bei Fürth ist ja eigentlich so ein erfolgreiches Zweitliga-Team, normalerweise. Ja, sehr lange, war auch kurzzeitig in der ersten Liga, haben dann Relegation für die erste Liga nochmal gespielt, verloren, gegen HSV. Und haben ja, es gibt ja auch diesen Running-Gag mit irgendwie, Fürth immer auf dem fünften Platz landet und das ist irgendwie alles weg. Ja, und ich kann mich erinnern, jetzt als Fürth bei Union gespielt hatte, kam es dann so, ja, Union hat jedes Heimspiel gegen Fürth seit dem Wiederaufstieg 2009 verloren. Ja, Angst gegen, aber ich dachte halt, diese Fürther-Mannschaft überhaupt nicht. Und es war auch so, das ist eine totale, also da stimmt überhaupt nichts in der Mannschaft, muss ich jetzt mal so sagen, das tut mir auch leid für die dort. Aber ich habe da nichts erkennen können, was mir als Fürther-Fan, wenn ich einer wäre, Hoffnung für die Rückrunde geben würde. Ja, da muss man einfach nur hoffen, dass man in der Liga jetzt bleibt. Und ne, also das ist, da passt überhaupt nichts zusammen. Also nach vorne absolut harmlos und hinten super anfällig. Mal sehen, vielleicht kriegen sie irgendwie noch jemanden hin, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Fürth irgendwo Geldtöpfe hätte, die man anzapfen kann. Also insofern schwierig. Die müssen wahrscheinlich froh sein, wenn sie es irgendwie schaffen, normal in der Liga zu bleiben oder in Abstiegsgefahr zu geraten. Und nach oben wird da überhaupt nichts gehen. Also ich fand das völlig harmlos, sehr enttäuschend irgendwie den Auftritt. Und nur weil unser defensiver Mittelfeldspieler Bibiana Steinhaus einen Rücken geschossen hat und der Ball zu Serdar Dujun geht, der dann einen anderen Spieler anschießt, von dem der Ball ins Tor geht, obwohl der sonst vorbei gegangen wäre. Nur deswegen haben sie einen Punkt geholt. Also es war das Kacktor des Jahres. Also insofern, ne, sorry, tut mir leid. Und Stefan Rutenberg, ich fand ihn als Trainer irgendwie auch vielversprechend. Und ja, vielleicht hat er es, ja, weiß ich nicht, so die Mechanismen vielleicht ein bisschen unterschätzt.
Es ist dünn, ja. Und wenn Dojo mit vier Treffern und Sebastian Freis mit drei Treffern schon deine erfolgreichsten Torschützen sind, bei insgesamt 17 erzielten Treffern, dann zeigt das ja allein schon mal, also da fehlt es definitiv schon mal an Qualität. Und die 27 Gegentreffer sprechen dann auch nicht dafür, dass alle, auch Verstärkungen, die man sich hinten geholt hat, funktioniert jetzt auch nicht alles. Das wird tatsächlich noch eine schwierige Saison. Aber dieses Tor war tatsächlich etwas sehr Besonderes.
Aber vielleicht ist es so ein Punkt, wir hatten ja vorhin so viele Vereine, also oben genannt irgendwie Würzburg oder Heidenheim, Vereine, die irgendwie einen Plan haben und diesen Plan sehr genau verfolgen, auch mit gezielten finanziellen Unterstützung natürlich. Vielleicht fällt dann so ein Verein, wie führt automatisch bei solchen Sachen zurück, plus du hast dann halt diese sehr finanzkräftigen Absteiger aus der Bundesliga, du hast Vereine wie Union, die halt über Jahre konstant irgendwie ihren Etat erhöhen und da zulegen. Vielleicht ist das dann halt so der normale Weg. Also das heißt halt nicht, dass sie jetzt besonders viel falsch machen. Vielleicht ist halt einfach, hat sich die Umgebung in der zweiten Liga, die hat sich ja sehr massiv geändert, ja auch finanziell. Vielleicht fällt man dann als Verein, wie führt, ohne die entsprechenden Strukturen, Beispiel Stadion, auch zurück.
Auch Beispiel Zuschauer-Andrang, also führt ja immer ein unterdurchschnittlichen Zuschauerschnitt für die zweite Liga. Das war früh immer so zwischen 10.000 und 11.000. In dieser Saison stehen sie jetzt, Zwischenfazit nach neun Heimspielen, bei knapp 9.000 sogar. Man hat natürlich auch den großen Konkurrenten vor der Nase, den Club, der sich jetzt nicht so arg wie besser anstellt. Wenigstens dieses Spiel konnten die Vörter gewinnen. Das war balsam auf leidgeplagte Seelen, aber es ist tatsächlich schwierig.
Ja, wenn du dir anschaust, die haben jetzt sechs Siege, aber alle sechs Siege mit einem Tor Unterschiede. Also es ist auch tatsächlich so, dass sie gegen keine Mannschaft irgendwie den Hebel ansetzen konnten, da mal den Offensivfußball, den zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung führte, in der zweiten Liga oft gespielt hat, irgendwie erfolgreich anzusetzen. Also das scheint tatsächlich dieses Jahr alles etwas anders zu sein.
Ja, sieht nicht so gut aus bei den Vörtern und das wird jetzt so ein bisschen sich durch die folgenden Vereine noch durchziehen, logischerweise, denn wir kommen immer näher in den Tabellenkeller. Wir steigen immer weiter runter in der Tabelle auf Platz 13 hinter den Vörtern. Der erste FC Kaiserslautern, bei dem auch schon wieder einiges los ist. Wie könnte es denn auch anders sein? Erstmal eine beeindruckende Zahl mit 11 erzielten Toren. Haben sie es tatsächlich geschafft, 19 Punkte zu erzielen. Das ist dann im Vergleich sogar noch herausragend, denn das ist die schlechteste Offensive zusammen mit dem KSC und dem FC St. Pauli und die haben beide weniger Punkte damit erzielt.
Also das ist glaube ich die beste Defensive.
Bitte? Das wäre jetzt der Punkt gewesen, auf den ich kommen wollte. Denn genau, du kannst ja nur mit wenigen Toren viele Punkte erzielen, wenn deine Defensive auch sitzt. Was sind denn da so für dich die entscheidenden Spieler, an denen man das festmachen kann, Sebastian?
Kaiserslautern, ich habe da wirklich keine Ahnung. Also das ist ein ganz großes Rätsel für mich als Negativbeispiel, wie man sich nicht an sich verändernde Strukturen und Umweltbedingungen für einen Fußballverein anpassen kann. Ein Verein, wo man ja die ganze Zeit überlegt, war der zwischendurch eigentlich illegalerweise pleite, zahlungsunfähig. Das ist ja so das Thema, was irgendwie so ein bisschen rumgeht und wo dann da mittel zwischendurch woanders für verwendet, damit man irgendwie zahlungsfähig bleibt. Also ganz großes Rätsel für mich. Ich sag dir nicht, woran es liegt, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass schon mal allein die Außenverteidiger, die beide Neuzugänge sind, eine wichtige Rolle spielen beim beim FCK. Da kennt man auch einen von Seutern Stieber, der kam vom HSV, und Philipp Mvenne von Stuttgart, also von Stuttgart 2, entschuldigung, rechter Außenverteidiger, wahrscheinlich habe ich ihn falsch ausgesprochen. Man möge es mir verzeihen, ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht besser. Dann Patrick Ziegler im defensiven Mittelfeld, wahrscheinlich hängt es sich an diesen Positionen auf. Und in der Innenverteidigung steht man da mit Robin Koch, Tim Heubach, dann wahrscheinlich auch nicht so schlecht da. Aber dass das zu nur 15 Gegentreffern reicht, ehrlich gesagt, mir ist das auch gar nicht aufgefallen. Also ich sehe ja schon hin und wieder mal was von der zweiten Bundesliga. Und allein deshalb, weil ich sie seit 16 Jahren inzwischen in einem Tippspiel mit meinen Brüdern tippe, muss ich die zweite Liga auch immer irgendwie im Blick haben. Aber mir ist dieser Fakt, wie stark die Defensive des FTK ist, mir nie so wirklich ins Auge gesprungen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Und das war ein Spiel, das eigentlich hätte 0-0 ausgehen müssen dann wahrscheinlich. Und ich kann mich nicht an viele Chancen von Union erinnern. Also wahrscheinlich gab es auch keine vielversprechende. Aber was auch immer sie da gemacht haben. Aber so richtig vom Fleck kommen sie halt damit nicht. Viele unentschieden.
Na ja, wenn du vorhin mehrfach die Vereine aufgezählt hast, Max, die man sich angucken soll, wenn man mit der zweiten Liga nicht so in Berührung kommt und sich einfach mal ein Spiel rausgreift, dann kannst du Kais Lautanis als das krasse Gegenbeispiel bringen. Das war fünfmal 0-0, davon drei Stück hintereinander weg. Mehrere 1-0 oder 0-1 Spiele. Das ist halt gähnende Langeweile. Um das ins Positive zu verkehren, also ich glaube einer der Spieler, die das so ein bisschen rausreißen, ist tatsächlich Julian Pollasbek, der relativ junge Torwart. Wenn du achtmal zu null spielst und er hat nur 14 Spiele gemacht, also viermal war er noch eine Vertretung im Tor, weil er verletzt war, dann reißt er schon einiges raus. Dann scheint man da zumindest in der Defensive einiges richtig gemacht zu haben. Aber nach vorne fehlt es da halt dann doch sehr.
Ich sehe auch gerade, dass Seuthen Stieber zehnmal als Zehner auflief. Das heißt, er ist definitiv nicht für die 15 Gegentore mitverantwortlich. Da hat der Max großen Unsinn erzählt, bevor sich alle Kaiserslautern-Fans aufregen. Aber es gibt ja Gott sei Dank auch Kaiserslautern-Podcasts, die sehr empfehlenswert sind. Da bekommt ihr das Ganze dann noch mal eine ganz andere Tiefe und Qualität geliefert als jetzt hier von uns. Mich erstaunt ist halt ehrlich gesagt daher, weil ich Typhoon Korkut, den Trainer, der seit dieser Saison auflautern tätig ist, als ein Offensiv-Trainer in Erinnerung hatte. So hat er bei Hannover 96 spielen lassen. Da war eher das Problem, dass hinten das Ganze zu wackelig war. Und jetzt ist halt dann die Frage, woran liegt das? Liegt das daran, dass er nicht mehr den Kader hat, um einen solchen Offensiv-Fußball spielen zu lassen? Oder liegt es daran, dass er tatsächlich seine Philosophie verändert hat? Ich meine, gegen die 15 ist ja auch nichts zu sagen. Aber die 11 erzielten Tore? Also schaut euch lauter nicht an, wenn ihr euch bisher nicht für die zweite Liga interessiert habt. Das nehmen wir mit aus diesem Segment. Habe ich richtig gesagt, Mike, ja? Dann stelle ich mir die Frage, erstmal wie lange wir über den kommenden Verein reden werden und ob man sich den anschauen soll. Ich glaube nämlich, ehrlich gesagt, es würde reichen, einfach nur die Berichterstattung mit zu verfolgen. Das ganze Sportliche können wir komplett vergessen. Wir möchten reden über das große Schauspiel des TSV 1860 München mit seinem Hauptdarsteller Hasan Ismaik, mit dem Nebendarsteller Anthony Powers, mit dem besten Namen aller Zeiten. Ich lebe in München. Ich komme nicht an Berichterstattung um 1860 herum. Und dennoch könnte ich euch nicht sagen, was eigentlich gerade die sportlichen Gründe für die Mähe-Serie sind, denn ich bekomme nur alle anderen Geschichten mit. Da weiß ich sehr gut Bescheid. Löwengehege direkt neben dem neu geplanten Stadion, Enthebung, wir reden auf der Geschäftsstelle im zweiten Stock alle nur noch Englisch, weil Anthony Powers Angst hat, dass sonst über ihn geredet wird. Er redet aber auch ständig Arabisch mit den Investoren, Freunden, die es da so gibt. Er kritisiert, dass er nicht zur Weihnachtsfeier der Mannschaft eingeladen wurde. Ein Abschiedsbrunch einer Sekretärin hat ihn sehr erboßt. Er hat es als Diebstahl von Arbeitszeit bezeichnet. Mehrere Artikel schreiben, dass die wirklich sehr, sehr leid geplanten Mitarbeiter der Geschäftsstelle bei 1860, dass da jetzt viele an Kündigung denken. Der Übersetzer von Hassan Ismail, ich muss ganz oft die Hälfte gar nicht mit übersetzen und und fängt damit die dann trotzdem noch irren Aussagen seines Investors noch ab. Das habe ich jetzt neulich gehört, dass Ismail immer sehr aus seiner wirtschaftlichen Sicht argumentiert und eigentlich auf arabisch Dinge sagt, wie ich habe hier so viel rein investiert, da muss jetzt mal mehr kommen. Und der Übersetzer sagt dann gegenüber der Mannschaft, ja also einige Dinge waren schon ganz gut, aber ein paar Dinge müssen noch besser werden. Also ein buntes Potpourri an Geschichten. Und ich weiß nichts darüber, wie 1860 in dieser Saison eigentlich gespielt hat, außer dass ich sehe, Tabellenplatz 14, 16 Punkte mit einem fast schon Endspurt jetzt überhaupt erst noch unten aus dem Tabellenkeller noch mal rausgekrochen, aber wie nachhaltig, das ist ehrlich keine Ahnung.
Aber mit interessanten Verpflichtungen eigentlich in der Sommerpause fand ich. Also das klingt ja erstmal eigentlich nach, wir wollen da oben mitspielen.
Und das ist doch auch genau das Problem, oder?
Ja, aber der Kader sagt ja auch, dass er ja vielleicht also viel Geld für Spiele ausgeben, die es dann nicht auf die Schienen bringen.
Ja, und der Name klingt vor allem gut.
Ja, aber also ich habe es mir jetzt nicht aufgeschrieben, aber wie viele Träne hatten sie jetzt so die letzte Zeit?
Und an welchen Zeitraum wir betrachten?
Also das ist halt so irgendwie schwierig. Also das ganze Konglomerat, ich finde es sehr witzig. Also man kann Hasan Ismail da auf Facebook folgen. Das ist so ein bisschen, als ob man Donald Trump auf Twitter liest. Ja, da kommt irgendwie ganz viel wirres Zeug raus. Man denkt sich immer so, also zum Beispiel diese Stadion-Sache.
Ja, also wir müssen die Hörer, glaube ich, damit reinholen. Auch wenn ich euch allen empfehle, Hasan Ismail wirklich überall, wo es geht, zu folgen. Es ist ganz großes Kino. Man kann sich eigentlich minütlich da neues Popcorn zubereiten. Also Hasan Ismail hat unter anderem gepostet, wie es denn sein könnte, dass damals die Anteile des TSV 1860 München an der Stadion AG für 11 Millionen Euro, glaube ich, verkauft wurden, wo doch die Allianz Arena wesentlich wertvoller sei. Das Ding ist, er hat da tatsächlich einen Punkt, aber das Ding ist gleichzeitig auch, damals stand es um 1860 ungefähr so schlecht wie heute. Das heißt, man war in einer wirtschaftlichen Notwendigkeit. Es hat sich auch direkt der Schatzmeister von damals gemeldet und hat gesagt, ne, ne, also wir haben uns halt nicht komplett über den Tisch ziehen lassen. Gleichzeitig waren aber logischerweise die beiden auch in einer starken Verhandlungsposition. Aber das ist ja nur der Anfang der Fahnenstange. Es geht ja weiter, dass er sagt, er wird die besten Anwälte dieses Landes beschäftigen oder wahrscheinlich der Welt sogar, um jetzt endlich Uli Hoeneß Gerechtigkeit zuzuführen, wo man sagt, ist eine coole Idee, aber haben halt auch schon Strafverfolgungsbehörden probiert. Also klar kannst du das machen. Ich gucke gerade, wann es den letzten Trainer gab bei 1860, der mehr als 30 Spiele gemacht hat. Ratet mal, wann war der letzte Trainer bei 60 im Amt? Also sag mir mal, wann er entlassen wurde, der mehr als 30 Spiele gemacht hat. Tatsächlich. 2012 Rainer Maurer würde im November 2012 nach 88 Spielen entlassen. Das war unfassbar lange. Davor übrigens Ewald Liene mit 39 Spielen, hat sich auch hier relativ lange halten können und zumindest keine nachhaltigen Schäden davon getragen, was einigermaßen beachtlich ist.
Ja, aber sie hatten ja eigentlich, also Kostarounianisch als Trainer ist da eigentlich ein vernünftiger Trainer. Aber ich glaube, in dem Umfeld kann man meinetwegen auch Pep Guardiola hinstellen und da wird da nichts draus. Und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass sie bei 1860 darauf warten, dass Daniel Birovka endlich einen Fußballlehrerschein hat und dann wird er ihr Trainer und vorher wird da sowieso nichts mehr.
Ja, dann wird alles gut. Ja, ich meine, es ist natürlich auch wirklich eine verzwickte Situation für den TSV. Also man hat sich durch verschiedene Fehlentscheidungen und auch tatsächlich einen gewissen Größenwahn, sage ich jetzt einfach mal noch, in der Wildmoser-Ära hat man sich in eine wirtschaftliche Situation gebracht, die in der Folge dazu geführt hat, dass wirklich herausragende Talente von 60 nie, also du konntest nie die Früchte ernten, die du dir selbst im Nachwuchs herangezogen hast. Die Nachwuchsarbeit von 60 gehört immer noch zu der besten dieses Landes, würde ich sagen. Allein, wenn man sich anguckt, wer da rausfällt, prominent ist das Beispiel Julian Weigl, aber auch die Bender, Zwillinge und und und. Diese Liste kann man endlos weiterführen und immer hatten sie nicht mal den Hauch einer Chance, diese Spieler zu halten.
Aber sie refinanzieren das ja auch überhaupt nicht richtig. Also ich erinnere mich, also Bobby Wood, der hat den ganzen Nachwuchs bei 1860 durchlaufen. Den hat man dann als irgendwie 18 oder 20-Jährigen dann als Sündenbock irgendwie suspendiert und nach Auer ausgeliehen für 800.000 an Union verkauft. 800.000 und Union verkauft ihn ein Jahr später für 4 Millionen an HSV. Das ist eigentlich, und davon sieht, von diesen 4 Millionen sieht 1860 kein Cent. Ja, und das ist halt eigentlich das Krasse, dass man halt im Prinzip diese tolle Arbeit, die man macht, die sich finanziell auch auszahlen könnte, selbst wenn man zweitlig ist, bleibt, dass man das nicht mal richtig nutzt. Das finde ich tatsächlich krass irgendwie.
Ja gut, das hat mit dem Sportlichen zu tun, oder? Ich meine, wir erinnern uns an die Relegation gegen Heustern-Kiel, das war die Saison 14-15, da waren wir Tabellenplatz 16, letztes Jahr jetzt dann Tabellenplatz 15, jetzt immerhin schon mal Tabellenplatz 14. Das heißt, es braucht nur noch zwölf Jahre und die steigen auf, das ist ja auch irgendwie was Schönes. Aber Ironie beiseite, die sportliche Situation ist halt natürlich auch kein Argument für junge Talente bei 60 zu bleiben. Also ich glaube, dass sie tatsächlich auch immer das Problem haben, dass die Spieler hier auch weg wollen und dann bekommst du für die halt nicht viel Kohle. Ja, aber die sind halt nicht in der Situation, wo sie sagen können, also unter 1,5 Millionen geht es jetzt aber nicht, liebes Union Berlin.
Also ich finde das schwierig, aber ich glaube, das, was wir am Anfang hatten, als wir uns so über Hasan Ismail lustig gemacht haben, ich glaube, das ist das eigentliche Kernproblem, dass irgendwie 1860 an der Nadel von diesem Investor und da hat auch dieser Gutsherrenart im Prinzip hängt. Im Prinzip ist Hasan Ismail ja das beste Beispiel, weshalb man diese 50 plus 1-Regel am besten zementieren sollte und so weiter und so fort. Das ist wirklich ein Trauerspiel. Ich weiß auch nicht, wohin das führen soll. Da ist jemand, der handelt aus Emotionen und das ist ja das Letzte. Wenn wir die ganzen Beispiele, wie gesagt Würzburg oder Heidenheim und meinetwegen noch Ingolstadt und was wir da in der ersten Liga an solchen ähnlichen Vereinen haben, Hoffenheim oder so, da ist das doch eher aus der Rationalität getrieben. Und das sehe ich überhaupt nicht bei 1860.
Rationalität siehst du hier schon lange nicht an.
Und das ist vielleicht so ein Punkt, an dem man, also dann soll er doch halt Geld investieren, aber halt Leute den Job machen lassen, denen man halt auch das Fachwissen zutraut und die dann halt auch arbeiten lassen. Aber da werden halt Leute nach Namen geholt, das hast du ja vorhin gesagt, auch halt auf den verantwortlichen Posten und müssen dann irgendwie mit Sachen arbeiten, die sie halt selbst gar nicht verantworten würden, am liebsten. Und also es ist sehr schwierig. Ich habe einen Freund, der ist 1860-Fan und ab und zu sitzen wir bei einem Bier zusammen und ich frage, wie sieht es bei 1860 aus? Er zuckt mir den Mundwinkel und fragt mich dann nach Union. Das ist halt so der Stand seit ein paar Jahren und das ist wirklich sehr schade. Aber mittlerweile, also ich als so, der ich jetzt die Jahre Zweite Liga irgendwie schaue und so, wünsche mir eigentlich endlich einen Abstieg von 1860. Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich so, wie halt viele Bundesliga-Fans sich einen Abstieg vom HSV endlich wünschen, damit da mal, weil man kann es ja, das ist unterhaltsam und nett und so, aber es ist halt irgendwie auf Dauer nicht anzusehen, was die an Geld verbrennen auch. Also es ist ja, mir blutet das Herz. Das ist ja sehr schade und andere Vereine, die das Geld vielleicht gebrauchen könnten und es sinnvoll einsetzen würden, haben es halt nicht.
Also ich wünsche mir einen Abstieg beider genannten Vereine und das auch seit Jahren und diese Relegation, als sowohl der HSV als auch 1860 das jeweils in der letzten Minute schafften, das war tatsächlich so ein Stich ins Herz. Also das hat mich echt stark getroffen und aber noch mal anschließend an, dass du es eben sagtest, dass auch junge Spieler da einfach nicht bleiben wollen. Genau das ist das Problem. Also wir hatten vorhin bei Hannover auch den Namen Sebastian Maier, der vor kurzem zu St. Pauli gegangen war vor drei, vier Jahren. Jetzt haben wir aktuell Richard Neudecker. Auch das wieder ein Spieler, der unfassbares Potenzial zugesprochen bekommt, aber bei 60 offensichtlich nicht bleiben will und man hat auch da in den letzten Jahren einfach mit den Leuten, die dann weg gingen. Ab dem Moment, wo der Weggang fest stand, immer es geschafft, sich das mit denen komplett zu verscherzen, was halt auch in der Außenwirkung ja zumindest nicht ist wahrscheinlicher macht, dass andere Leute gerne da bleiben, weil man einfach immer wieder sieht, der Umgang ist weder menschlich noch professionell. Also es ist einfach etwas, was so, glaube ich, im deutschen Profifußball in dieser Dimension sich schlecht darzustellen und auch schlecht miteinander umzugehen, sehr selten ist. Also das schaffen nicht viele Vereine.
Ja, allerdings, man wirkt bei allen, also ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, dass 1860 bei allen relevanten Zielgruppen als Witzvereine inzwischen wahrgenommen wird und das schließt halt nicht nur andere Zuschauer aus. Dass die Bayernfernse sich lustig machen, ist ja eh klar, sondern ich glaube, das bezieht inzwischen auch das Umfeld und die eigenen Spieler mit ein. Also Julian Weigl war ja derjenige, der Kapitän war, mit ich glaube damals 17 Jahren bei 1860 und sich dann eben auf einer Taxifahrt so abfällig über den Verein geäußert hat, dass er plus die anderen, die im Taxi saßen, der Taxifahrer hatte natürlich den Verein informiert, alter 60er-Fan, suspendiert wurde und das ist, das kannst du ja von beiden Seiten sehen, ist natürlich auch nicht gut, wenn ein Spieler tatsächlich so über seinen Verein spricht, wie es zumindest kolportiert wurde, das muss man noch dazu sagen. Aber das zeigt ja genau den Stellenwert. Also es bedeutet auch tatsächlich den Spielern glaube ich wenig für 60 zu spielen. Da kann ein Investor noch so viel sagen, er wäre jetzt ein Löwe und irgendwelche alten Tugenden beschwören und da kannst du auch einen portugiesischen Meistertrainer holen mit Vitor Pereira. Aber ich meine, damit könnte jetzt endlich mal wieder sportliche Kompetenz einzugehalten haben bei 1860 und das ist dringend dringend notwendig. Aber ob das der Weisheit letzter Schluss ist, weiß ich nicht. Aber anders als ihr beiden wünsche ich zum Beispiel 60 den Abstieg nicht, weil ich glaube, dass der Verein dann verschwindet auf die eine oder andere Art. Entweder sehr weit unten in der Liga oder er zerbröselt tatsächlich und es bräuchte in München schon zwei Vereine, auch wenn ich selber ja ein Roter bin, aber im mehrheitlich leicht blauen Giesing wohne, nicht so nicht so deutlich wie die 60er immer rumschreien, aber gibt es auch 60er hier und es ist auch nicht so schlecht zwei Vereine in einer Stadt zu haben und ich glaube tatsächlich, so sehr ich den Verein, so sehr es irgendwie verdient wäre. Sie bewerben sich jetzt um diesen Abstieg wirklich nachhaltig und lange. Irgendwie täte es mir für viele Leute, die ich kenne, dann doch auch leid.
Ja, aber der Kader ist natürlich viel zu gut für einen Abstieg, das müssen wir jetzt mal festhalten. Wenn wir jetzt gleich noch vielleicht auf Mannschaften kommen, die ein bisschen vor 1860 stehen oder hinter. Das ist überhaupt kein Kader, der dort in dieser Tabellenregion eigentlich was zu suchen hat. Und was mich, glaube ich, so als jemand von einem Berliner Verein, wir haben hier zwei große Vereine in der Stadt. Hamburg hat auch zwei große Vereine in der Stadt, München halt auch. Und nur dort ist man auf die wahnnützige Idee gekommen, ins gleiche Stadion wie der leicht größere Verein HaHa zu ziehen und mit denen irgendwie auf Augenhöhe irgendwie was zu machen, was völlig absurd ist im Prinzip, weil man halt seine komplette Identität und alles Einzigartige aufgibt dadurch. Wie würde das denn aussehen, wenn Union im Olympiastadion spielen würde? Mit meinetwegen, lass es halt dann 25 oder 30.000 Zuschauer sein, im Olympiastadion mit 74.000 Plätzen. Ist doch Blödsinn. Und wie würde es denn aussehen, wenn sein Pauli da in dieser, wie auch immer das Stadion jetzt heißt, spielen würde, da wo der HSV spielt? Das ist halt Quatsch. Das kann man nicht machen. Da muss man was Eigenes irgendwie aufziehen. Und das haben sie irgendwie verpasst. Und diese Zeche zahlen sie halt die ganze Zeit. Und die ganze Zeit ist der Verein zerrissen zwischen, wir spielen jetzt hier in dieser Allianz Arena und quasi die Mehrzahl der Mitglieder möchte doch am liebsten wieder zurück nach Giesingen in das Stadion, obwohl das nie wieder passieren wird. Und das diskutieren sie die ganze Zeit, obwohl im Prinzip die Fakten ja da sind. Das ist genauso quark, als ob Hertha sagen würde, was sie ja machen. Wir prüfen einen Umzug und Neubau in Brandenburg eines Stadions. Das ist halt symbolhaft. Das ist bar jeder Realität, bar aller Fakten. Daran hält sich dieser Verein auf und zieht sich hoch und runter daran, anstatt irgendwie zuzusehen, sich einen Plan zu machen, was man will und das dann auch mal durchzuziehen.
Du hast ja bei jedem Verein immer mal wieder Leute, die sagen, ach ich will gar nicht aufsteigen oder meinetwegen können wir auch eine Liga tiefer spielen. Aber ich glaube, so in der Vehemenz, wie das momentan bei 1860 tatsächlich diverse Gruppen oder auch Einzelpersonen gibt, die wirklich sagen, ein Abstieg wäre sinnvoll und gut und das wünsche ich mir für meinen Verein, das hast du glaube ich bei keinem anderen Club. Also das ist schon sehr krass und das zeigt ja auch diese Zerrissenheit, die natürlich dann letzten Endes durch Hasan Ismaik zustande gebracht wurde und ich weiß nicht, ob der sich bei einem Abstieg verabschieden würde, vielleicht sogar verabschieden müsste, keine Ahnung, ob er dann die Lust an seinem Spielzeug verliert. Ich glaube dafür war es jetzt zwischendurch zu teuer, aber ich muss ihm auch klar sein, er müsste halt noch mal mehr Geld reinstecken, um das dann irgendwann wieder bespielbar zu machen. Vielleicht die Frage noch, wäre denn in der dritten Liga dann die Grünwalder Straße wieder eine Option?
Also es gab ja Umbauten, die das städtische Stadion an der Grünwalder Straße tatsächlich so hergerichtet haben, dass es drittliga-tauglich ist. Ich glaube, es gäbe dann auch wenig andere Optionen. Die ganze Sache ist aber nicht so einfach, wie es auch viele 60-Fans oft hinstellen. Da spricht die Stadt ein entscheidendes Wort mit und wer einmal an diesem Stadion war und einmal bei einem größeren Spiel, das sind halt derzeit immer die Amateur-Dolbys, da kann man es verfolgen, der sieht, was für einen Chaos ausgelöst wird, wenn da tatsächlich mal 10.000 Zuschauer rein gehen. Da kann man sich tatsächlich kaum vorstellen, dass die Stadt dankbar und freudig erregt wird. Ja klar, sperren wir da jedes Mal den Wettersteinplatz, die Kreuzung vom Mittleren Ring einfach und ihr könnt da in Ruhe eure Fußballfans rüberlaufen lassen und ist auch gar kein Problem mit der mit der Tram und so weiter. Also es ist tatsächlich alles nicht so einfach, muss man sagen und selbst wenn die Stadt das sagen würde.
Ja, es gäbe ja die Anwohner würden sie einfach runter Boden klagen.
Ja, da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher. Ja gut, wobei wird gerade fröhlich durchgetrifiziert. Da also könnte man es auch nicht mehr ausführen.
Also schau an, ich meine selbst Darmstadt, die halt irgendwie so ein Stadionumbau inmitten eines eng bewohnten Gebietes, den kriegst du da nicht durch. In Darmstadt haben sie es fallen lassen wegen dieser Anwohner-Sache und basteln da jetzt irgendwie mit Stahlrohr und so weiter und so fort. Ja, das ist, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendwie hingeht. Also müsste man einen anderen Weg finden und da hat die Stadt glaube ich zu viel Geld irgendwie bei dieser Allianz-Arena mit versenkt und da gab es auch diesen Volksentscheid. Ich meine, was ist der plötzlich nicht mehr bindend?
Na gut, das ist hier in München. Du kannst auch gegen eine dritte Sparternbahn klagen und dann sagt der Horst, ja dann fragen wir heute nochmal und stellen die Frage ein bisschen anders. Also das ist hier Demokratie, ein bisschen Bayern. Also das ist jetzt alles nicht so wild hier. Aber es ist halt auch alles nicht so einfach. Tatsächlich bedauere ich es ernsthaft sehr, sehr, sehr, dass es keinen 1860 München Podcast gibt. Denn es gibt so viele Themen, auch das sportliche eben, über das wir ja jetzt auch immer noch nicht gesprochen haben, die wirklich interessant wären, wo ich auch gerne mal den ausführlicheren Blick drauf hatte. Also wenn das jemand da draußen hört, der sagt, meine Güte, was reden die denn da? Ja bitte, bitte machs besser. Ich würde mich sehr freuen. Vielleicht hat ja auch der Kumpel vom Sebastian Bock sich aus Berlin zuzuschalten. Dann kann der Sebastian bei der Technik helfen. Ich würde auch mit ihm helfen. Also ich finde echt ein 1860 Podcast wäre sehr gewinnbringend, weil da auch so viele verschiedene Dinge in diesem Verein passieren. Ja auch die Fan-Struktur mit sowohl einem Problem auf der rechten Seite, aber auch der Gegenbewegung dazu. Also es gibt ja auch kein Schwarz und Weiß. Bei 1860 gibt es wirklich ein 1860 Podcast. Das wäre mal dringend notwendig, wenn ihr mich fragt.
Ich glaube, das wird es nicht geben, weil du vom Verein so viele Steine in den Weg geschmissen bekommen würdest.
Also wir können es nicht hinsetzen. Wenn Fans einen Podcast machen.
Ja, glaube ich.
Also was sollen die denn dafür Steine schmeißen? Wir reden doch auch gerade über 60.
Wir reden halt über 60. Natürlich kann das jeder mal machen, aber ich glaube, auf Dauer länger wirst du einfach bei dem Verein dann keinen Spaß mehr haben, weil auch diese Gruppen untereinander alle so zerstritten sind. Also ich habe auch von dem ehemaligen, wie heißt denn dieser, ah, verflucht, ich komme gerade nicht auf den Namen. Es gibt einen, ich glaube der war früher Fanbeauftragter bei 60 oder Fanbetreuer oder irgendwas. Der hat so eine Archivseite über 1860 und den wollten wir halt für den Milan-Ton vor dem nach dem Spielgespräch haben und der hat dann gesagt, ne darf ich nicht. Wo ich gesagt habe, wieso, du bist doch Fan. Ja, ne, darf ich nicht, kriege ich Ärger vom Verein. Was mir halt völlig unbegreiflich ist und deswegen glaube ich, also ich will nicht sagen, es kann keinen 1860-Podcast geben, aber ich glaube, auf Sicht wird sich sowas da nicht lange halten.
Ja, ja und tatsächlich auch die zerstrittene Fanszene, da sprichst du ja auch das Richtige an. Viele 60 Fans, die ich kenne, haben sich ja tatsächlich auch schon vom Profi-Verein, wenn man ihn als Profi-Verein bezeichnen möchte, also von dem Verein, der noch in der Profi-Liga mitspielen darf, von dem schon verabschiedet, aus ganz diversen Gründen, wo auch viele Dinge aus der Fanszene tatsächlich auch eine Rolle spielen. Also da ist es auch, ja, an allen Ecken und Enden gibt es da irgendwie Baustellen. Und jetzt würde ich trotzdem gerne irgendwie noch mal kurz über sportliche reden, weil ich das eben selber auch gar nicht so mitbekommen habe. Es gab eine ganz, ganz schlimme Phase für 1860. Das war zwischen dem fünften Spieltag begann wie passend mit einem 1 zu 2 zu Hause gegen den ersten FC Union Berlin. Sebastian wird sich erinnern. Dann ein Unentschieden. Dann ein Unentschieden beim FC St. Pauli auswärts. Daran wird sich Mike sehr gut erinnern. Und dann wurden sie für diesen Punktgewinn bestraft mit vier Niederlagen in Folge. Dann gab es ein kurzes Zwischenhoch. Im DFB Pokal nach F-Meter-Schießen weitergekommen gegen die Würzburger Kickers. Nicht unbedingt zu erwarten. Dann zu Hause Erzgebirge Auer 6 zu 2 weggemacht. Auer auch spielt eine vollkommen wilde Saison. Werden wir ja gleich noch drüber reden. Aber das hat richtig wehgetan. Und jetzt erst mit so einem Zwischensport zwischen dem 15. und dem 17. Spieltag, wo man noch mal vier Punkte sammeln konnte, steht man jetzt eben mit 16 Punkten immerhin außerhalb der Abstiegsränge. Also auch sportlich gesehen gibt es da ja auch wenig Positives, was man bei den Sechskern entdecken kann. Oder wollt ihr mir da widersprechen?
Würde uns natürlich nie einfallen, aber wir haben ja schon häufiger über Konstanz gesprochen. Und wenn du dir dann mal anschaust, wie viele Spieler da 17 Spiele gemacht haben, wirst du sehen, kein einziger, nicht mal der Torwart. Und Sascha Mölders ist mit 16 Einsätzen noch der, der am meisten dann hat und dann geht es halt, glaube ich, noch einen mit 15, nee, nicht mal, dann kommen schon 14 Spieler. Das heißt, du kriegst auch in der Mannschaft einfach keine Konstanz rein, sportlich. Und ich glaube, das wirkt sich dann eben auch aus. Und dementsprechend kriegst du in dem Verein insgesamt keine Ruhe und dann eben auch nicht in die Startelf. Und wenn Sebastian sagt, der Kader ist viel zu gut für Zweitege-Abstiegskampf, stimme ich ihm da grundsätzlich zu. Vielleicht sind es aber auch einfach jetzt Leute, die da sich als Zweckgemeinschaft sehen, aber halt zu wenig dann auf Dauer auch Bock haben, Abstiegskampf zu spielen und dann eben auch sagen, steigen wir halt ab, egal, nächstes Jahr bin ich woanders.
Es ist ein vollkommen wilder Verein. Und ja, jetzt ja auch nach einem Unentschieden entlassen, zu Hause gegen Lautern eins zu eins.
Ach, das war doch die Geschichte, wo sie gesagt haben, stand schon seit zwei Wochen fest, da war doch Landerspiel-Pause davor und dann, dann sagt man nach dem Spiel, was eher ein positives Zeichen war, ja, das stand schon vor zwei Wochen fest, aber wir warten jetzt halt noch, bis dieses Spiel rauskommt und entlassen ihn dann wie wahnsinnig. Also, nee.
Positiv formuliert, sie pfeifen auf alle Konventionen, die der gesunde Menschenverstand sonst so etabliert hat. Ich meine, es gab ja auch diesen lächerlichen Presseboykott und man ist da ja tatsächlich auch vom Gedankengut her und von der Argumentationsführung oft sehr in der Nähe von Populisten wie Trump und Konsorten. Also der Vergleich von dir, Sebastian, war sehr, sehr passend zwischen Ismaik und Trump. Es ist eine ganz, ganz merkwürdige Gemengelage und dennoch könnte man das bitte noch mal in einem Podcast Woche für Woche aufbereiten. Geschichten gibt es genug. Also, ich glaube, jede einzelne Folge würde so lang werden, wie alles, was wir gerade hier besprochen haben. Naja, 60. Derzeit Tabellenplatz 14 mit zwei Punkten Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz und dahinter wartet dann der KSC, eine der Traditionsmannschaften, die wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben, als wir im Bochum-Segment uns noch befanden. Auch nur mit elf erzielten Toren, 21 Gefangene mit 14 Punkten. Punktgleich mit Aminia Bielefeld dahinter auf dem Relegationsplatz. Und der KSC ist für mich tatsächlich auch immer mehr zu einer Black Box geworden, Sebastian. Ich fühle mich da nicht in der Lage, irgendwelche Schlüsse aus dem, was ich so mitbekommen habe, da zu ziehen. Wie geht es dir da?
Ja, immerhin haben sie jetzt den neuen Stadionbau auf den Weg gekriegt. Also das ist jetzt nicht alles schlecht beim Karlsruhe SC. Aber es ist tatsächlich schwierig, da zu prognostizieren, irgendwie was will der Verein, Anspruch, Wirklichkeit. Ich glaube, sie leiden mehr unter dem Weggang von Markus Koczynski, als man sich das vielleicht hätte eigen bestehen wollen. Das war für mich so die Konstante beim Karlsruhe SC, Markus Koczynski und ich fand den gut. Und das war so mein Kandidat für den neuen Trainerposten bei Union so ein bisschen. Thomas Oral?
Okay, jetzt Mirko Slomka.
Jetzt Mirko Slomka, das sind beides so. Aber vielleicht ist Mirko Slomka, vielleicht hat er jetzt gesehen, Jens Keller geht es gut in der zweiten Liga. Vielleicht ist es ein Weg wieder in dieses Trainer-Kausell reinzukommen für ihn. Und ja, also ich kann dir überhaupt nicht sagen, wo die jetzt hingehen und was sie wollen. Ich fand, mit Thomas Oral hat das nicht gepasst irgendwie. Also genau wie du es sagst, es ist eine Black Box.
Also ich finde, wir hatten ja Kaiserslautern eben schon als Verein, den man sich nicht angucken muss. Karlsruhe gehört da auch zu. Wir haben auch fünfmal 0 zu 0 gespielt. Also auch das furchtbar unansehnlich aus den letzten vier Spielen, alleine dreimal 0 zu 0. Und was dazu kommt, war tatsächlich eines der Spiele, wo ich sage, das hätten wir eher gewinnen müssen. Wir haben da relativ souverän in Karlsruhe gespielt, sind im Führung gegangen, dazugegebenermaßen durch ein ziemlich glückliches Tor, weil der Torwart irgendwie außerhalb des Sechzehners meinte, klären zu wollen und das nicht hingekriegt hat. Aber das Spiel hatte St. Pauli tatsächlich mal im Sack und hat sich dann durch einen Schuss aufs Tor da einen Unentschieden reinschenken lassen. Die Mannschaft, weiß ich nicht, ob Slomka da so furchtbar viel entwickeln kann, dass es zu einer besseren Rückrunde führt. Also da scheint auch nicht ganz so furchtbar viel positiv zu laufen. Und auch da, du hast keinen Spieler, der 17 Spiele gemacht hat, du hast in der Abwehr, Janne Thölke ist der mit 14 Spielen, der die meisten Einsätze hat. Das heißt, du hast da auch keinerlei Konstanz im Kader. Sieht nicht so furchtbar vielversprechend aus für die Rückrunde.
Und das, obwohl da mein Lieblingsspieler vom Olympischen Fußballturnier spielt, allein vom Namen her, Grisha Prommel, defensives Mittelfeld, 21 Jahre alt, wurde beim Olympischen Fußballturnier meist eingewechselt, aber hat einfach einen schönen Klang, dieser Name.
Ich finde Shara Lampos, Mavrias noch viel schöner klingend und Dimitrios Diamantakos auch, aber ich möchte dir da nicht widersprechen.
Vielleicht war da auch ein bisschen Ironie drin. Aber weiß ich nicht. Wir bewegen uns zu auf die Abstiegsränge und wir haben auf dem Relegationsplatz Aminia Bielefeld auch 14 Punkte. Der KSC hat es geschafft, mit seinem letzten 0-0 am 17. Spieltag sich tatsächlich noch auf Platz 15 vorzuschieben. Das heißt, irgendwie hat es dann doch seinen Sinn gehabt, zumindest aus KSC-Sicht. Und Aminia mit 14 Punkten, ja, das ist ganz schön eng da unten. Die 16, 17, 18 haben 14, 13 und 11 Punkte. Das heißt, wir sind fern davon, dass sich da unten schon irgendeine klare Tendenz abzeichnen würde. Das ist alles innerhalb von einem Spieltag leicht zu drehen. Und Aminia, nicht so ganz überraschend da unten drin, haben einen auch einen bunten Blumenstrauß an Problemen, tragen sie über die Jahre mit sich herum. Aber Sebastian, woran liegt es denn sportlich gesehen, dass es in der Saison schon wieder nicht zu mehr klappt oder zumindest mal zu einer ruhigen Saison?
Sie haben ja auch ihren Trainer entlassen und das war für mich ja eher so, ich weiß nicht, ich bin jetzt so nicht so bielefeld dran oder so, aber ich fand das überraschend irgendwie, dass sie halt, sie sind hier mit, wie heißt der, wie heißt der, ah, von Rüdiger Rehm, der stand auch bei vielen auf dem Zettel, Sonnenhof Groß-Aßbach war er vorher, kann es sein, und man wusste irgendwie, dass dieser Kader irgendwie es jetzt nicht so einfach haben wird in der zweiten Liga, glaube ich, und ich verstehe nicht, wieso man dann halt so diesen Trainer weggehen lässt. Jetzt haben sie Jürgen Kramny. Das ist so, manchmal habe ich so das Gefühl, dass man den Trainer entlässt, wenn man denkt irgendwie, okay, wir müssen irgendwas ändern, und dann stellt man so fest, oh Mist, auf dem Markt ist aber gar keiner, der so richtig zu uns passt. Denke ich auch bei manchen Erstligisten so, dass es manchmal so komisch kommt, und dann denkt man, oh, ist ja nur noch der und der, verdammt, und so ein bisschen ist dieser Eindruck von dieser Jürgen-Kram-Ni-Verpflichtung für mich. Damit ändert sich ja im Prinzip auch nichts weiter, außer man hat jetzt eine Person ausgetauscht, aber das macht man dann halt, also es war klar, dass die jetzt nicht irgendwie oben mitspielen werden oder so, und dass man vielleicht auch ein bisschen kämpfen muss irgendwie im Abstiegskampf und so. Und ich glaube, man hat Rüdiger Rehm einfach jetzt nicht die Zeit gegeben, der konnte das vorher in Sonnenhof Groß-Astbach ja entwickeln und die Zeit hat er überhaupt gar nicht in Bielefeld gehabt. Und an sich, also das war ein totales Freakspiel, was ich gesehen habe. Ja, das war die Show von Bielefeld gegen Union. Das war dieses 4 zu 4 in Bielefeld, in dem Bielefeld schon 3-1 führt und das halt nicht fest machen kann und noch 4-3 zurückliegt und dann irgendwie durch 4 zu 4 macht. Das war sicher auch die Ausnahme. Da hab ich gedacht, wow, irgendwie, wenn die mal so in Fahrt kommen, ist das ganz interessant. Aber ich kann dir nicht mehr dazu sagen, außer dass mich dieser Trainerwechsel total ratlos zurückgelassen hat. Weil Sonnenhof Groß-Aspach ja dann, ich glaube, die mussten auch Ablöse zahlen für Rüdiger Rehm. Nicht zu knapp. Also dass man so ein Ding dann halt so schnell wieder beendet, das finde ich halt irgendwie merkwürdig. Lässt mich Fragen zurück.
Ja, Erkostin konnte nicht in die Fußstapfen von Norbert Maier treten, der ja auch ein merkwürdig, typisch Spielefeld irgendwie, wie so seine Amtszeit verlief. Wir erinnern uns alle in der Relegation gegen Darmstadt, damals aus der dritten Liga nach oben gekommen, im Hinspiel 3 zu 1 auswärts gewonnen und dann tatsächlich das Zuhause noch versemmelt. Die Darmstädter haben sich dementsprechend jetzt ja dann damals sehr gefeiert, als man dann genau ausgerechnet diesen Trainer dann als eigenen Vorgesetz bekam. Das haben wir auch in vergangenen Schlusskonferenzen schon behandelt. Dann aber im darauffolgenden Jahr als Erstplatzhielter souverän aufgestiegen. Ich habe auch die erste Zweitligasaison 15, 16 ein bisschen schlechter gemacht, als sie war. Mit 42 Punkten ging das hinten raus, war das dann okay. Ich habe es allerdings noch als ein bisschen chaotisch im Hinterkopf. Ja und dann geht Norbert Maier zum SV Darmstadt. Wir alle wissen, weil es dann auch nicht von so nachhaltiger Dauer. Und dann kriegt der neue Trainer elf Spiele, um sich zu beweisen. Also ich möchte dir da voll zustimmen, so ganz kann ich das auch nicht nachvollziehen. Jürgen Kramny sicherlich kein schlechter Trainer. Aber wenn es da jetzt keine konkreten Probleme zwischen Mannschaft und Trainer gab, dann finde ich, ist das jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen zu früh die Reißleine gezogen. Vielleicht aber halt auch Ausdruck einer gewissen Ratlosigkeit. Das beobachtet man ja auch immer wieder.
Wir hatten da vorhin ganz am Anfang dieser Sendung, ist ja schon ein bisschen her, über Frank Schmidt gesprochen und dass der nicht zum VfB Stuttgart wollte und dass er lieber in Heidenheim bleibt. Und das ist ein bisschen Rüdiger Rehm hat diesen Schritt aus diesem Wohlfühl-Biotop Groß-Aßbach, wo er halt irgendwie angesehen war und wo man halt so eine Krise wie in Bielefeld durchgestanden hätte, hat er ja gewagt und ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen abschreckendes Beispiel für Trainer, die in solchen Umgebungen arbeiten, die gerne woanders hin möchten, aber die dann sehen, das ist total chaotisch. Das ist als ob man irgendwie als HSV ist vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil es halt so ein riesig großer Verein ist. Aber da kriegt man halt auch nicht die Zeit, etwas zu entwickeln. Also es ist halt so, vielleicht bleibt man dann lieber da und sagt halt nö, ich warte dann halt auf einen Club, wo es ruhiger ist. Man macht dann halt eher die kleineren Schritte, obwohl jetzt Groß-Aßbach-Bielefeld, das war jetzt sportlich kein großer Schritt. Das war halt der Schritt zu einem gerade in die zweite Liga aufgestiegenen Verein von einem Drittliga-Verein. Also das ist jetzt nicht so ein riesen Ding, aber so der Chaos-Faktor, den manche Vereine irgendwie ausstrahlen und die Ungeduld in diesem Verein, das sollte man manchmal nicht unterschätzen, wenn man sich fragt, warum manche Trainer vielleicht dort nicht hin wollen.
Also ich glaube, bei Bielefeld, das ist ja mal so ein beliebter Spruch, dass man sagt, wenn ich die Zeit jetzt mal so und so viele Wochen weiterdrehen würde, in Bielefeld wirst du wahrscheinlich sehr schnell wissen, wo es lang geht, wenn man sich die nächsten drei Pflichtspiele anguckt, weil das sind die Spiele in Karlsruhe gegen 60 und dann im Pokal-Achtelfinale bei Astoria Walldorf. Und mal davon ausgehen, dass du vielleicht aus diesen ersten zwei Ligaspielen nicht allzu viele Punkte holst. Wenn alles normal läuft, kommst du dann im Pokal eine Runde weiter, hast also auch noch ein Viertelfinale irgendwo am Horizont, bist mit den Gedanken vielleicht auch wieder ganz woanders und wirst dann in der Liga Schwierigkeiten haben. Da bin ich mir relativ sicher. Also ich glaube, wenn man aus den Karlsruhe und 60-Spielen nicht mindestens ein Sieg holt, kann das für Bielefeld in der Liga sehr schnell Richtung ganz unten dann gehen.
Ja, das Gute ist, dass wir dann wenigstens nicht wieder gleich den Trainer entlassen werden. Das wäre dann selbst für Bielefeld eine etwas zu hohe Taktung. Ja, aber sehr, sehr wichtiger Hinweis auf den Beginn der Rückrunde. Das wird für gerade für Bielefeld tatsächlich sehr interessant. Und dann haben wir auf Platz 17 den einzigen Aussteiger, der es nicht geschafft hat, sich vorne einzureihen. Erzgebirge Aue mit 13 Punkten, das heißt ein Punkt Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz und auch schon aufs rettende Ufer. 17 zu 32 Toren, drei Siege nur in diesen 17 Spielen. Und Aue ist auch so für mich, ja, tatsächlich stehen die ehrlich gesagt da, wo ich es auch erwarte. Ich traue Aue alles bis Tabellenplatz 10 zu. Es gab ja auch schon wesentlich bessere Zeiten. Und für mich ist das so wie der SC Freiburg zum Beispiel eine Mannschaft ist, die zwischen erster und zweiter Liga pendelt. Das ist für mich Aue eins der Teams, wo ich sage, ja das passt irgendwie auch schon, dass die quasi nicht zu den besten 25 Vereinen gehören, so wie der SC Freiburg, sondern dass man eben sagen würde, die gehören halt zu den besten 45 Vereinen in Deutschland. Und dann ist das irgendwie auch okay, so wie die platziert stehen.
Kann ich dir total zustimmen. Also das ist eigentlich für Aue, ja, hier ist ja eine Sensation, wenn sie in der zweiten Liga bleiben. Das ist so ein kleines Nest. Ich war immer noch nicht dort. Ich habe es mir vorgenommen, aber von Berlin aus ist das so schwer zu erreichen. Aber das ist halt einfach ein kleiner Verein, der aus einer, wenn ich Berlin schon als strukturschwache Region bezeichne. Also dann ist das jetzt wirklich irgendwo im Nirgendwo. Und der ist so, auch das wissen Sie ja auch, ist ja so abhängig von dieser ganzen Führungsebene der Leonards, hier Uwe und Helge Leonhardt mit ihrem, mit ihrer Firma. Und der Co-Trainer ist mit der Tochter von Helge Leonhardt zusammen. Ein Spieler ist aber mit der anderen Tochter von Helge Leonhardt zusammen. Das ist alles so ein bisschen irgendwie, ja, das ist halt Aue. Und da weiß man halt, dass das zweite Liga ist stark. Wenn Sie das halten und schaffen und Sie bauen da dieses neue Stadion, das auch wichtig ist dort, sodass man nicht mehr irgendwie oben an den Bäumen irgendwie sitzen kann, an den Hängen und dann ins Stadion gucken kann. Man muss sich dann glaube ich demnächst auch wirklich Karten immer kaufen. Also das ist irgendwie, ja, anders kann ich es nicht bezeichnen. Es ist eine Sensation, wenn Sie es halt schaffen.
Punkt. Also wenn man sich mal die Spiele jetzt auch gerade zum Schluss angeschaut, also The Trend Is Your Friend kommt da überhaupt nicht zur Geltung. Ich formuliere es mal so. Seit dem 3-0 in Dresden, was vielleicht ja irgendwie als Derby durchgeht und deswegen vielleicht ein bisschen außer der Reihe tanzt, haben Sie eigentlich alle Spiele verloren, außer dem Spiel bei uns, was Sie 2 zu 1 in der letzten Minute gewonnen haben. Und das war halt auch ein Spiel, was die niemals gewinnen dürfen. Und auch dieses Tor in der letzten Minute darf nicht fallen. Wenn Mavendukš einfach mal zum Kopfball hochgegangen wäre, hätten wir nicht verloren. Und wenn man die zwei Punkte, also es geht unentschieden aus, einfach mal in der aktuellen Tabelle irgendwie noch denen ab und uns hinzuzieht, dann sind die halt letzter. Sportlich glaube ich, ist das das, was man da halt momentan in dieser Saison erreichen kann. Also ich sehe da ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass Aue sich noch sonderlich hoch entwickelt. Muss ich natürlich jetzt auch sagen, weil sonst wird es für uns langsam eng. Aber die stehen halt da zurecht und das ist kein Vorwurf.
Meiner Einschätzung von etwas weiter entfernt nach sieht man das aber in Aue auch genau so und ist dann dementsprechend so entspannt, wie man so in der Situation halt entspannt sein kann. Also Pavel Dvochev ja auch schon eine ganze Weile jetzt Trainer. Seit Juli letzten Jahres kam mir ehrlich gesagt länger vor. Habe ich dann doch nicht so richtig im Blick gehabt. Aber die gehen das schon auch mit einer gewissen Gelassenheit jetzt an, obwohl man da auf dem 17. Tabellenplatz steht.
Sie kennen ja die Situation auch nicht anders, oder? Also das ist ja glaube ich so der Punkt, also dass man das ja weiß, dass man total abhängig im Prinzip von dieser Führungsriege ist. Also sollten die jetzt irgendwie bei, das gab ja diesen Vorwurf irgendwie Fetternwirtschaft im Verein und so weiter und so fort, stelle ich mir vor, die würden halt diese Leonhard-Brüder schassen und so weiter. Ich meine, was passiert denn dann? Also das geht ja auch nicht. Also ich glaube, die kennen das halt nicht anders und die machen das und wenn sie drin bleiben, wunderbar. Und wenn nicht, dann nächstes Jahr wieder in der dritten Liga oben hoffentlich mitspielen.
Ja, glaube ich auch. Seit der Saison 2011, 2012 immer Tabellenplatz 15, 14 oder Abstieg, dann der direkte Wiederaufstieg und jetzt sind wir eben wieder hier unten. Besser fasst man das, ja die kennen das ja nicht zusammen. Und jetzt lieber Mike, kommen wir endlich, bzw. ich weiß gar nicht, ob du dich so wahnsinnig auf dieses Segment freust. Wir kommen jetzt zum FC St. Pauli. Jetzt hast endlich mal du mehr Redeanteile, du, der du vorhin teilweise sehr, sehr lange schweigen musstest. Du darfst oder musst mir jetzt erklären, was beim FC St. Pauli passiert ist, dass man jetzt nach 17 Spielen nur zwei Siege einfahren konnte, 11 Tore nur geschossen hat und mit 11 Punkten dann schon auch eine Punktesumme gesammelt hat, wo alleine das Verdoppeln in der Rückrunde nicht reichen würde, um den Abstieg zu verhindern. Was sind denn so die Punkte, die dazu geführt haben, dass der FC St. Pauli da steht, wo er jetzt steht?
Ich glaube, wenn ich es mir sehr einfach machen würde, würde ich einfach nur auf den ersten Spieler verweisen. Da haben wir beim VfB Stuttgart das Montagabendspiel gehabt und haben zur Halbzeit 1-0 geführt. Und man hätte schon zur Halbzeit 2-3-0 führen können. Und auch in der zweiten Halbzeit hatte man noch Chancen, das nächste Tor zu machen. Unter anderem dann in der zweiten Halbzeit einen Ball an die Latte. Und aus dem Konter entsteht dann der Ausgleich durch Maximo. Und in der Nachspielzeit verlieren wir dann durch ein Tor von Gentner 2-1. Ich glaube, wenn wir dieses Spiel, was absolut drin gewesen und auch verdient gewesen wäre, gewonnen hätten, dann hätten wir jetzt nicht drei Punkte mehr, sondern hätten wir wahrscheinlich 9 oder 12 oder 15 Punkte mehr und würden ungefähr dastehen, wo man uns dann auch erwartet hätte. Und dann nahm die Saison halt einen gänzlich anderen Verlauf. Wir haben dann das zweite Spiel zu Hause gegen Braunschweig gehabt, was wir verdient verloren haben, was wir wahrscheinlich auch bei einem Sieg in Stuttgart hätten verdient verlieren können. Aber du stehst dann halt in der zweiten Liga nach zwei Spielen mit null Punkten da, fährst dann nach Dresden, wo wir an dem Tag vielleicht mit mehr Punkten auf dem Konto auch anders aufgetreten wären, als wir es dann da taten, verloren da erneut. Und so kommst du halt sehr schnell in diesen Negativlauf und befindest dich in einer Tabellensituation, die du als Mannschaft, als Verein einfach so vor der Saison nicht hast kommen sehen. Und ich kann da nur nochmals meinen Verein dahingehend loben, dass man da sehr, sehr lange Zeit völlig die Ruhe bewahrt hat, was ich auch zu einem großen Teil dem aktuellen Präsidium zuschreiben möchte. Und ja, inzwischen steht man eben nach 17 Spielen, wie du sagst, mit 11 Punkten da und muss eigentlich eine Rückrunde mit fast dem Doppelten dessen erreichen, was man jetzt gemacht hat. Also wenn wir nochmal 20 Punkte holen, dann hätten wir 31. Das könnte auch schon durchaus zu wenig sein. Also es muss deutlich mehr werden. Und trotzdem, wenn man sich da unten anschaut, ich glaube Aua hat den Trainer auch nicht entlassen. Das war es dann aber auch alle anderen, sowohl in Liga 2, die unten stehen, als auch in Liga 1. Die letzten sechs oder sieben Teams haben alle ihren Trainer entlassen. Und bei uns sitzt immer noch Evalin auf der Trainerbank. Das kann jetzt einige gut, einige schlecht finden. Ich bin da grundsätzlich immer noch von überzeugt, dass es eine gute Entscheidung war. Ich finde aber auch, dass es sehr, sehr gut war, in der Zwischenzeit Olaf Jansen geholt zu haben. Da komme ich dann vielleicht gleich nochmal drauf. Zurück zu der Frage, warum das überhaupt so gekommen ist. Neben dem ersten Spiel, was sehr unglücklich verlaufen ist, haben wir halt auch in der Folge der Saison oftmals Pech gehabt. Wir haben ein ziemliches Verletzungspech gehabt. Die ersten 16 Spiele hatten wir immer eine andere Anfangsformation. Und das nicht, weil Linen so rotierfreudig war, sondern weil es tatsächlich in den allermeisten Fällen irgendeinen Verletzten gab, der im letzten Spiel noch gespielt hat oder dann gesperrt war oder sonst irgendwas. Insbesondere in der Viererkette gab es, ich glaube, hat es bis zum 13. oder 14. Spieltag gedauert, bis wir das erste Mal mit derselben Viererkette auflaufen konnten. Und das war ja in den letzten anderthalb Jahren oder zwei Jahren, seit Linen da ist, immer die Stärke des FC St. Pauli, defensiv gut zu stehen, mit einer sehr guten Viererkette, insbesondere Philipp Ziereis, Lasse Sobich in der Innenverteidigung, auch gut dazustehen und dann eben, wenn hinten die Null steht, vorne mindestens eins zu machen. Und das ist halt dieses Jahr überhaupt nicht gelungen. Also im letzten Jahr hatten wir glaube ich 16 Spiele zu Null. Dieses Jahr gab es dann am 15. Spiele hat das Null zu Null überhaupt das erste Mal, dass wir zu Null gespielt haben. Und in der Kaderplanung, gut, ich bin jetzt nicht so der Fußballfachmann, aber es gibt halt ja doch einige, die sich da besser auskennen und die dann eben sagen, da ist viel schief gelaufen. Thomas Meckle wurde dementsprechend ja auch im Verlauf der Saison bei uns geschasst, als Verantwortlicher auf dem Managerstuhl. Wenn man sich allein die Abgänge anguckt, bleibe ich dabei. Da ist nicht so viel Substanz verloren worden. Also es ist Marc Schatowsky gegangen, der bei Raba Salzburg jetzt spielt. Der fehlt wirklich an allen Ecken und Enden. Den konnte man auch nicht adäquat ersetzen. Man hatte gehofft, dass Christopher Buchmann so ein bisschen in die Rolle reinschlüpft. Das ging zum Ende hin auch ein bisschen besser, bis er sich dann leider auch am Endeskurs verletzt hat. Im Sturm ist Lennart Thi gegangen. Spoiler, den haben wir jetzt zurückgeholt gestern. Also zumindest bis Sonnende wird er von Werder wieder ausgeliehen. Den, finde ich, aber haben wir mit Asis Buaduz nahezu deckungsgleich ersetzt, wenn wir uns nicht sogar verbessert haben. Und ansonsten gingen halt noch Ines Alouchi. Da weint nicht wirklich jemanden die Träne hinterher. Und in Nürnberg würden sich inzwischen, glaube ich, auch wünschen, sie hätten ihn nicht geholt. Und Sebastian Maier, das ist etwas, was tatsächlich sportlich, glaube ich, sehr weh tat und was man vielleicht vor der Saison ein bisschen unterschätzt hat, den man da eben nicht ersetzt hat. Ansonsten war es viel Verletzungspech, ein, zwei unglückliche Entscheidungen im Elfmeterbereich für oder gegen uns. Dumme Eigentore, die wir uns gefangen haben, weil man eben dann da unten drin steht und dann eben diese Spirale, die so eine Zweitliga-Saison bei einem schlechten Saisonstart eben sehr schnell nimmt. Und unterm Strich haben wir letztes Jahr als vierte abgeschlossen, vielleicht ein paar Plätze zu gut oder besser, als wir von der Leistung her hätten tatsächlich da stehen sollen. Und genauso sehe ich das diese Saison auch. Ich glaube, von der Leistung her müssen wir nicht auf Platz 18 stehen. Klar ist auch, wir stehen nicht auf Platz 4. Aber wir können schon vier, fünf Plätze besser stehen, wenn uns da der Fußballgott ein bisschen gewogener gewesen wäre.
Gut, das ist aber leider häufig so, wenn man unten im Keller steht und der Konjunktiv rettet dich ja nicht vom Abstieg. Es gab einen Moment in der Saison, wo ich gedacht habe, jetzt dreht sich das Ganze. Das mit dem Auftakt, mit dem unglücklichen Verlauf des ersten Spiels und den Folgen daraus, da stimme ich dir zu. Mir ist es aber ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu einfach. Du hast es ja auch selbst schon so abgefangen, hast du es selber so formuliert, das auf die komplette Hinrunde zu beziehen. Denn es gab ja dann den Sieg gegen Arminia Bielefeld zuhause, danach zwei Unentschieden. Die hätten zwar nicht unbedingt unentschieden sein müssen gegen den KSC und 1860, aber immerhin waren das mal fünf Punkte, die man da geholt hat. Und dann war es natürlich schwierig, auswärts bei Union, auswärts bei Hannover, aber dann fiel man wieder zurück in diesen Trott. Und was mir so gefehlt hat die ganze Zeit bei St. Pauli war, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, da kommt jetzt ein Impuls, der wahrscheinlich, meiner Meinung nach, vom Trainer kommen müsste, der richtig etwas verändert. Also dann machen wir eben einfach mal die Schotten hinten dicht und wir spielen halt dreimal in Folge 0 zu 0, so wie es andere Kandidaten da unten drin gemacht haben. Das ist dann auch nicht schön, aber immerhin sind das schon mal ein paar Punkte. Und ich hatte immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck, welche Hebel hat Ewald Lin noch, die er ansetzen kann? Gerade eben auch angesichts dieser Probleme hinsichtlich Verletzten.
Ja, also zum einen, wie du schon sagst, das Spiel gegen Bielefeld wurde dann ja auch so gewonnen, dass man das tatsächlich hätte als Startsignal nehmen können, nämlich mit einem Tor in der Nachspielzeit, der das Stadion im Dach heben lässt. Holst dann eben das, was ich vorhin schon sagte, in Karlsruhe ein Spiel, ein Punkt, wo du eigentlich gewinnen musst und dich einfach dumm anstellst und dumm anstellen könnte halt auch echt explizit die Saisonüberschrift sein bei uns. Holst dann noch einen Heimpunkt gegen 60, wo man auch hätte gewinnen können, aber gut. Und dann stehst du halt vor zwei Auswärtsspielen bei Union, bei Hannover, wo du realistisch nichts holen kannst, wo wir in Union auch glaube ich tatsächlich chancenlos waren und völlig verdient 2-0 verloren haben. Das hat Linen so ein bisschen in der Pressekonferenz anders dargestellt, weil wir natürlich ja, das durch individuelle Fehler begünstigt haben, dass da Union die Tore geschossen hat. Aber Union musste halt danach auch nicht mehr viel tun, sondern konnte das zu Ende verwalten. Das haben sie sehr souverän gemacht. Und ich erinnere mich an die Diskussion im Textilvergehen, dass diese individuellen Fehler von uns halt auch erzwungen wurden durch das Spiel von Union. Und genauso war es ja auch. Und auch das Spiel in Hannover, da spielen wir im Vergleich zum Spiel bei Union recht gut. Verlieren dann nachher durch einen Standard, den wir schlecht verteidigen, in einer 75. Minute. Bis dahin hatten wir ganz gut mitgespielt. Ja, verlieren dann dumm gegen Aue, sind chancenlos in Sandhausen. Und das war dann der Punkt. Also nach dem zehnten Spieltag hat Evald Wien ja diese doch sehr viel beachtete Pressekonferenz gezogen, wo er quasi Holger Schalewski das immer als Gesetzknopf drücken bezeichnet, die Saison nochmal neu gestartet hat, seine Spiele aufgerüttelt hat. Ja, und da weiß ich halt nicht so recht, ob das der beste Zeitpunkt war, weil das war der Zeitpunkt vor dem Pokalspiel gegen Hertha, wo eigentlich schon absehbar war, selbst wenn wir einen guten Tag erwischen, werden wir da nichts reißen. Wir haben dann ein Zeichen gesetzt, wie es immer so schön heißt. Das Spiel war relativ gut, wir haben 2-0 verloren, aber es war so was, wo man sagt, ok, wenn da der tabellenletzte der zweiten Liga gegen den, ich weiß nicht, zweiten oder dritten der ersten Liga zu der Zeit spielt, dann war das schon eine ganz annehmbare Leistung, für die kannst du dir aber halt auch nichts kaufen. Und diesen Punkt zu setzen vor dem Spiel war halt vielleicht nicht ganz so richtig. Dann kam danach ein halbes Spiel gegen Nürnberg, was ganz nett war, was uns aber Guido Burgstaller ein bisschen versaut hat, dadurch nur 1-1. Dann kam ein Spiel, wo wir in Würzburg gespielt haben, wo eigentlich aus meiner Sicht genau das gemacht wurde, was du gesagt hast, da wurde endlich mal versucht, hinten kompakt zu stehen. Aber das kannst du dann auch keinem erzählen, sowohl das Spiel gegen Würzburg als auch das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf, spielen zwei Mannschaften auf Augenhöhe jeweils und beide Spiele verlieren wir 1-0 durch den Eigentor. Also das kommt dann halt, wenn du 18er bist. Und gerade das in Würzburg, da kommt halt Brian Koglin, ein ganz junger Mann, der bisher noch A-Jugend und die Saison U23 gespielt hat, spielt aus meiner Sicht wirklich sehr gut in dieser völlig verunsicherten Abwehr und drischt dann in der, ich weiß nicht mehr, 85., 87. Minute im Befreiungsschlag, schießt er den eigenen Mann an und von daher kullert der Ball ins Tor. Das sind so Tore, die fängst du halt nur, wenn du da unten stehst. Ich glaube auch, dieses Momentum, was Evalin da auslösen wollte, hätte er vielleicht besser vor einem anderen Spiel gemacht als vor diesem Pokalspiel. Ich glaube aber auch, er musste es zu dem Zeitpunkt schon fast machen, weil er da so angeschossen war, was dann im weiteren Verlauf auch irgendwann zur Beurlaubung von Thomas Meggle führte. Und ja, Kristallkugel hätte ich gerne. Ich bin immer noch verhältnismäßig entspannt. Was natürlich in erster Linie dadurch begründet ist, du hast jetzt elf Punkte und müsstest eigentlich sieben, acht, neun Punkte Rückstand haben aufs rettende Ufer. Hast aber tatsächlich nur drei auf den direkten Klassenerhalt, weil alle anderen auch so unfassbar schlecht dastehen, dass du halt immer noch sagst, okay, wenn wir jetzt mal zwei, drei Spiele in Folge gewinnen, sind wir da auch schnell raus. Das Problem, und damit bin ich jetzt auch wieder beim Rückrundenspielplan, ist, du spielst erst mal zuhause gegen Stuttgart und dann in Braunschweig. Also das, was wir am Anfang gesagt haben, mit naja, gut, unglücklicher Start, holt uns jetzt halt wieder ein, weil wir haben auch einen unglücklichen Rückrundenbeginn, logischerweise. Und wenn du die beiden Spiele verlierst und die anderen dementsprechenden Punkten, hast du dann vielleicht schon wieder sechs, sieben Punkte Rückstand aus Rettende Ufer, spielst dann zuhause gegen Dresden, in Bielefeld, gegen Karlsruhe, in 60. Also ich glaube, nach dem 60-Spiel, das ist der 4. März, da sollten wir bitte, wenn irgend möglich, auf dem Nicht-Abstiegsplatz stehen, oder zumindest punktgleich irgendwie sein, weil danach spielen wir dann gegen Union. Das Gute ist, gegen Union ist eigentlich eine fest verabredete Sache zwischen Sebastian und mir. Wir gewinnen die Heimspiele, die gewinnen ihre Heimspiele. Von daher schauen wir mal.
Wie oft haben sich denn die Mannschaften bisher da drin gehalten?
Ja, ich muss jetzt mal Fußballdaten aufrufen.
Das gibt mir mal die Macht von Podcasts, liebe Hörer.
Ja, wirklich glücklich sind wir beide damit nicht, aber es geht halt immer einigermaßen aus.
Ich habe mal eine Frage. Also diese Nummer, also man hält jetzt an Evalin fest, soweit ich das verstanden habe. Und das bleibt dann auch nach dem schweren Rückrundenstart so. Bist du dir sicher irgendwie? Weil ich hatte so ein paar Momente in dieser Saison und tatsächlich die Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel hier in Berlin von Evalin war so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, was erzählt der Trainer dort eigentlich? Also das war so, ich habe es nicht verstanden, weil es halt, also jeder hat gesehen, dass St. Pauli keine wirkliche Chance hatte und Evalin hat dieses Spiel dann auf individuelle Fehler reduziert und deswegen hätte man verloren. Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Und ich habe einfach nur den Eindruck gehabt, irgendwie will er jetzt irgendwie die Mannschaft schützen, und es nicht so schlecht reden, wie es halt vielleicht war.
Ja, wüsste ich auch gerne. Also ich habe in vielen Pressekonferenzen diese Saison bei ihm das Gefühl gehabt, ich hoffe, dass das, was er da jetzt nach außen sagt, nicht das ist, was er nach innen kommuniziert. Denke halt auch, in vielen Situationen wollte er wahrscheinlich wirklich die Mannschaft schützen. Kann gut sein. Ob er jetzt nach mal gesetztem Fall, wir verlieren die beiden Spiele, was ja nicht völlig ausgeschlossen ist bei den beiden Gegnern, immer noch Trainer sein wird, keine Ahnung. Ich würde das momentan dezent bejahen, also vermute, dass es so ist. Aber dann wird es natürlich die Frage sein, wie viele Spiele dann noch. Wenn du dann gegen Dresden zu Hause auch wieder verlierst, spätestens dann wird es eng. Nochmal, was ich eben schon andeutete, ich bin sehr davon angetan, wie sich die Mannschaft in den letzten Wochen entwickelt hat. Und das schreibe ich dann auch zu einem Großteil Olaf Jansen zu. Auf dem Platz sieht man das natürlich immer nur in kleinen Details. Zum Beispiel die Standards haben sich klar verändert. Das ist so eine Baustelle, die Jansen in letzter Zeit angefasst hat. Es ist auch noch nicht so, dass wir deswegen jetzt alle Spiele gewinnen, weil wir zehn Standards pro Spiel reinhauen. Aber man hat zumindest mal wieder das Gefühl, ok, da tut sich was. Und ich finde ja auch immer die Position des Trainers, aus meiner Sicht, wird auch oftmals überschätzt, weil natürlich ist es nicht der Trainer. Auch bei Bayern ist es nicht der Pep Guardiola, sondern es ist immer ein Team von vier, fünf Leuten. Und wenn man dann sieht, dass in den letzten zwei Jahren bei uns das Team um Ewald Lin mit Co-Trainer, Torwart-Trainer etc. ja doch sehr viel rausgeholt hat, kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass dieses Team jetzt in 4,4 oder 5 Köpfen bestehen, auf einmal alles falsch macht und gar keine Ahnung mehr hat und alles schief läuft. Also von daher, ich glaube, mit der Verpflichtung von Olaf Jansen wurde viel Gutes angestoßen und hoffe jetzt einfach, dass man diesem Team die Gelegenheit gibt, das auch sauber zu Ende zu spielen und sie dann eben auch vom Erfolg dann da bestätigt werden. Es gab jetzt, vielleicht das werden nicht alle mitgekriegt haben, es gab jetzt am Wochenjahr das Halbspiel gegen Bochum und danach gab es eine Pressemitteilung des Vereins, in der zu einer Pressekonferenz am Sonntag, also am Tag drauf geladen wurde. Das sorgte quasi sofort in den Medien für die Diskussion oder die Gerüchteküche Oha, Ewa Lin tritt zurück. Bei der Pressekonferenz sollten auf dem Podium sitzen unser Präsident Uge Göttlich, Andreas Rettig als sportlicher Leiter und eben Ewa Linen. Und man hatte da schon so ein bisschen erwartet, Linen wird da seinen Drücktritt bekannt geben, Olaf Jansen konstituieren als neuen Chefcoach. Das war auch bei seiner Verpflichtung sofort das Gerücht Nummer eins, dass Olaf Jansen auf lange Sicht dann neuer Trainer wird und nur die Frage ist, wann wird das umgesetzt? Und dann wurde am Sonntagvormittag diese Pressekonferenz abgesagt und daraufhin schossen dann die Spekulationen endgültig ins Kraut und es gab keine Konstellation, die nicht in den Hamburger Medien irgendwie von der einen oder anderen Zeitung diskutiert wurde. Unter dem Strich hat Andreas Rettig dem ja dann jetzt einen Riegel vorgeschoben und dann nochmal vor Weihnachten bekannt gegeben, nee nee, alles gut, wir werden auch nach der Winterpause weiterhin mit Ivaldin auf dem Trainerposten arbeiten. Er hat das ja auch während der Saison immer nach vorne geschoben, dass er sagt, wir vertrauen diesem Trainer und wenn wir das anders sehen würden, hätten wir längst schon gehandelt. Und ich habe Andreas Rettig jetzt ja auch kennenlernen dürfen in dem längeren Müllantongespräch, wo er bei uns zu Gast war. Das nehme ich ihm auch ab. Und auch dem Präsidium nehme ich ab, dass da eine gewisse Konstanz gewollt ist und dann wirklich so lange wie möglich auch an Ivaldinen als Trainer festhalten wird. Und man kann ja viel vom Kultclub-Gelaber und so immer denken. Und das kann mich auch noch so sehr stören, aber ich glaube, dass Ivaldinen tatsächlich diesen Verein gefunden hat und das Ganze zusammenpasst wie Arsch auf Eimer. Und ich hoffe halt, dass wenn vielleicht trainertechnisch da nicht mehr bis ins letzte Prozent alles rausgekitzelt werden kann von ihm, dass dann halt Olaf Jansen jetzt dafür der richtige Mann ist, das so zu ergänzen, dass dann am Ende alles gut wird. Und alles gut heißt natürlich in der Saison irgendwie, wenn möglich Platz 15 oder im schlimmsten Fall Platz 16 plus zwei Verlängerungsspiele.
Ist das nicht schon so? Also wer hat ihn denn geholt? Jetzt die Vereinsführung oder hat Lien ihn geholt zu sich im Team? Und also weil das sieht ja schon merklich aus, wenn man einen Co-Trainer mitten in der Saison neue hinzu holt. Also klingt für mich sei das irgendwie so ein bisschen aus, als ob man Lien jemand, wie du es vorhin schon gesagt hast, an die Seite gestellt hat, der im 2-2 übernehmen kann. Und das ist ja nicht das, was eigentlich so die Position eines Chefs irgendwie gegenüber eines Teams verstärkt.
Ja, was vielleicht dann da auch noch als Name einmal fallen sollte, ist Abdaram Dane, der war ja bisher Co-Trainer, ist das auch weiterhin, hat aber natürlich eine große Historie mit Ivalin, die arbeiten ja seit Jahren zusammen. In grauer Vorzeit war das auch mal sein Schwiegersohn. Die sind aber inzwischen, also Ivalins Tochter und Ramdane sind wieder getrennt. Also das ist aktuell keine familiäre Bande mehr. Aber die beiden haben natürlich ewig zusammengearbeitet. Und das wirkte natürlich jetzt auch als quasi Entmachtung von Ramdane, dass ihm da jetzt ein Co-Trainer vor die Nase gesetzt wurde. Und tatsächlich ist auch in der Außenwirkung Ramdane deutlich zurückgefahren worden. Er sitzt jetzt auch nicht mal mehr auf der Bank, er sitzt jetzt auf der Tribüne, was natürlich in der Außenwirkung komisch war, was man aber intern jetzt kommuniziert hat mit, ne ne, das ist schon richtig, weil er sieht ja von oben auch viel besser und kann dann Input geben in der Halbzeit und so weiter und so fort. Also auch das nachvollziehbare Gründe. Es war aber so, dass bei Lienens Verpflichtung damals, er folgte ja auf Thomas Meckle als Trainer, woraufhin Meckle dann eben in den Manager-Posten gehoben wurde. Auch da war es ja so, dass es im Hintergrund schon Workshops gab, wo das Präsidium eben mit verschiedenen Leuten extern sich immer mal wieder Input holte und sagte, wir gehen jetzt mal andere Wege, als das im Fußballverein eigentlich der Fall ist. Und da war eben einer dieser Workshop-Teilnehmer Evaldine. Und als dann die Trainerposition vakant wurde, weil man das Gefühl hatte, mit Thomas Werkele geht das so nicht weiter und Thomas das wohl auch ähnlich selber formuliert hat, konnte man eben aus diesem Workshop heraus sagen, wir holen jetzt den, der uns da am besten gefallen hat. Und das war in dem Fall eben Evaldine. Ob es da jetzt sowas Ähnliches auch gab, weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, wäre totale Spekulation. Würde mich auch eher wundern, weil Olaf Jansen halt ja noch in Lohn und Brot stand beim VfB Stuttgart. Aber grundsätzlich glaube ich schon, dass man sich auch in den letzten Monaten immer mal wieder Gedanken gemacht hat. Was können wir verändern? Wie können wir uns anders aufstellen? Und ob da jetzt Rettich am Ende das entscheidende Wort gesprochen hat oder Lienen, also ich tendiere da eher zu Rettich, aber Evaldine hat sich bisher in jeder Frage, die ihm gestellt wurde in Richtung Olaf Jansen, ausnahmslos absolut positiv über Olaf Jansen geäußert und das klang auch nicht nach, das muss ich jetzt sagen, sondern das klang schon sehr überzeugt, dass der uns da weiterbringt.
Ja, danke für die Nachfrage auch, Sebastian. Genau dieselbe Frage habe ich mir nämlich auch gestellt bei der ganzen Kauser Jansen und auch die hier zum Mehrfach angesprochene Pressekonferenz fand ich damals sehr interessant. Ich stelle mir tatsächlich die Frage, das vielleicht so ein bisschen abschließend mit dem Blick dann auch in die Zukunft, was sich sportlich tatsächlich ändern kann. Also wenn ich mir den vorhandenen Kader anschaue, wenn ich mir ansehe, wie die Spiele gelaufen sind, und ich gebe dir vollkommen recht, sehr, sehr viel Unglück mit dabei, aber das hilft ja nichts. Also der Blick nach hinten hilft mit der Erkenntnis, wir hatten Pech, hilft ja nicht mit dem Blick dann wieder nach vorne zu wenden, sondern man muss ja auch schon andere Dinge abstellen. Man kann ja zum Beispiel auch einfach versuchen, den Ball aus gewissen Zonen, in denen häufig dann Tore auch unglücklich fein rauszuhalten, das ist jetzt ein bisschen arg vereinfacht, und das ist natürlich auch nicht alles so trivial, aber ich stelle mir eben wirklich die Frage, Mike, was kann sich denn sportlich verändern? Muss man da vielleicht nochmal die Grundordnung verändern? War 4-2-3-1, dann war es mal 4-1-4-1, damit wurden jetzt dann zuletzt ja auch dann 5 Punkte geholt in den letzten drei Spielen. Was sind da noch so die Möglichkeiten, die du siehst jetzt mit Blick dann auf die Rückrunde?
Ah, ehrlich gesagt habe ich ja von Taktik viel zu wenig Ahnung, um das jetzt hier fundiert beantworten zu können. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass wenn alle Spieler fit sind, dann muss sich gar nicht so furchtbar viel verändern, weil dann würden wir wieder mit Philipp Ziereis und Lasse Sobich eine Innenverteidigung haben, mit Robin Himmelmann im Tor. Das würde schon funktionieren und das würde auch genug Punkte geben. Mag sein, dass das total naiv ist und ihr beide mich jetzt auslacht, aber ich glaube diese defensive Grundordnung war immer die Stärke von den Teams von Evaldin und das glaube ich ist auch tatsächlich die Bank, auf der wir die Rückgründe aufbauen müssen. Natürlich sagen alle, wir brauchen jetzt noch jemanden für das offensive Mittelfeld, weil da einfach nach dem Weggang von Schatkowski, der aber Klammer auf letztes Jahr auch eher auf der Sechs gespielt hat, nicht entsprechend nachgerüstet wurde. Und ja, sehe ich auch so. Ich glaube, was uns noch tatsächlich gestern eine sehr gute Nachricht war, neben der Verpflichtung von Lennarty ist, dass Assis Boaduz nicht zum Afrika Cup fährt. Das war so ein bisschen das Damoklesschwert, was noch über uns hing in den letzten Wochen. Der wurde jetzt von Marokko einfach nicht eingeladen, was für ihn natürlich sehr tragisch ist, weil er in seinem Alter auch lange darauf gewartet hat und jetzt erst vor kurzem so an die Nationalmannschaft gerückt ist, was uns natürlich unheimlich hilft. Der hat halt von Elftor und hat R5 gemacht. Wenn der nicht da wäre, wäre es nochmal schwieriger gewesen. Jetzt bleibt er zum Glück und kann dann die komplette Vorbereitung mitmachen, weil er ein sehr physischer Spieler ist, glaube ich auch sehr wichtig für ihn. Und dann zusammen mit Lennarty haben wir, glaube ich, einen ganz guten Kader. Und wir haben auch auf den Außen, das war eigentlich das Fund vor der Saison, dass ich gedacht habe, wir werden eine ähnlich gute Rolle spielen. Rio Miyahichi, Walde Masopota, Cengiz Sahin sind alles Leute, die auf den Außen ein unheimliches Tempo und mit sehr viel Ballsicherheit auch kombiniert bringen können, sodass das mir im Offensivspiel eigentlich auch schon reichen würde und man gar nicht unbedingt den zentralen Zehner da jetzt braucht, der das Spiel macht. Ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich glaube, wenn da auf der Zehne noch jemand geholt wird, wenn Christopher Wuchtmann dann auch wieder auf der Sechs wieder fit ist nach seiner Knieverletzung und man dann eben vielleicht einfach ein bisschen mehr Glück hat, sollte das schon reichen. Es kann aber sein, dass wir dann am Ende der Saison hier sitzen und alle sagen, Gott, Krückermeier, warst du blauäugig.
Naja gut, aber man kann ja auch nichts gegen seine Gefühle tun. Mich freut es aus freundschaftlichen Aspekten auch, dass dir das nicht so nahe geht und dass du dann noch relativ gelassen bist. Das wünsche ich allen meinen Fußballfreunden. Das soll bitte allen so gehen und vielleicht hast du ja auch recht. Und dann bin ich mal sehr gespannt und würde mich ja sehr freuen, wenn wir dann nach der Saison wieder zusammensitzen, so wie es mich jetzt gefreut hat, dass ihr euch heute unfassbar viel Zeit für diese Aufnahme genommen habt, ihr beiden. Ich kann gar nicht genug betonen, wie toll es ist, dass ihr euch diese Zeit genommen habt. Liebe Hörer, ich kann euch so viel verraten, auch wenn die Aufnahme kürzer ist. Wir sitzen jetzt in der Konstellation schon seit über 5 Stunden am Rechner mit einem ganz kurzen Puls zwischendurch. Das ist wirklich großartig, dass ich immer wieder Gäste finde, die das machen. Vielen, vielen Dank euch beiden dafür. Folgt bitte Sebastian und hört das Textilvergehen. Das habe ich jetzt schon so oft gesagt. Wenn ihr es immer noch nicht gemacht habt, dann werde ich auch langsam sauer. Add Saumselig bei Twitter und add Textilvergehen und hört natürlich auch den Millern-Ton. Wenn ihr nicht wisst, mit welcher Folge ihr einsteigen wollt, dieses benannte Gespräch von Andreas Rettig. Die Folge kann ich euch sehr ans Herz legen. Ich hatte auch damals eine Schlusskonferenz empfohlen. Ich werde es auch noch mal in den Show notes verlinken. Das ist, glaube ich, ein sehr guter Einstieg, aber der Millern-Ton lohnt sich eh. Und Mike, könnt ihr folgen, oft wird der Add der Übersteiger. Vielen Dank, Mike. Und in diesem Sinne, liebe Hörer, haben wir es alle gemeinsam hinter uns gebracht. Wir haben eine Zweitligaschlusskonferenz gehört. Hinterlasst mir Feedback, wie ihr es fandet, ob das euch tief genug war oder dann doch an manchen Stellen da Max ein bisschen inhaltlich zu sehr gewackelt hat. Die Gäste ja sowieso eh nicht. Ohne die wäre ich vollkommen aufgeschmissen gewesen, meine Güte. In diesem Sinne wünsche ich euch frohe Weihnachten. Das wird auch gleich noch mal Berti Vogts für mich unternehmen. Und wir hören uns dann im Rasenfunk-Royal zur ersten Liga. Macht's gut, ciao.
Ein bisschen mehr Freude und weniger Streit, ein bisschen mehr Güte und weniger Neid, ein bisschen mehr Liebe und weniger Hass, ein bisschen mehr Wahrheit, das wäre doch was. Ich wünsche euch eine frohe Weihnacht und vor allen Dingen uns allen Gesundheit und Glück und ein gutes Miteinander 1994. Danke.